O'CLOCK. AND WE'RE WAITING FOR
A FEW MORE MINUTES FOR THE
MEMBERS OF PUBLIC SAFETY
ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY OF TO.
COME TO THE CAN ROOM. THE.
GOOD
AFTERNOON IS NOW TWO OH FIVE
AND WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN THE
ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REGGIE JONES SAWYER CHAIRED A
COMMITTEE- AND THERE'S A LONG
LIST OF IN THIS NEW CORPORATE
ENVIRONMENT NEED TO READ STOP.
ARE WE GOING TO BE WITH THIS
MEETING SO BEAR WITH ME AS I GO
THROUGH ABOUT. TWO PAGES OF
INSTRUCTION. WELCOME TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE OUR PUBLIC
OUR PUBLIC SAFETY. DUE TO THE
CAN STAY AT HOME ORDER WE'RE
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCING
HIS. MMHM AT THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING SO WE ARE ONLY
ABLE. TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WHY AND PARTICIPATE
IN HEARING ROOM IN HERE IN
HEARING IN PERSON WE'RE ALL
REQUIRING THAT MAP MOORE AND
THE COULD DISTANCE. BE MAY BY
ALL OF THE PUBLIC TESTIFYING.
WHAT HERE IN THE OR AT THE VERY
CONFERENCING SITE. IF YOU DO
NOT HAVE A MASK WE CAN PROVIDE
ONE FOR YOU. WE HAVE A FEW
DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR WITNESS
TESTIMONY TUESDAY. THE PUBLIC
IN THE ROOM. TODAY IN ROOM.
FOUR TWO ZERO TWO FORTY TWO OH
TWO WE CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE A
MINIMAL CONTINGENT OF STAFF AND
A LIMITED NUMBER OF LOOKS AND
MEDIA SO WE CAN MAINTAIN SIX
SPACING. SOCIAL PHYSICAL
DISTANCE. TO THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAP FOR THE
HERE IN THE ROOM. IF ANY MAN
THE PUBLIC IN THE- LIKE TO
TESTIFY ON A BILL. PLEASE RAISE
YOUR HAND AND I WILL ASK YOU TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. I WOULD ASK
THAT THE PUBLIC NOT TOUCHED A
MICROPHONE. YOU COULD EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU ARE DONE
TESTIFYING OR RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT. YOUR TO OBSERVE-
DISTANCING UPON LEAVING THE
CAPITAL. INCLUDING LIMITING
LIMITING ELEVATOR USE AT ONE
PERSON AT A TIME. FOR W. V. R.
N. R. T. S. WITNESSES. IN
ADDITION TO BEING ABLE TO
TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE HEARING
ROOM. WE HAVE SOME BUILT
WITNESSES MAKING USE OF ONE OF
OUR WITNESS VIDEO CONFERENCING
ROOM. WVIR WHICH ARE LOCATED
HERE IN THE CAPITAL. OUR REMOTE
SIMONI STATIONS RTS LOCATED ON
THE CAPITOL GROUNDS AND THER
LOCATIONS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THOSE WITNESSES WILL APPEAR ON
THE SCREEN SO MEMBERS CAN WATCH
THEIR TESTIMONY. LIVE FROM
OUTSIDE OF THE HEARING ROOM.
ASK HIM QUESTIONS. FOR DIALING
WHAT. WILL ALSO BE USING A
MODERATE IT TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH ANY WITNESS CAN
TESTIFY ON A BILL. THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THE HEARING IS.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. LET ME
SAY THAT AGAIN. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
TWO- TO ONCE AGAIN. THAT'S ONE
THREE. ONE FIVE FOUR TWO OH TWO
YOU CAN ALL FOR US NUMBER ON
THE ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL ON
YOUR TV'S AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV
SCREEN. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASED TO DO SO AS THE AUTHOR
OF THE BILL YOUR TESTIFYING ON
IS BEGINNING THEY'RE BUILT
TATIAN. THE OPERATOR ON. WILL
GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO
PLACE HOW TO BE PLACED IN QUEUE
BASED ON WHETHER YOU YOU
SUPPORT. ARE YOU OPPOSE A BILL
IF YOU'RE CALLING IN PLEASE
ELIMINATING THIS IS REAL
IMPORTANT PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
MUTING YOUR LIVESTREAM
BROADCAST AND YOUR SMART
DEVICES TO REDUCE THE SOUND OF
DISTORTION. PLEASE ALSO BE
DIVIDE PLEASE ALSO BE ADVISED
IF YOU ARE A MAIN WITNESS OR-
WRITING TESTIMONY FOR OR
AGAINST THE BILL. YOU REMAIN ON
A LIFELINE AND WILL NEED TO
MEET YOURSELF UNTIL YOU ARE
CALLED ON TO SPEAK. IF YOU'RE
HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE
MODERATED PHONE SERVICE. YOU
CAN CALL THE COMMITTEE AT NINE
ONE SIX. THREE ONE NINE THREE
SEVEN FOUR FOUR AGAIN. NINE ONE
SIX THREE ONE NINE THREE SEVEN
FOUR FOUR AND MY STAFF WILL BE
THERE TO TRY TO HELP. NOTE THAT
WE ARE ACCEPTING TESTIMONY.
THROUGH THE LETTER POOR HONORED
COMMITTEES. THANK YOU FOR
BEARING. THANK YOU FOR WITH US.
AS WE IMPLEMENT MATHIS TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC'S HEALTH CONCERNS WE ALL
FACE TODAY. MADAM SECRETARY I
BELIEVE WE HAVE A QUORUM NOW
CALDERON. HERE. BACKING IN.
KAMLAGER WORK FOR YEAH. YEAH
RIGHT HERE I'M HERE. THE
PERFECT. WHAT DO I PUSH. IS
THAT THE ONE. YES. OKAY DO YOU
NEED TO DO THAT AGAIN I THINK
WORK IF YOU CAN JUST ENOUGH OF
A QUORUM IS PRESENT. THANK YOU
MADAM SECRETARY TO. NOW
PRESIDENT. BOB. TODAY AND IF
YOU HAVE I WOULD LIKE THIS MAY
ASSEMBLY. STONE FOR SEVEN FOUR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS. THE OFF
CALENDAR FOLLOWING UP ARMS WILL
NOT BE HEARD TODAY. S. B. THREE
SIX NINE HERTZBERG AND SB SEVEN
THREE ONE BRADFORD WILL BE
GOING THROUGH THESE MEASURES
TODAY AN ALPHABETICAL ORDER
HOWEVER. WE WILL START WITH
MISTER KING AB THIRTY TWO
THIRTY FOUR AND OF THE BUDGET
YEAR SHE TEAM YOU MAY NOW
APPROACH. MISTER KING ALSO HAS.
YOU HAVE WITNESSES TO I BELIEVE.
MISTER CHANG. WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AT
THIRTY TO THIRTY FOUR GIVES
JUDGES THE DISCRETION ALLOW
INDIVIDUALS CHARGED WITH
MISDEMEANORS TO TAKE PART IN A
DIVERSION PROGRAM. HE WOULD
ALSO CHANGE THE ELIGIBILITY.
FIFTY YEARS OLD. TWENTY FIVE TO
TWENTY YEARS OLD NOTHING IN
THIS BILL ALLOWS FOR THE
AUTOMATIC RELEASE OF PRISONERS
OR PEOPLE WHO ARE ARRESTED FOR
MISDEMEANORS. YOUR PROGRAMS ARE
PART OF THE STATE BOTH FELL
STRUCK READ A- AND RESEARCH HAS
SHOWN THAT THESE PROGRAMS.
REDUCE RECIDIVISM. UNDER THIS
BILL JUDGES HAVE THE DISCRETION
TO DECIDE FOR PERSON WITH SHARP
WITH THE ABILITY OF DIVERSION
PROGRAM. INSTEAD OF IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM ABOARD
FORECLOSURE CONSEQUENCES WITH A
COUPLE SPEAKING IN METAPHOR
HOUSING. SMALL NOT ALL. TRIALS
THE COURTS SO UP TO TWELVE OH
DOLLARS PER DAY TO HOLD IT WAS
CAN WOULD JUST ARE ABLE TO
DIVERSION COURT TRIALS BY INTO
THOUSAND TWO YEAR PERIOD IN THE
LAST TWENTY YEARS ELDERLY FIFTY
FIVE YEARS NATIONALLY BY FIVE
HUNDRED. THE CALL OKAY GROWING
FINANCIALLY WITH RISING ACROSS
ELDERLY PRISONERS THE STATE TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND TO THREE
THOUSAND TO CONTINUE
INCARCERATED. THE STUDY FROM
THE JUSTICE PAUL TO FROM THE
RECIDIVISM RATES FOR ELDERLY EX
PRISONERS WAS ONLY 3% YOU TO
INCARCERATED OF THE PRISONERS
FOR LONGER THAN THAT FOR PUBLIC
SAFETY.THIS BILL WOULD
AUTOMATICALLY RELEASED ELDERLY
PRISONERS IT SIMPLY INCREASES
THE POOL OF INDIVIDUALS ALLOWED
TO GET A HEARING. WITH THE
PAROLE BOARD. IN ORDER TO BE
RELEASED PROBAR WOULD NEED TO
PROVE THEIR CASE PROVIDING
PROPER SAFE IT'S FOR THIS IT.
YOUR BILL BEFORE. FOR PERSONAL
ITEMS HUNDRED OLYMPUS THE PAST
IN THE M. SCHOOL IMPACT OF THE
NINETEEN. MOST AFFECTED WE USE
OUR LIMITED RESOURCES. MUST
ADDRESS CRIMINAL JUSTICE
OUTCOMES. ALLEVIATE CASE BOTH
REDUCE COMMON FINANCIAL COSTS
AND CONFIRM. IT IS THE PART OF
AND MORE EFFECTIVE WAYS. I HAVE
TO ASSIST A WONDERFUL SUCH AS
COUNTY SUPERIOR JUDGE DANIEL J.
LOWENTHAL AS WELL ASJAMES
CANNING FOR ELLEN CENTER FIRST.
AND I BELIEVE THE OPERATOR.
THAT VEHICLE YES. THE BILL HAS
ALREADY. BUT THIS IS FOR. ITEM
TWENTY FOURTEEN WHO YEAH. WELL
NO ITEM SB. TEN FIFTY FOUR
FIFTY TO SIXTY FOUR NO NO HI
THIS IS JAMES CAME TO BE KNOWN.
USING CELL THIS IS FOR A THIRTY
THIRTY WE'RE TAKING IT OUT OF
ORDER MR TANG. AND SO AS JOHN
DANIEL LOWER TOTAL. SO IS THAT
YOUR PERSON AT W. LOCAL AND
JAMES KING ARTHUR HEARD MR KING
ON THE LINE MISTER IS JUDGE
LOANS ALL ON THE LINE AS WELL.
THANK YOU ONE. READ APOLOGIZE
MISTER KIT THANK MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS DAN HOW
LOW INCOME I AM A LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT JUDGE. A
JUDICIAL DISCRETION POPPER
DIVERSION IT'S NOT A RADICAL
CONCEPT IN FACT THE MAJORITY OF
OUR OTHER STATES HAVE CONFIRMED
THEIR RESPECTIVE. SUCH CHEN.
EXCLUDING MANY A CONSERVATIVE
STATES SUCH AS IDAHO TEXAS
TENNESSEE MONTANA UTAH IN
GEORGIA AND IN FACT IN SEVERAL
OF THE STATE COURTS HAVE BEEN
CONFERRED WITH DISCRETION TO
GRANT DIVERSION AND FELONY.
THIS BILL BY CAR. ARE MORE
MODEST IT CONFIRM JUDGE. WE
JUST TO DEPART MISDEMEANOR CASE
THIS. IMPORTANTLY THE BILL DOES
NOT CONFIRM DIVERSION UPON A
SINGLE PERSON. OR DOES IT
CREATE A PRESUMPTION OF
DIVERSION IN ANY. INSTEAD
PLEASE ELECTED JUDGES. OKAY
UNITY IS NOT A SIR WITH THE
DISCRETION TO DIVERT WHEN THE
INTERESTS OF JUSTICE SO DICTATE
AND PROPHETICALLY THAT'S THE
DISCRETION OF PROSECUTORS ARE
HAVE. A PILOT. IN L. HI IN
WHICH DESCRIBE INTO DIVERT WAS
GRANTED TO JUDGES NOT BETWEEN
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEN IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. X. HI
RESULTS DIVERSION WITH EXTENDD
ROUGHLY FIFTY SIX HUNDRED
PARTICIPANTS. OVER 95% OF WHOM
COMPLETED ON THE DIVERSIONARY
CONDITIONS AND WE'RE SUCCESSFUL
IN HAVING THEIR CASES DISMISSED
AND LEAVING THEIR ACCOUNT TO
SYSTEM WITHOUT A LIFELONG THE
BILL. GEN ONLY TO PILOT.
ADEQUATE REDUCE COURTHOUSE IN
IN FACT MISTER JERRY TO IN L.
A. COUNTY DROP FROM OVER THIRTY
TWO HUNDRED A YEAR IN FISCAL
YEAR TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN YEAR
PRIOR TO THE PILOT THE LAST
THOUSAND A YEAR THIS CLEAR. TO
IN THE FINAL HIGHLIGHT. THIS
WEEPING WILLOW DIFFERENT ARE OF
THE CRIB JUSTICE I AND ALLOW
ALLOW THE TO FOR RESOURCES TO
MORE SERIOUS. I SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NOW MR KING. GOOD AFTERNOON
THANKS TO THE CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR ALLOWING ME
TO SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY. WE
URGE YOU TO VOTE YES ON SB
THIRTY TO THIRTY FOUR. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER FOR BRINGING
THIS LEGISLATION FORWARD. OUR
PRISON OR STATE PRISON
POPULATION AGING DRAMATICALLY.
IN THE NINETEEN NINETIES OUR
STATE EXPERIENCED A MASSIVE
INCARCERATION CREEK DUE. TO AND
I THE AFFECT OF THE BLOG AND-
THEN I HAVE YOUR IN CAR
SERRATION. THE WORST. THREE
ELDERLY. BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE
GOING TO WORK IN PRISON
FACTORIES PARTICIPATING IN
RAMMING AND WALKING PATHS ON
OVERCROWDED PRISON YARDS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. NOT A
BILL WELL ONE OF THE FOR PEOPLE
TO MIND READY CALL STRAIGHT
SEVENTY NINE YEARS OLD AND IN
SPITE OF UMEROUS SERIOUS HALL
PROBLEMS LAST YEAR HE'S WENT TO
WORK. HE DID THE- FRAZIER WITH
THANKS DURING. KEEP MY SHOPPING
OF ONE DAY THE RESULT. HE
CURRENTLY SO IN ST CROIX HOPING
LIVE LONG ENOUGH TO A HIS CALL
BOARD HEARING AND- TWENTY NINE.
THOUGH HE IS OVER THE AGE OF
SIXTY THAT ARE CURRENTLY
ELDERLY PAROLE LONG HAIRS YOU
DON'T BEEN IN FLORIDA FOR ABOUT.
FIRST BILL WOULD GIVE
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE THE- WILL
IT BE FOR WILL. ANY FIVE GIVING
FRED BETTER BE WILL GET CHANCE
TO TUTORS GREAT GRANDKIDS. BILL
IS A MODEST REFORM WILL ONLY
MAKE A FEW HUNDRED PEOPLE WOULD
BE ELIGIBLE TO THE REVIEW BY
THE BOARD. I WISH FOR IT WASN'T
ACTUALLY PAGE BUT OUR PRISON
PART. CONTINUES AGE AND GIVING
PEOPLE THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVE
THEY ARE NO LONGER TRUST THE
PUBLIC SAFETY BENEFITS OF SOFT.
BY ALLOWING THE MENTAL USING.
IS TO PUNISH PEOPLE WHO ARE NO
LONGER A WRECK. YOU THANK YOU
ARE. ANY WITNESSES HERE IN
SUPPORT IN WITHIN THE CHAMBER
IN THE ROOM. ANY WITNESSES IN
AN AND A PUBLIC HEARING ROOM.
YOUR NAME MUST BE A DIFFERENT
NUMBER OF WITNESSES VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOMS. I DON'T.
ACCESS TO THAT SO WE'RE WE'RE
GETTING READY HERE FROM DIAL IN
WITNESSES. IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE MIGHT
BE CLOSE TO EIGHTY. WE WILL
ONLY A LOT YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION LET ME SAY THAT
AGAIN YOU WILL BE CUT OFF IF
YOU START A SPEECH. AS WE HAVE
LIMITED TIME ALL WE HAVE TIME
FOR IS YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION. A BIG. OPERATOR
GO ONE THE GAP WE WANNA HEAR
FROM. GOING TO TRY TO GET AS
MANY PEOPLE AND AS FAST AS
POSSIBLE SO OPERATOR WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY NAME AN
ORGANIZATION DIALING IN. FAMILY
ENJOYMENT ON THE PHONE IF YOU'D
LIKE TO PROVIDE COMMENT FOR
YOUR SUPPORT POSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS. TONY
CAME IN PLACING IN UPPER WILL
PROVIDE YOU A NUMBER AND THEN I
WILL ANNOUNCE YOU BY THAT
NUMBER WE'RE READY HERE
COMMENTS. BEGIN PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. I AM. AND AT THIS
TIME LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE ABOUT
TWELVE THAT ARE IN THE QUEUE
OKAY. THIS IS PUTS IT WILL
START. NAME AN ORGANIZATION.
WE'LL START WITH NUMBER THIRTY
FOUR THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WELL NUMBER THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE MAKE SURE NOT ON MUTE. I
WILL MOVE TO THE NEXT ONE
NECKLACE WILL. NUMBER SIXTY
EIGHT SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I'M SORRY I GOT IN THE
WRONG QUEUE. OUR NEXT TO MOVE
TO NUMBER THIRTY FIVE THIRTY
FIVE THE LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN BIRTH
MICHAEL DR OFF ON THE HAVE TO
BE A FAILURE OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT. THAT YOU. NEXT SUMMER
FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SACRAMENTO CAREFIRST MARKED UP
THE CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NEXT WILL BE NUMBER
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HER
CHILD DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NEXT WILL BE NUMBER SEVENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. NOT YOUR
HERNANDEZ BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXUS
NUMBER FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. REGULATED OUT WITH
INITIATE JUSTICE VERY STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANKS WILL
BE NUMBER TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BUT IT ARE WITH THE LOOK
VALLEY DEEPER INWARD PORT YOU.
NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I DEFINITELY TELECOM
DAILY DEFECT IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NEXT WILL BE NUMBER
TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MARKOVICH CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS JUST CREATION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT WILL BE
NUMBER EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NEARLY CAMPUS WITH THE
COMPELLING IN STRONG. OKAY. HI
THE NEXT WILL BE NUMBER NINETY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE TRIED
WE ARE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE FOR YOU TO COMMUNITY
JUSTICE AND TRANSPORT. THANK
YOU. NEXUS NUMBER SEVENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO NUMBER
SEVENTY SIX PLEASE MAKE SURE
NOT ON MUTE. THOSE ARE THE
VALUES YOU JUST COALITION A
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. OUR
NEXT WILL BE NUMBER THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALL RIGHT I'M
NOT. A COUPLE DEFENDER'S OFFICE
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HOW NEXT WILL BE NUMBER EIGHTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SEVEN MEN HEN
WITH WORKING FOR PROGRESS INTO
COURT THANK YOU. NEXT TO BE
NUMBER FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. PUT THAT WITH THE POLICY
BACK IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. BUT
NEXT WILL GO TO NUMBER NINETY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GET ON
THE LEVEL READY WITHIN THIS
YEAR CHAPTER IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. ONCE AGAIN LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU'RE IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
WE DID HAVE JUST A COUPLE MORE
JOINT. THE NEXT NUMBER WILL GO
TO IS NUMBER ONE HUNDRED PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME PRIMARY.
FROM LANCASTER AVENUE IN FORT.
THE NEXT WOULD BE NUMBER IS
SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALL
AND WORLD NUMBER SIXTY NINE
YOU'RE OPEN. OUR NEXT WOULD BE
NUMBER NINETY SEVEN NINETY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. LOW WITH
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE IN STRONG SUPPORT. HOW
NEXT TO BE NUMBER ONE OH TO ONE
OH TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. BACK AT
THE DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE IN
SUPPORT. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
NO FURTHER IN SUPPORT- PLEASE
CONTINUE MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
AND I BELIEVE. WE'RE NOT HERE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION I
BELIEVE WE HAVE LARRY MORRIS.
CALIFORNIA JUST. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS LARRY
MORSE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO AB THREE TO
THIRTY FOUR WE APOLOGIZE FOR
THE LATE NOTICE BUT THIS IS A
GOOD AND AMEND BILL IT WAS A
MESS ON MONDAY. NOT EVEN HAD A
LOT. TO HELP REVIEW POWER
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE IS AT OUR
USUAL PRACTICE BEFORE ADOPTING
A POSITION. COMMITTEE KNOWS THE
KEY PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL
HAVE BEEN LIFTED FOR MAYBE
EIGHTY EIGHT THE PUBLIC SAFETY
TRAILER BILL WITH CDA CAL
CHEESE CLOSED END WHICH WAS
PULLED FROM THE FLOOR BEFORE
COULD BE VOTED ON. IN LARGE
MEASURE BECAUSE OF THE VISIONS
THAT ARE NOT PASSED THE BABY
THIRTY. FOUR THE BILL IS BASED
ON L. A. COUNTY PILOT PROGRAM
AB TWENTY ONE FOUR TWO .ORG.
EXPIRED EIGHT. WELL ONE FALLS
PROGRAM APPLY TO PER TIME UP
AND INCLUDED MULTIPLE
EXCLUSIONS INCLUDING SEX CRIMES
DO YOU EYES WEAPONS CHARGES
TRYING CRIMES AGAINST ELDERS
AND MINERS INCLUDING POSSESSION
OF CHILD **** AND ANNOYING OR
MOLESTING A CHILD WEAPONS
CHARGES DEFENDANT HAD THE VERGE.
RENDON'S WITH PRIOR BIO WITHIN
LAST TEN YEARS AS FAR AS WE CAN
TELL THEM THERE'S A VERY SHORT
OPPORTUNITY FOR REVIEW THIS
BILL CONTAINS NONE OF THOSE
EXCLUSIONS CONSEQUENTLY THIS
BILL WOULD ALLOW THE COURT TO
GRANT DIVERGENT TO ALL
MISDEMEANOR OFFENSES INCLUDING
SEX CRIMES DO YOU WISE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE ELDER ABUSE FIREARMS
OFFENSE NOT ONLY WITH THE. THE
BILL WOULD ALLOW THIS DIVERSION
GAP TO BE OFFERED TO REPEAT
OFFENDERS THAT MEANS THAT NO
OFFENSES INCLUDING FELONIES
WILL NO LONGER BE ABLE TO
ALLEGE CRIER DIVERTED CHARGE IN
TWO WITH THE PRIOR ANY DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE WITH A PRIOR AND ALLOW
RIGHT. TRAILER BILL THE CHAIN
THE ELDERLY PROGRAM CURRENT
STATE LAW OFTEN. A REVIEW OF
THE PAROLE. OF INMATES WERE
SIXTY YEARS OF AGE OR OLDER AND
WHO HAVE SERVED A MINIMUM OF
TWENTY FIVE YEARS OF CONTINUOUS
INCARCERATION. IT MAY SURPRISE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE TO
REALIZE THAT FIFTY IS NOW
CONSENT. UNDER THE BEST
PROPOSAL ELDER AT FOR THE-
WOULD NOW BE CONSIDERED FIFTY
YEARS OF AGE AND AVAILABLE TO
AN INMATE WHO HAD SERVED TWENTY
YEARS ON THE TWELFTH OF
CONTINUOUSINCARCERATION. IF
GIVEN MORE TIME THAN IS BEEN
AVAILABLE UNDER THE
DRAMATICALLY ACCELERATED
HEARING OF THIS BILL CDA EIGHT
COULD CITE HUNDRED SAMPLES
OBTAINED AND BY. WELCOME
HEINOUS CRIMES. BOB INTO.
BETWEEN AGES OF AND SEVEN TO
NINETY READ ARE L. FOR ELDERLY
PAROLE RELEASE THIS BILL ALL
MAKE AVAILABLE TO THOSE FIFTY
YEARS OF AGE AND OLDER- ELDERLY
POLL RELEASED FOR HAVING
COMMITTED CRIMES THAT REQUIRE
THEM TO READ YOUR READING LIST.
THIRTY THREE EIGHT. THIRTY TWO
THIRTY TWO FOUR AND
RESPECTFULLY I FOR YOUR
NOTEBOOK. THANK YOU MORRIS.
OTHER ANY MA'AM OF THE PUBLIC
IN IN THE IN HERE ROOM RIGHT
NOW THEY WANT TO COME IN. IN OP
OF THE BILL. ANY INDIVIDUAL IN
THE CONFERENCING ROOM. AND NOW
THEN WE'LL OPEN IT UP FOR
DIALING FOR ANYONE THAT'S IN
OPPOSITION OF. OF A. B. THIRTY
TWO THIRTY FOUR OPPOSITION NOW.
YOU MAY OPEN UP GERMAN ON THE
PHONE LINE IF YOU'D LIKE TO
STAY OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME AGAIN ONE
ZERO IF YOU WERE IN OPPOSITION.
AND AGAIN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
KERN OPPOSITION. WE'LL GO TO
NUMBER NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NAY YOUR NUMBERS
JONATHAN TOLD ME WITH THE TROUT.
THE SERGEANTS AT MEMBERS JOHN
PUBLIC CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION A LINE OR UP WITH
THE OF THE- WE ARE IN OPPOSITE
THANK THANK YOU FELDMAN. AND
WHAT ARE YOU ARE NOT. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
MISTER MEMBERS RIGHT SHERMAN
SUCH LOCATION ALL ABOUT. THANK
YOU MISTER SHERMAN. AND AT THIS
TIME WE ARE NO FOR IN THE QUEUE
FOR OPPOSITION. OKAY THEM NOW
WILL BE IT BACK. TO COMMITTEE
FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR. OUR VICE
CHAIR MISTER LACKEY THE FIRST
WAS CERTAINLY HAVE SOME OF TO
THIS PROPOSED. AS A- MANY OF
THE MEMBERS HAVE A HEARD MOST
OF MY- FRUSTRATION WITH THIS
PARTICULAR BILL. AS EXPRESSED
ON THE FLOOR PRETTY DECENTLY
MOST OF MY OPPOSITION WAS
STATED BY MR MORRIS THE DA-
WHEN WE HEAR THE TERM. LOW
LEVEL OFFENDERS I'M STRUCK BY
THAT BECAUSE IT DEPENDS I THINK
IF YOU ASK MANY OF THESE
VICTIMS. THEY WOULD DISAGREE
WITH THAT CHARACTERIZATION. AND
I THINK- THIS DESERVES A LOT OF
CONSIDERATION ESPECIALLY WHEN
WE HEARD THE JUDGE. REFER TO IT
AB TWENTY TWENTY FOR THE- PILOT
PROGRAM. IT PILOT PROGRAM IT
WAS MUCH DIFFERENT THAN WHAT'S
BEEN PROPOSED RIGHT NOW- THIS
THIS PARTICULAR. ALL HAS NO
LIMIT ON OFFENSES. AND THAT IT
HAD MULTIPLE HAS YOU HEARD-
EXPRESSED BY MISTER MORRIS. I'M
A LITTLE BIT MADE BY FIFTY
YEARS OLD BEING ELDERLY. AND
THE DA'S I'LL JUST CLOSE WITH
THIS THE DA'S HAD THE JUST. OF
A HANDLING THIS. AS IS BEING
CONSIDER BY THE J. TO SOMETHING.
AND I THINK THAT THAT'S THE WAY
IT SHOULD REMAIN I THINK THIS
IS VERY VERY DANGEROUS. AND I
CAN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. YES
MISTER CHANG JUST A QUICK IN
YOUR OPENING YOU REF AS THAT
SAID THAT ONLY INDIVIDUALS AND
HAVE GREAT I ALSO. FIFTY
DOESN'T SEEM OUT MEANS HISTORY
IN THAT STUFF WHAT THEY THEY
DEFINE ELDERLY IT'S A- IT'S A
GOOD. I DON'T HAVE THE STUDY
FRONT OF I'M HAPPY TO GET THAT.
BACK TO YOU. I DON'T KNOW IF
MISTER IS FOR WITH STUDY OF.
MISTER KING ARE YOU ON THE LINE.
I AM THIS IS A SIDE OF JUSTICE
POLICY INSTITUTE. LEAVE IT TO
THE- NUMBER IN THE JUSTICE
POLICY INSTITUTE WAS FIFTY FIVE
I'M NOT CERTAIN ABOUT THAT
THOUGH. OKAY THANK YOU AND WE
CAN FOLLOW UP AND FIND OUT
AFTER TODAY BUT I ALSO JUST
WANT TO REITERATE THE COMMENTS
OF MY COLLEAGUE ABOUT I THINK
THAT JUDGE LOW INTEL'S COMMENTS
ON THE SUCCESS OF THE LA DIVERT.
BLACK WHAT WANT TO SEE OUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM WHICH AN
OPPORTUNE FOR CERTAIN OFFENDERS
TO I'M- TO GET AN OPPORTUNITY
TO MAKE IT RIGHT AND- BUT THERE
WERE SIGNIFICANT EXT SINCE
MARRIAGE EVEN WITH THOSE
EXCEPTIONS WE SAW THE NUMBERS
HE REFLECTED A HUGE BOTH COST
SAVINGS AND SUCCESS RATE IN
THOSE IN THAT PART I WOULD
REALLY WILL A CLOSE. OKAY
MISTER CORE. THAT WAS TWENTY
FOUR YEARS AGO WELL. LOOK
YOU'RE IN PRISON YOUR HEALTH IS
NOT THE RESULT YOU'RE YOU'RE
PRETTY WELL BY THE TIME THE
FOOD EIGHT SPOKE YEARS. THIS
MORE THAN ANYTHING FULLER. LOS
FOLKS AND SO THE BUFFALO MORE
THAN THE FIFTY. SO I REALLY
THAT THE IS SOMETHING THAT I BE
THE FOR MOORE HAD MOVED THE
BALL NOW. COLUSA INTEREST. SO I.
FIFTY FIVE. I WORKED FOR MONTHS
AND MONTHS. THE FOLDERS ALL UP
UP ONLY ABOUT A THIRD. SO PEARL
HAS DISCRETION. WITH REGARD TO
THE DIVERSION PROGRAM IS
FIFTEEN TO ONE OF OUR FLOW WHAT
WELL EXCEPTIONS YOU DO HAVE
SOME OF HIS. WE WERE TOLD WERE
NOT IN THE BILL ONE OF. THE ALL
I WAS GOING TO LET THAT JUDGE-
PERHAPS EXPRESS- YOU KNOW WHY
IN HIS OPINION IT MADE SENSE TO
INCLUDE CATEGORIES THAT WERE
EXCLUDED AND- L. A. COUNTY
PILOT SO IF YOU COULD. IF YOU
COULD ADDRESS ASK QUESTIONS
HE'S HERE. FOUR SO THERE ARE
OVER THOUSAND CRIMES IN OUR-
PENAL CODE IN OTHER ASSOCIATED
CODE- THAT ARE PRESCRIBED.
OUTED OUT OVER FIVE THOUSAND-
WELL OVER FIVE THOUSAND CRIMES
THERE WERE ABOUT EIGHT THAT
WERE EXCLUDED FROM- DIVERSION
CONSIDERATION IN AB TWENTY ONE
TWENTY FOUR AB THIRTY TWO FOUR
DOESN'T. CONTAIN THOSE
EXCLUSIONS- FOR THE REASON THAT
EVEN THOUGH IT IS UNLIKELY THAT
A JUDGE WOULD EXTEND DIVERSION
IN SOME OF THOSE. EIGHT TYPES
OF CASES CASES THAT INVOLVED A
SEXUAL OFFENDER REGISTRATION
PURSUANT TO. EIGHTY TO NINETY
EIGHT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE THIRTY
WHY DEADLY OR DANGEROUS WEAPON
ON IT IS POSSIBLE THAT
INTERSTATE WITH FORTY MILLION
PEOPLE UNIQUE CASES COLORIZED
THERE WAS ONE PUBLISHED CASE-
THEY CAME OUT OF. L. A. COUNTY
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN IN WHICH I
PERSONALLY GRANTED DIVERSION IN
A DEADLY OR DANGEROUS WEAPON
CASE AND THAT WAS EXCLUDED AND
I WAS REVERSED AND- I THINK IT
ILLUSTRATES THE PROPRIETY OF
NOT HAVING EXCLUSION THAT WAS
THE CASE. INVOLVED A FORTY
THREE YEAR OLD. WITH NO
CRIMINAL RECORD WHO GOT PULLED
OVER ON A ROUTINE TRAFFIC STOP
IN IN THE TRUNK OF HIS CAR HE
HAD NOT. HE SAID THE NINE
CHECKS BELONG TO EIGHTEEN OLD
SON IT WAS UNCLEAR. I TO WHOM
THEY BELONGED I THOUGHT THAT
WAS AN APPROPRIATE CASE TO. GET
OFFER DIVERSION- BUT BECAUSE
THAT WAS CONSIDERED A DEADLY OR
DANGEROUS WEAPON IT WAS MY
DECISION WAS REVERSED. I THINK
THAT IT HIGHLIGHTS THEIR IN-SUCH A HUGE STATE IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE TO ALWAYS ANTICIPATE
WHAT CASES MIGHT COME UP AND
INSTEAD I THINK IT'S SAFE TO
TRUST THE DISCRETION OF JUDGES
TO- APPLY TO VERSION ONE
APPROPRIATE. YOU REMOTE
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ARE COMMON. KAMLAGER
THANK YOU MR TANG I WAS- WANTED
TO ECHO THE COMMENTS OF MY-
COLLEAGUE. IN THE BACK SO WELL
PROTECTED- THERE WAS A STUDY
ACTUALLY THAT CAME OUT THAT
THAT CALIFORNIA'S OWNERS MEANT
BY CALIFORNIA'S OWN ASSESSMENT
ABOUT 50% OF OUR INCARCERATED I.
AT VERY LOW RISK OF RECIDIVISM
OF ANY KIND- AND MOST OF THE
FOLKS IN THAT STUDY ARE
ELDERLY. I'M EVEN MIDDLE AGED
AND SICK AND ESSENTIALLY HAVE
AGED OUT OF CRIME AND I DO
BELIEVE THERE WAS A SENTENCING
REPORT THAT CAME OUT THAT SET.
FOR WHO ARE SENIOR. THERE'S
ACTUALLY LESS THAN A TEN PERSON
CHANCE OF RECIDIVISM I. ALSO
BELIEVE I THINK AT THE AGE OF
FORTY NINE OR SO A RP BEGIN TO
SEND YOU- YOU'RE BENEFIT. YOU
TO SIGN IT BECAUSE THEY'RE
WAITING FOR YOU TO TURN FIFTY I
WAS WONDERING IF YOU HAVE ANY
INFORMATION OR CONSIDER MAYBE
YOU CAN ADDRESS THIS IN YOUR
CLOTHES. THE RECIDIVISM RATES
OF THOSE WHO ARE ELDERLY ARE
INDOOR ARE SICK OF REAL. WHO
HAVE BEEN RELEASED SO YOU HAVE
THAT INFORMATION MAYBE THAT
WOULD BE GREAT SHARE IN THE
CLOTHES- AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYMORE COMMENTS THEN
YOU MAY CLOSE MISTER THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR FIRST LET ME
JUST AGAIN. REITERATE THAT THIS
IS A PROPOSAL FOR JUDICIAL
DISCRETION AROUND MISDEMEANOR
DIVERSION IT IS NOT A
AUTOMATIC. DIVERSION PROGRAM IT
IS NOT A PRESCRIPTIVE DIVERSION
PROGRAM- I THINK JUDGE LOW
FALLS EXAMPLES EXCELLENT- THE
NUMB TRUCK INCIDENT IS VERY-
VERY COMICAL BECAUSE THE
BECAUSE- COULD HAVE BEEN AFTER
CARRYING. PROP FORGOT TO
RESIDENTS A DEAD WEAPON I THINK
IT IS. THAT CALIFORNIA AND I
KNOW I NOTED THAT BECAUSE ABOUT
BELIEVE ARIZONA JUST RECENTLY-
LABELED NUN CHUCKS NOT A DEADLY
WEAPON I THINK IT IS ON THAT
CALIFORNIA STILL LABELS NUMBER
DALY RIGHT. I'M I THINK UNDER
THE RIGHT BUDGET OFTEN THAT
PARTICULAR. THE CITY. FROM IN
TERMS OF ELDERLY PAROLE AGAIN
IT IS JUST INCREASING THE POOL
OF PEOPLE WHO COULD GO BEFORE
THE PAROLE BOARD DOES NOT
PRESCRIBE PAROLE IT DOES NOT
TELL THE PAROLE BOARD. AFTER
THESE VIGILS AS- PART MAKE UP
OF THE PAROLE BOARD IT IS VERY
DIFFICULT TO GET PAROLE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA EVEN AS WE
INCREASE THE POOL. IN ADDITION
MAKES A COMPLETE FISCAL SENSE
TO GO BROACH BECAUSE WITH THE
ELDERLY POOR- YOU KNOW WALL ON
AVERAGE WHAT WE SPEND ABOUT A
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER INTO. OF
FOR. TO REACH INTO. IT IS UP OF
TO THE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR
FOR ELDERLY PERSONS BECAUSE THE
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN
HEALTHCARE COSTS AND DR CORPUS
ACTUALLY RIGHT THAT A FIFTY
YEAR OLD WHO'S BEEN IMPRISONED
FOR TWENTY YEARS. NOT HAVE THE
HEALTH AND VITALITY OF THE
CHROME. AT MORSE PARTICULATE I
THINK THEY HAVE- VERY DIFFERENT
LIFE EXPECTANCY THEY'RE VERY
DIFFERENT HEALTH- I DON'T KNOW
THAT ANY OF US I'M SURE NONE OF
US WOULD LIKE TO HAVE BEEN AND
THEN FOR TWENTY YEARS TO. SPEND
THAT. IMPACTED HAVE OUR HEALTH.
SO AGAIN HE GIVES JUDGES THE
DISK AS IT DOES THEY DO FOR
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS. I DOESN'T
EVEN GIVEN THE LAST QUESTION
RETURNEES GET ALSO. I THE WITH
THE DISH ATTORNEY'S. APPLE YOUR
AGO TO GET THE DISK WHICH WHEN
THEY BELIEVE THAT THEY HAVE-
SENTENCE HAD OVERLY PUNITIVE
CENSUS FOR THE DOES DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS AND THOSE JUDGES TO
WORK TOGETHER TO GET THOSE
SENTENCED ON THE SAN DIEGO
DISTRICT ATTORNEY TWENTY
UTILIZED OUT ALL. BUT THE FACT
THAT WE'VE GOTTEN FROM ALL THE
DIFFERENT COMPANIES IS THEY
DON'T HAVE STAFFING ABILITY
WELL THEY DO IN THIS TO GO IN
THEY DO BILITY NOT THIS LAW WE
PASSED UP YEARS AGO. THEY DON'T
HAVE. SO IN. OF THE RE THE
DIVERSE HOUSING BEEN FULLY
YOU'LL THIS AGAIN THIS IS NOT A
NUMBER ONE ON THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S DO LIST IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT US TO SET ASIDE
TWO AND WHEN YOU HAVE A JUDGE'S
AS IT IS GET BROUGHT FORWARD
THEM JEFF. NOW INDIVIDUAL WHO
WOULD REALLY MAKE A DECISION
YOU'RE PAYING HIS OR HER
DISCRETION SO AND- WE ARE BUILT
FOR THIRD TO THIRTY. PLUS THE
CHAIR FOR LETTING ME FIRST TO.
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR THE
BILL. AND THANK YOU IN I THINK
YOU SHOULD ALSO THANK SENATOR
TO LEAD A GROUP A LOT. THANK
YOU SENATOR ARCHULETA FOR SAID.
CORRECT I VOTE SPACE. WHAT I
FOUND IN WITH WITH JUDGE NDAS
THEY BOTH HAVE A VERY HIGH BAR
WHEN IT COMES TO RELEASING
INDIVIDUALS FROM PRISON AND- I
TRUST THAT THE SAME HIGH
STANDARDS. AS WE MOVE TOWARD
THE OVER JUDGE WHAT WILL STILL
BE THERE AND THAT OF WE SHOULD
BE SHOULD SAFE AND SECURE THAT
THE JUDGES WILL WILL. MAKE SURE
AND ALSO THE PAROLE BOARD WHICH
ALSO HAS A VERY VERY HIGH. TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE PUBLIC IS
SAFE WITH THAT IT DID THE FIRST
IN THE SECOND. VENTURE WE CALL
THE ROLL. THE BILL WAS MOVED BY
MR CORGAN SEGMENT MY MESS CALM
WATER. THE BILL IS AB THIRTY
TWO THIRTY FOR THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED. JONES SAWYER
CHEN I LUCKY LACKING BARRICADE
CAN DEEP NO DEEP NOW KAMLAGER.
CAP UNDER A COURT I QUIRK AT
THANK THE AGA. STONE STONE
THANK BILLS ON CALL ME BY THE
BILL'S UNCLE NEEDS ONE MORE
THANK YOU MISTER CHANG BOB REP
WE HAVE TO PUT. CONSENT
CALENDAR- ITEM NUMBER FIVE S.
B. NINE TWO TWO CHIANG OF
CRIMINAL PROCEDURE LIMITATIONS
OF ACT THIS ITEM NUMBER SIX S.
B. ELEVEN TWENTY THREE CHIANG.
AND THE PET. I REMEMBER AS
EIGHT EIGHT GALGIANI PERSON
REPORT LOCAL AT AGE. I AM TEN
AS NINE OF GROW GRANT THAT
AGRICULTURAL EQUIPMENT BUT THE
URGENCY. I DON'T KNOW BUT
THIRTEEN SB SEVEN TWO THREE
JONES FIREARMS AND PROHIBITED
PERSONS. I DON'T BEFORE TO BE
ELEVEN TWENTY SIX JONES OUT OF
COURT RECORDS. AND AN ITEM
NUMBER SEVENTEEN S. B. TWO B.
SIX RUBIO THE THREE INCHES
STATEWIDE DOMESTIC. PROGRAM GOT
A MOTION TO ACCEPT CONSENT
KELLY. BYE BYE OKAY AND SECOND
BY MR QUIRK. JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER IRAQI BLACKIE A
BARRICADE HAND BARRICADE HANNAH
I DEEP DEEP I KAMLAGER KAMLAGER
I QUIRK QUIRK I THANK THE AGA
STONE STONE. THE CONCEPTUALISED
UPDATE RENOWNED MOVE TO ITEM
NUMBER ONE MR ARCHULETA YES TO
ITEMS ITEM ONE AND TWO SB FOUR
EIGHTY PRO IT IT'S A LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY FROM
PERMITTING A PEACE OFFICER TO
WORK IN A POINT THAT IS SOME
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR TO A
MILITARY UNIFORM. AND THE ITEM
NUMBER TWO S. B. PROVIDES A
DEAL BE SHELDON. REQUIRED TO
READ. IS IT A MISTER BACK
EVERYBODY KNEW REPLY TO WITH A
MINOR AND MAKES A TOUGH LIMIT
TO FACILITATE THE PROCESS IT OF
BACKGROUND CHECKS. EVEN START
WITH US BEFORE. PERCENT SO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR GOING
TO. THE SENATE BILL FOUR EIGHTY
FIRST. OKAY HERE WE GO- THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. I WOULD LIKE TO ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. TODAY
I'M PRESENTING. SENATE BILL FOR
EIGHTY THAT WOULD. LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES FROM
AUTHORIZING THEIR OFFICERS TO
WEAR UNIFORMS THAT ARE COMMON
FLIGHTS OR SUBSTANTIALLY
SIMILAR TO THOSE OF THE UNITED
STATES ARMED FORCES ESPECIALLY
THE NATIONAL GUARD. OVER THE
PAST FEW MONTHS I'M SURE MANY
OF YOU HAVE SEEN PHOTOS. AND
VIDEOS OF ON FORSMAN AT
PROTESTS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
WITH SOME OFFICERS WEARING HEAD
TO TOE COMMA FLIGHT PATTERNS.
FOR THE AVERAGE CITIZEN THESE
YOU KNOW BEAR SUCH A STRIKING
RESEMBLANCE TO THOSE WARM BUYER
MILLER. THAT MANY HAVE TROUBLE
TELLING THE TO SUPPORT AS WE
SAW WHEN THE MEDIA TRIBUTE
ACTION PERFORMED BY LOCAL
POLICE TO THE NATIONAL. THIS IS
WRONG AND WE SHOULD BE
PURPOSELY MAKING IT MORE
DIFFICULT TO DISTINGUISH
BETWEEN THE TWO GROUPS
ESPECIALLY WHEN POLICE AND THE
ARMED FORCES ARE MEANT TO SERVE
VASTLY DIFFERENT ROLES IN
AMERICAN SOCIETY. WHEREAS OUR
LOCAL FORSMAN IS HERE TO SERVE
AND PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES OUR
MILITARY HAS A DUTY TO SUPPORT
AND DEFEND OUR CONSTITUTION
AGAINST ENEMIES. THE MILITARY
CAMOUFLAGE UNIFORM OF OUR ARMED
SERVICES SERVICE SPECIFIC
FUNCTION TO DECEIVE THE ENEMY.
AS TO THE PRESIDENT'S POSITION
AND INTENTIONS OF MILITARY
FORMATIONS. POLICE ON THE OTHER
HAND WEAR UNIFORMS THAT EASILY
IDENTIFIED THEM AS MEMBERS OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT. OUTSIDE OF
TACTICAL OPERATIONS WHICH ARE
EXEMPT FROM THIS BILL THAT THE
PURPOSE OF CONCEALMENT SHOULD
NEVER BE USED BY POLICE
OFFICERS WHILE ON DUTY FOR
EVERYDAY PATROL CRIME FROM
RUSSIAN OR WHILE AT AN
ADVANTAGE. IF COME OF LIFE IS
MEANT TO OBSCURE MOVEMENTS THEN
IN A PROTEST SCENARIO OUR
POLICE SHOULD BE CLEARLY
VISIBLE ENGAGING ALL AND TEMPS
TO DE ESCALATE THE SITUATION.
THESE CASES NOT ONLY OUR
MILITARY STYLE UNIFORMS THE
INAPPROPRIATE UNIFORMS BUT
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT YES THE
MERE PRESENCE OF I'M CAN INVITE
HERE. AND DISTRUST WITH THE
COMMUNITIES THAT OUR POLICE
OFFICERS ARE THERE TO SERVE. BY
MINUTE IN THE FUSION BETWEEN
THE MEMBERS OF THE MILITARY AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT SENATE BILL
FOUR EIGHTY HELP. THE SAFETY OF
THE PUBLIC WHILE ALSO HELPING
TO IT OUR NATIONAL GUARD
MEMBERS AND POLICE OFFICERS CAN
PERFORM THE RESPECTIVE DUTIES.
TO THE BEST OF THEIR ABILITIES.
MORE TO REMAIN. WITH THE NOTE
THIS BILL ALLOWS. AN OFFICER'S
WHO ARE MEMBERS OF TACTICAL
TEAMS SUCH AS SWAT OR SPECIAL
OPERATIONS TO CONTINUE USING
THEIR COME FLOOD UNIFORMS WHILE
ENGAGE IN AND A TO SPONSORS FOR
UP. THE PROVISIONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR- THANK
YOU BOB. OTHER IDIOTS.
WITNESSES YOUR WITNESS AND
SUPPORT ORDERS TO STAFF NOT
OKAY ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
A IN A HEARING ROOM DO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK ON SB FOUR EIGHTY.
ANY WITNESSES ON VIDEO
CONFERENCING THAT WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK ON SB FOUR EIGHTY. NOPE
DAN- WE'RE GOING TO DIAL IN ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES ON THE
DIALING IT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK.
IN LATE IN GERMAN THE PHONE
LINES IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AGAIN WE ARE IN PORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. OUR
FIRST WE'LL GO TO NUMBER ONE.
YEAH. NUMBER ONE NINETEEN YOUR
LINES OPEN. YOURLINK STABLE
WELL FOR THE PEOPLE ALLIANCE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. OUR NEXT TO
GO TO NUMBER TWELVE THESE GUYS.
HELLO WHAT THE MARCO GEORGE FOR
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NEXT TO THE NUMBER NINETY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. ISRAEL
REAR WHAT'S THE YCJA IN STRONG
SUPPORT. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS. ONE
ZERO. I DO HAVE A FEW THAT HAVE
ENTERED THE QUEUE IS JUST TAKE
A MOMENT. THE NEXT WE'LL GO TO
NUMBER ONE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS DANIELA SANCHEZ I LIVE IN
THE COMMUNITY OF LAKE LA HOW
LITTLE A SMALL LITTLE TOWN- AND
I DEFINITELY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
AND NEXT ROAD NUMBER ONE OH
FIVE- ONE OH FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. TURN NUMBER ONE OH SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND LOOKS LIKE
THEY'VE DROPPED- AT THIS TIME
WE HAVE NO FURTHER IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE GO AHEAD MR TRAP. THANK
YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FOR. OF WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. I THE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IN THE HEARING ROOM.
CNN ANY WITNESSES IN VIDEO
CONFERENCING IN OPPOSITION. AND
ON THE DIED ON LINE ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION SB
FOUR EIGHT ZERO. PLEASE TELL ME
IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION WELL
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. WE DO
HAVE ONE IN THE QUEUE TO JUST
TAKE A MOMENT. AND WE'LL GO TO
LINE ONE TWENTY TWO LINE ONE
TWENTY TWO YOU ARE OPEN. HELLO
MY NAME IS AMANDA MODERATELY.
WHAT AN INTERNAL. M. INITIATE
JEFF WITH. THANK MA'AM. HI
THERE ANYONE CAN KERN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AT THIS TIME THERE ARE NO
FURTHER IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE MISTER CHAIR ANY
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WELL. SECOND. OKAY
MISSED OUR K. AND MOVED IT
MISTER COURT SECOND ARE THERE
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR- YOU MAY
CLOSE. THE SEARCHER MEMBERSHIP
THANK YOU AT URGENT ASK YOUR
BIBLE THANK YOU THAT. REGARD
JOHN. YOUR STATE FOR GOOD. OKAY
THANK YOU SHE L. PUT DISSING
SHE'S AN EXCELLENT FOR JUST ONE
WISH YOU BETTER EARLY TRAINING.
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH IF YOU
WERE TO BUY STAFF HE STARTED
ENTER SO YOU GOT YOU GOT THE
BEST. GOOD ALL RIGHT. WE HAVE A
MOTION THEY MIGHT IN THE SECOND
YOU. SB FOUR EIGHTY MOTION IS
DUE PASSED AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER HI JONES SAWYER I BLACK.
YES YEAH. D. I. BARRY BACKING
HANNAH I DEEP DEEP NO KAMLAGER.
QUIRK QUIRK I SENT. STONE STONE
I. THE MEASURE PASSES THANK YOU
YOU MAY NOW GO ON TO SB NINE OH
FIVE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS WILL. GOOD
OKAY THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I'M HERE TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL NINE OH FIVE THE
BACKGROUND CHECKS SECURITY AT.
CALIFORNIA ALLOWS ORGANIZATIONS
TO REQUEST ALL EVENT APPLICANTS
RECORDS OF CONVICTIONS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT JUSTICE
IF THE APPLICANT WILL HAVE
SUPERVISORY OR DISCIPLINARY
POWER OVER A MINOR OR ANOTHER.
IN THEIR CASE AND THEY'RE- THIS
MEASURE IS PRUDENT STEP IN
ENSURING THE SAFETY OF MINERS
RATHER VULNERABLE INDIVIDUALS.
HOWEVER THESE REQUESTS CAN BE
EXPLOITED TO DIVULGE THE
LOCATION OF UNDOCUMENTED
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE PLAIN TO
VOLUNTEER IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
THE YEAR OF THIS PERSONAL
INFORMATION BEING TAKEN. E.
EIGHTY THAT ENOUGH. ON THE
VOLUNTEER EFFORTS. IN THE
COMMUNITIES FOR FREE- OF THEIR
PRIVACY BEING BREACHED BY THE
BY FEDERAL AGENCIES AND
ENTITIES. DURING THE CALL WITH
NINETEEN CRISIS WE NEED
VOLUNTEERS MORE THAN EVER.
ESPECIALLY NOW SHOULD NOT BE
HELD BACK FROM FROM PROCEDURE
FROM CONTRIBUTING TO THEIR
COMMUNITY. SENATE BILL NINE OH
FIVE PROTECT THE PRIVACY OF
CALIFORNIA I KNOW LAW CHOIR IN
RESIDENCE ADDRESS. BACKGROUND
CHECKS. BY NOT REQUIRED AN
ADVERT IN THE BACKGROUND CHECKS
WE CAN PROVIDE SHEERAN'S TO
INNOVATE. THEY CAN BE.
COMMUNITIES WELL. FOR MY- BE
INSECURE. SELF. FROM PROVIDED
ANY INFORMATION RELATED TO THE
BACK RUNNING GREAT TWO OTHER IN.
BERMAN WHAT. ABSENT COURT ORDER
WARRANT. ESPINO FOR DOES NOT
PLEASE THEIR DUTY TO KEEP KIDS
SAFEFROM PREDATORS IN FACT SB
NINE FIVE WHEN INTRODUCED A
UNIVERSAL CITATION BACKGROUND
CHECKS FOR. THE LAW. F. B.
STANDERS I IN THE PROCESS AND
REDUCING THE NUMBER OF REQUESTS
FOR FEDERAL CORRECT THAT ARE
DENIED BY THE FBI. SB NOT A
FIVE ADD TO THE EXIT. CITIZENS
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS ALIVE
THE STATE WITHOUT IMPLEMENTING
THE ABILITY OF PARTNER JUSTICE
TO INVESTIGATE THOSE RACKING
WITH NOBLE THEY SHOULD ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS TODAY AB
AND RIVAS EXACTLY YOUR
CALIFORNIA AVERAGES. MARTIN
SAVIDGE FROM DONALD'S OFFICE TO
FIND SUPPORT VIA THE TELEPHONE
CONFERENCE THANK. THANK YOU
MISTER TAYLOR OPERATOR.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. YEAH. ONE
YEAH. YES THEY CAN BEGIN. EDU
REVISTA SORRY FOR. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND THANK YOU
SENATOR ARCHULETA FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY- MY NAME ASSEMBLY
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE IN.
CHALLENGING IN OUR HISTORY WE
ALSO THAT THERE IS AN INCREASE
NECESSITY FOR PROVIDING KEY
SURPLUS FOR MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
TO WHETHER THE CURRENT. THIS
INCREASED TREMENDOUSLY OVER THE
PAST SEVERAL MONTHS ANY
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE OUR CATHOLIC
PETITIONS REQUIRE. UNDER
FINGERPRINTING AND BACKGROUND
CHECKS IN ORDER TO ENSURE THE
SAFETY OF THE CHILDREN. S. B.
NINE OH FIVE THE STATE WOULD BE
LIMITED NOVEMBER BALLING TEARS
WHO WHICH LIMITS THE SUPPORT BY
OUR- NINE CRISIS. DOCUMENTED
BROTHERS. TO VOLUNTEER IN A
BALL. DO SO BY UP TO OUR
PARENTS WE NEED HAS BEEN OUT OF
FOOTBALL FIVE NINE. WHAT YOU TO
BY CHILDREN BY TO MAKE
FINGERPRINT BACKGROUND CHECKS
ON ALL OF OUR- TO PUT THE WHAT
CALIFORNIANS WHO DO WHAT THE
BALL AND HELP. WE ARE TRYING
TO. ALL CAL. SHOULD DO WHAT.
THE PRIVACY THE NEIGHBOR OF THE
BALL IN THEIR COMMUNITIES WITH
TRANQUIL PHILIP. THE HOLD
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS CAL
SHOULD BEEN TWENTY IN THE
SCHOOL AND THEIR NEIGHBOR FULL
OF BECAUSE THAT THE ATTENTION.
NEEDED TO OUR COMMUNITIES.
TOGETHER I ASKED WE BOTH.
PACKAGING CORP FOLLOWING IN
CHERRY OUR COMMUNITIES WHILE
ENSURING SAFE AND FOR ALL THANK
YOU. THE YOU. HELLO MY NAME
DOCUMENTS LEGISLATIVE THE
ADVOCATE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE ATTORNEY
GENERAL BECAUSE- I KNOW FIVE
AND ON BEHALF OF THE ATTORNEY
JACK. THERE ARE INCLUDING THE
AND THEN TO ALL J. CONTINUE
PROVIDE CRIMINAL HE RECORD
INFORMATION C. H. R. I. WHILE
WE'RE CUTTING BACK CHECKS FOR
LIFE. CERTIFICATION ARE PROOF
OF THAT OKAY YEAH I. POINT OF
CONTACT IN CALIFORNIA ATTAINING
FEDERAL C. I BELIEVE I TO SING
CERTIFICATION PURPOSE. EACH
TIME IT STATUTES ACCORDING TO
THINK THAT YOU TO MAKE IT UP TO
BY WEARING FOR. I YEAH. I
UNIVERSE RIGHT. FIVE FIFTEEN
CHRISTIE FOR AGENCY AND NATIONS
TO RECALL IT BASED CRIMINAL HAS
INCOME. DOJ THE FBI AND INSTEAD
OF INCOME EXPECTED THAT YOU.
EACH A THAT OUR GET YOU TO
STATUTES WE'RE PLEASED TO
SUPPORT THE PROVISION OF ACTUAL
CLOSER AT FOR FEDERAL HIS FROM
A FROM SCREENING FOR PEOPLE IN
THE OF TRACK THANK. NAME AND
ORGANIZATION. MISTER MARMALADE
YOUNG ON THE PHONE LINE IF YOU
IF YOU'RE- ZERO. OKAY IF YOU'RE
IN SUPPORT PRESS ZERO AT THAT
TIME. AND WE'LL GO TO NUMBER
TWELVE NUMBER TWELVE YOUR LINES
OPEN. MARKET WHICH FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND WORK. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE DO HAVE ONE MORE IN Q.
TO JUST TAKE A MOMENT. NEXT WE
ARE THE NUMBER ONE TWENTY FOUR
ONE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO. THE
RADIO CALIFORNIA LIVES DO YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. EITHER
ON THE PHONE VIDEO CONFERENCING
ANY WITNESSES IN A ROOM IN
OPPOSITION. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES ON THE PHONE DIALING
IN IN OPPOSITION. SB NINE OH
FIVE. ON THE PHONE. LINES IF
YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THROUGHOUT THIS TOP.
I GOT A ONE ZERO IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION. ONCE AGAIN IT'S ONE
ZERO IF YOU ARE AN OPPOSITE.
THERE ARE NONE IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. PLEASE CONTINUE MR THANK
YOU WILL TALK ABOUT YOU ANY OR
FROM CA MEMBERS. BEING DONE YOU
MAY CLOSE MISTER TAYLOR. THANKS
SHARE IN. THANKFULLY AFTER.
THANK YOU SAID FOR BRINGING
THIS TO COMMITTEE OF THE CHAIR
FOR MANY AYE VOTE WE HAVE A
FIRST AND SECOND YOU MAY CALL.
RAMOS SECOND. BARRICADE HAND
THAT'S NINE OH FIVE THEM IS TO
PASS TO THE APPROPRIATE
COMMITTEE J. SAWYER JOHNSON I.
OUR K. BARK HANNAH. D. KAMLAGER
KAMLAGER I WORK ON WORK I THANK
YOU ALL. STONE STONE I. IS YOUR
PASSED SENATOR THANK YOU CHERUB
LEADERS THANK YOU MUCH AGAIN
THANK YOU PREPAY. SENATE STEVE
BRADFORD. THAT WOULD BE S. B.
TWO ZERO THREE BRADFORD EXPANDS
AND EXTENDS CAPTIONS FOR MINORS
PART BECAUSE THE INTERROGATE.
BY ARE FORTUNATE. SIXTEEN AND
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD TO CONSULT
WITH AN ATTORNEY BEFORE WAIVING
THEIR MIRANDA RIGHTS. YOU MAY
BE CENTER. MISTER OUR S. B. TWO
OLD THREE WHICH WOULD REQUIRE
YOU UNDER. EIGHTEEN TO CONSULT
WITH LEGAL COUNSEL PUT BEFORE.
I SHOULD STATE WHAT YOUR MIND
OR- ALL RIGHTS ARE. WE KNOW FOR
DECADES OF RESEARCH THAT YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE WHAT I UNDERSTAND
THEIR RIGHTS AS WELL. ALL OF US
ARE FAMILIAR WITH THE CENTRAL
PARK FIVE EIGHT CASE THAT
HAPPENED YORK IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE. TIME FIVE I'M
BLOOD IN HIS BAG BOYS BETWEEN
THE AGE OF FOURTEEN AND SIXTEEN
MEMBERS OF THE- HOME IT. LEGAL
COUNSEL QUESTIONING AND HERE'S
OF THEIR LIFE. THEN FOR AND
THEY DIDN'T AT. ALL WERE
EXONERATED YET YOU STILL. MORE
RECENTLY AND THE THIRD. IN LOS
ANGELES SINCE TWENTY FIVE YEARS
AND HER PARTNER JUNE FIFTH FOR
HE DID NOT COMMIT LAPD
DETECTIVES QUESTIONED HIM FOR
HOURS WHEN I'M A LAWYER THIS IS
A LIST BAUSKA. THEY TOLD THAT
HIS MOTHER HAD IT JENNIFER HIM
THE KILLER AND NOT STOP YOUR
GATE WINNING. IT MADE NOT I
SHOULD SAY STOP THE TERROR WHEN
HE ASKED FOR A- OUR TOLD IS.
SOLDIERS MOTHER. THAT HE ONLY
YES BECAUSE- WE'RE GOING TO
TELL THE JOBS I'M A COLD
BLOODED AND I'M GOING TO GET
OUR TOP. YOUR EXONERATION 36%
OF PEOPLE WHO SLEEP CONFESSED
TO A CRIME AND WE'RE EXONERATED
FOR UNDER THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN
THIS BILL PROTECTS ALL POP CAL.
THE SEVENTEEN THAT WAS
ULTIMATELY ULTIMATELY AMENDED
TO YOUTH UNDER THE TO SIXTEEN
POLLUTING THE SUNSET INTO TWO.
AND REQUIRE A- THANKS HELLO THE
POSITION TO THE BILL ARGUE THAT
WE WAIT TO HEAR TO READ OF THIS.
WE SHOULD HAVE WAIT FOR SOME WE
ARE ANSWERS THANK PEOPLE MIGHT
IN THE- LONG DATA THIS NOT IF
HERE'S- I MEAN STATEMENT IN A
CIVIL AND WHAT NOT PREVENT
LAUNCH FOR USING ACTION
PUBLISHED THE WORK. BILL HAD A
CAPABILITY AND DO ALL CAL
THANKS. ON THE LAW. TODAY TO
JUST. FIVE IS DRAWN DICKS WHO
SPEAK UP. IT'S AN ANTI. AND
SAMPRAS'S DISTRICT THE JOHN
SHOOP. WHO WILL TALK A- HOW THE
EARLY HOLLY ALREADY INTO
FRANCISCO WE ALSO WILL A LOOP
WOMEN ARE HERE WHAT AVAILABLE
FOR A TECHNICAL DISTANCE
MEMBERS ARE FOR YOUR I'VE.
AVAILABLE AND READY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. BOB S. B. TWO OF THREE.
THIS IS TRACEABLE DEAN ON THE
SAN FRANCISCO DISTRICT ATTORNEY
AND I AM UNABLE TO SPEAK LET ME
START BY THANKING CHAIRPERSON
JOINS JONES SAWYER MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. I WAS. CISCO TO.
OKAY FOR MORE JUST FOR ALL TO
ACHIEVE THIS I WORKED TO BUILD
A JUSTICE SYSTEM THAT PROTECTS
THE RIGHT OF EVERY INDIVIDUAL
COMMUNITY AND MARBLE FOR THESE
REASONS I AM HERE TODAY
INDUSTRY SUPPORT. HE TO THREE.
UNDER EXISTING CALIFORNIA LAW
USE UNDER AGE SIXTEEN IN POLICE
CUSTODY MUST CONSULT WITH AN
ATTORNEY WHO EXPLAINS THEIR AND
AEROBICS BEFORE YOU DECIDE TO
WAIVE THOSE RIGHTS. L. BEFORE
YOU TODAY WOULD RAISE THE AGE
OF THAT PROTECTION TO EIGHT T.
I BELIEVE I. SHOULD SPEAK TO
YOUR ACTIVITIES BOTH. BECAUSE
LAST YEAR SAN. ACTIVE IN ORDER.
TO ACTUALLY WHAT. STATEWIDE AS
A RESULT USE TO EIGHTEEN ALL
RIGHT HAVE THESE PER AND MY-
THEREFORE I KNOW FOR ME TO THAT
THESE PROTECTIONS HAVE NOT
UNDER MY OFFICE IS ABILITY TO
PROSECUTE CRIMES I ALSO KNOW
THAT THESE PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES SAFER BECAUSE THEY
HELP YOUNG. FROM GROWING
MISTRUSTFUL OF LAW ENFORCEMENT.
I SUSPECT THAT SOME MAY OPPOSE
THIS BILL B. BECAUSE THEY
BELIEVE THAT IF YOU CAN
UNDERSTAND THEIR RIGHTS THEY
WILL BE LIKELY TO WAIVE THEM.
HOPING YOUR CAN. HERE'S THIS
BUT DID IGNORE A BASIC TENET OF
JUSTICE. IF PEOPLE CAN WAIVE
THEIR RIGHTS WITHOUT EVEN
UNDERSTANDING THEM THAT OUR
RIGHTS ARE MEANINGLESS. THAT IS
ONLY MORE. WHEN TALKING ABOUT
YOU. THESE DAYS PROSECUTORS
RELY LESS AND LESS SOME
CONCESSIONS AND FOR GOOD REASON
WE RELY MORE ON POLICE BODY PUT
IT NEARLY YOU SECURITY CAMERAS
INCREASE ELECTION DATA AND FOR
EVIDENCE THERE IS NO QUESTION I
CONSENT THANKS A CASE BUT THOSE
OF US WHO VALUE THE
CONSTITUTION RATHER THAN A
BLIND FOCUS ON DURING ELECTIONS
AT ALL COST OUR- GOING TO.
COURT. OF LAW PROVISIONS. FINAL
WELL ACTUALLY UNDERSTANDING
LEGAL RIGHTS TO AND MAKING GOOD
IS UNDER BECAUSE OF THIS ARE
ALSO MUCH LIKELY THAN A TO
FALSE CONFESS LEADING TO WRONG
CONVICTION. WE MUST ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT BLACK AND BROWN
YOUTH FACE INTERROGATION BY
POLICE FAR MORE THAN WHITE YOU.
AS A RESULT MORE YOU CALLER
CALLS. RECENT RESEARCH FOUND
BLACK YOUTH ARE MORE LIKELY TO
BE WRONGFULLY CONVICTED AT THE
RESULT OF HALL TIONS THAT THE
OTHER PLACE THIS BILL PROTECTS
THE RIGHTS OF YOU PARTICULARLY
TO COLOR. LONG FOR PROFESSIONAL
MY JURISDICTION. CENTRAL DUTY
IS TO UP THE CONSTITUTION
EVERYTHING I DO FLOWS FROM THAT
RESPONSIBILITY SB TWO OH THREE
PROTECT OUR CONSTITUTION BY
HELPING ENSURE THAT YOU
UNDERSTAND RIGHT BEFORE THE
SITE WHETHER TO WAIVE THEM I
URGE TO VOTE HI THANK YOU. AND
NOT. SWISS MISS MARTIN THAT.
THE BILL WHENEVER YOU'RE JONES
SAWYER YES AND- KIM JON JONES
SAWYER MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU MY NAME IS DERON
DIXON I LIVE IN LOS ANGELES
WHERE I AM BUDGET MANAGER
BOOKING. COMPANY I HERE FROM
SUPPORT SENATE TWO OR THREE. AT
SEVENTEEN I WAS INTERROGATED
FOR TWENTY FIVE HOURS BY THE
POLICE. HE WAS ONE OF THE WORST
EXPERIENCE OF MY LIFE. THE
POLICE HAD A STORY ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENS. WHEN IT. MYSELF IN IT.
BY OUR FIFTEEN OF QUESTIONING I
WAS SO EXHAUSTED I COULDN'T
HAVE TOLD YOU IT WAS NOT YOUR
DAY. OUR TWENTY ONE. I WANTED
TO GO HOME TO MY FAMILY. I TELL
THE OFFICERS WHAT THEY WANTED
TO HEAR. I TO A CRIME I DID NOT
COMMIT. AT OUR TWENTY ADDITION
STUFF AND I THOUGHT MY
NIGHTMARE HAD ENDED. IT YEAH.
MAYBE SOME OF YOU CAN'T
COMPREHEND HOW SEVENTEEN YEAR
OLD COULD GIVE UP HIS RIGHTS
AND CONFESSED THAT SOMETHING HE
DIDN'T DO. BUT I NEVER
UNDERSTOOD RIGHT. BUT WHAT IT
MEANT TO GIVE THEM UP. I REALLY
DID NOT UNDERSTAND WHAT COULD
HAPPEN IF I GET THE GREEN TO
WHAT THEY WANT. AS RESEARCH.
THIS IS NOT UNCOMMON FOR TEAM.
I TRIED AS ADULTS AND SPENT
TWENTY ONE AND A HALF YEARS IN
PRISON. I'VE NEVER HAD A SINGLE
DISCIPLINARY ACTION. NO YOUNG
PERSON SHOULD MAKE AN
UNINFORMED LEGAL DECISION ONE
THAT COULD COST TWENTY YEARS OF
HIS LIFE. I ASK FOR YOUR GUEST
BOOK. THANK YOU. THANK YOU ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN THE
ROOM- RIGHT NOW IN SUPPORT. ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES ON THE
TELECONFERENCING IN SUPPORT.
MISTER MODERATOR WE CAN NOW GO
INTO THE DIALING NIGHT NAME
AND- ORGANIZATION FOR WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. MY ONLY IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN
IN THE SUPER PLEASED. ZERO I
WILL START WITH NUMBER ONE
THIRTY TO ONE THIRTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS YOUR
BODY WITH INITIATE CHAPTERS AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. XO THE NUMBER THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. FOR
BECKY GONZALEZ NATIONALISTS
THAT THE HMO POSTAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NEXUS NUMBER FORTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIRST
MAJESTIC CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. WHAT ARE TE NUMBER
ONE THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT JIM WOOD
BURKE ARE TO BE CAPPED THE
FRENCH COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NEXT WILL BE
NUMBER SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS A SERIOUS
TRAVIS- WHICH- COMBAT EVOKE AT
PRAGUE WILL SPONSOR FOR THIS
BILL. NEXT TO BE NUMBER SEVENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I ST THE
MANGO SILICON VALLEY DE BUG
PALCO THE BOND IN THE BUILD
STRONG SUPPORT. IT WILL BE
NUMBER SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WEBER TOMORROW MMHM IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. IT WILL
BE NUMBER ONE THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
JESSICA GRIFFITH FINISHED
INITIATE JUSTICE AND TROPICAL.
I WILL NOW GO TO NUMBER SIXTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE DIED
OF SILICON VALLEY DE BUG IN
STRONG SUPPORT. I WILL GO TO
NUMBER EIGHTEEN THE CLEAR HEAD.
CURSED CHILD DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. NOW WILL
GO TO NUMBER ONE THIRTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BUDGET OFFICE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF CHILD AND ADOLESCENT
PSYCHIATRY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NEXUS NUMBER ONE TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
DONNA SITES REPRESENTING THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT. SO THE
NUMBER SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IT'S NOT CLEAR HERNANDEZ
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
IN SUPPORT. SO HE NUMBER
TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MARCO
GEORGE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NEXUS ONE THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
REMOVAL I MEAN THAT IS WITH THE
NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW
IN STRONG SUPPORT. Q. NEXT
ORDER NUMBER EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. SO THE NEXT TO GO TO
NUMBER ONE TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU YOUR MESSAGE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
ALAMEDA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
NOW GO TO NUMBER NINETY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT NINETY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NEXT
WE'RE GONNA NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WE'LL GO TO NUMBER ONE
TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SEVERAL COUNTY BOARD DINNERS
WITH SILICON VALLEY DE BUG IN
SUPPORT. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
NUMBER TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BUT NAY THE HARDWOOD
SILICON VALLEY DE BUG IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF ITSELF. X. WILL BE
NUMBER ONE TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I'M COALITION THE
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE
TWENTY EIGHT WOULDN'T CATCH THE
FIRST PART YOUR NAME. WHEN WE
GATHER HERE. ANTI TERRORISM
COALITION. AND TRANSPORT THANK
YOU. OUR NEXT WILL GO TO NUMBER
ONE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE TWENTY FOUR LINES OPEN.
WELL WE. ARE WITH THE YPJ IN
STRONG SUPPORT. NEXT WILL BE
THE NUMBER ONE THIRTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I GET AFTERNOON
DOMINIQUE YOUNG CHILDREN'S
DEFENSE FUND CALIFORNIANS
STRONG SUPPORT. IN ORDER TO
TWENTY SEVEN NUMBER TWENTY
SEVEN AIRLINES OPEN F. FUNDING
pCOSPONSORED SOMEWHERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.%
NEXT TO BE NUMBER ONE FORTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
THE CHEAPER THE EMPEROR SAID
WITHIN COALITION WE ARE A PROUD
CO SPONSOR OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU. THE NEXT WILL BE NUMBER
FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SENATE QUARTERS WITH THE
COMMODITY BUT TROPICAL
SPONSORED AN OPEN WITHIN THEIR
COUNTY PARTICIPANTS FOR THE
FANS IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ONCE AGAIN THOSE ON THE
PHONE LINES IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. IN ONE ZERO CARE IN
SUPPORT. HEY WILL GO TO NUMBER
NINETY SEVEN NINETY SEVEN YOUR
LINES OPEN. WELL DID YOU JUST
CALL IT IN ON THE TRUCK BUT
THANK YOU. NEXT IS NUMBER
EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
WITH. NEARLY ASSEMBLY DEVO FIVE
HUNDRED AND PHONE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. NEXT WILL BE AT ONE
FORTY THREE ONE FORTY THREE
YOUR LINES OPEN. MILES. THE
ENTIRE RECIDIVISM COALITION WE
ARE CO PROP CULTURE THIS BILL.
NEXT TO BE ONE FORTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
DARIA WILL READ TODAY FROM THE
NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH WHILE
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU. NOW GO TO
NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS YOLANDA DOES NOT WITH ALL
CON BALLY DEEPIKA PROUD COOK
BONTA DOESN'T FILL IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THE ACTUAL
THE NUMBER SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I DON'T HAVE ANY WITH Y.
J. C. INSTRUCTED BURKE. ANNEX'S
NUMBER SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FOR SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I KNOW ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO ENTER SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. WE'RE
GONNA NUMBER SEVENTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WE'LL GO TO NUMBER
NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AND AT THIS TIME- WE HAVE NO
FURTHER IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
OTHER IT TO ANYONE. OPPOSITION
I BELIEVE WE HAVE A COREY CELLS
ARE LOW. AND ON THE PHONE FROM
C. S. S. A. AND LORI MORRIS
FROM CD EIGHT ON THE PHONE. IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CORY CELLS L.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL HAVE YOU DISCUSSED
EXISTING PROVIDES UNTIL JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY FIVE THE
PRIOR TO CUSTODIAL
INTERROGATION BEFORE THE WAIVER
OF ANY MARANDA RIGHT TO USE
FIFTEEN YEARS OF AGE OR YOUNGER
SHALL CONSULT WITH LEGAL
COUNSEL IN PERSON BY TELEPHONE
OR BY VIDEO CONFERENCE. AND
UNDER CURRENT LAW THIS
CONSULTATION MAY NOT BE WAIVED
IN OPPOSING SB THREE NINETY
FIVE WHICH CREATED THIS
PROVISION WE ARGUED THAT THE
BILL EXCEEDED WHAT THE UNITED
STATES SUPREME COURT AND
REQUIRED ON THE MATTER LAW
ENFORCEMENT MAY SIMPLY WANT TO
TALK TO MINOR AND EVEN IF THE
PARENT OR GUARDIAN IS NOTIFIED
IN ADVANCE THIS GUYS. COUNCIL
CONSULT WITH THE MINOR THERE
WAS A CHANCE THAT THE
INTERACTION FALL UNDER THE
BILL'S GOING TO FIND OUT. HE'LL
INTERROGATE. THANKS STANDING TO
MINOR SEVEN YEARS OF AGE OR
YOUNGER PROBLEM A GOOD. WOMEN
ALL. FIRSTOBJECT TO THE BILL
BECAUSE IT SEEKS TO MAKE THESE
PROVISIONS PERMANENT WITHOUT
THE FULL BENEFIT OF THE
TEMPORARY TRIAL PERIOD INCLUDED
IN SB THREE NINETY FIVE.
FURTHER SB TWO OR THREE
ELIMINATES THE REQUIREMENT THAT
A PANEL BE CONVENED TO EXAMINE
THE IMPACTS OF THIS LAW. WOULD
BE NO REASON TO EXPAND THIS
PROGRAM INDEFINITELY WHILE
REMOVING ANY NOTION THAT THE
PROGRAM'S OUTCOMES WILL BE THE
SUBJECT OF AN UPPER REVIEW. AS
REASONS. MONSTROUS OPPOSE SB OR
THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU KNOW
MISTER MORRIS. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS GERALDINE WONG
WILLIAMS AND I AM A DEPUTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY FROM ORANGE
COUNTY AND AT THIS TIME INSTEAD
OF MISTER MORRIS I WILL BE
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF TDA AND
THE ORANGE COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY TODD SPITZER. ALL OF
US RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE S. B.
TWO OH THREE AS THE JUVENILE
SEXUAL ASSAULT EIGHTY A FOUR
INCH COUNTY IT IS PART OF MY TO
BE THE DESIGNATED EXPERT ON
EVEN MORE RANDOM LOS ANTIBIOTIC
COUNTY WHY TRADING ON THE
ISSUE. YOU SHOULD ALSO KNOW
THAT I ONE EIGHT. THE FOR YEARS
IN ORANGE COUNTY FIVE OF WHICH
I WORKED IN DEPENDENCY TO
REUNIFY FAMILIES. AS A MINORITY
MOTHER TO AN AUTISTIC CHILD I
AM VERY SENSITIVE TO HOW
VULNERABLE OUR CHILDREN CAN BE
TO MANIPULATION HARASSMENT AS
WELL AS THE BEES AND
VICTIMIZATION. AND AS AN
IMMIGRANT FROM HONG KONG A
PLACE WHERE DEMOCRACY IS WANING
BY THE DAY I. HAVE THE UTMOST
RESPECT FOR PERSONAL CIVIL
LIBERTIES. PROFESSIONAL
PERSONAL BACKGROUND LET ME SEE
THAT SB TWO OR THREE IS
UNNECESSARY IT OVER REACHES
BEYOND JUST RAISING THE TARGET
AGE AND WILL HAVE LASTING
NEGATIVE IMPACTS ON JUVENILE
JUSTICE REFORM. FIRST OF THE
UNINTENDED EFFECT IS THE
RATIFICATION OF BUILT IN
SAFEGUARDS THE CURRENT JUVENILE
MARANDA LAW ON THE- AMONG
DISCIPLINARY. OF EXPERTS AS
WELL AS COMMUNITY
REPRESENTATIVES TO CONVENE AND
REVIEW JUST HOW EFFECTIVE THE
LAW IT IS THE BILL TEN WHAT TO
ENSURE ENGAGED AND FOR MINORITY
LEADERS AND TO ADDRESS THE
SPECIFIC CONCERNS OF GOVERNOR
OUT OF WHEN HE WROTE HIS VETO
MAY. TO S. B. TEN FIFTY TWO.
WHILE WE ARE THE PURPOSE OF THE
GREATER PROTECTIONS FOR
JUVENILES WE CANNOT DESTROY
THESE BUILT IN. ANOTHER
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE OF SB
TWO OH THREE IS THE HINDRANCE
OF JUVENILE SEXUAL ASSAULT
INVESTIGATIONS MANY JUVENILE
SEXUAL ASSAULT HAPPENED ONE ON
ONE WITHIN THE HOME AND BETWEEN
SIBLINGS. AND OFTEN THE
PERPETRATOR ARE THEMSELVES
VICTIMS OF ABUSE BY SOMEONE
EVEN OLDER AND BIGGER AND THE
INABILITY TO TALK TO THAT CHILD
JUST BECAUSE HE'S BEEN LABELED
AS THE PERPETRATOR. IN THE
INABILITY TO PROTECT ANY OF THE
CHILDREN WITHIN THAT HOME FROM
ONGOING ABUSE TO TIE THE HANDS
LAW ENFORCEMENT PROPER THE CASE.
I MEAN WE CAN'T LOOK TO
CHILDREN AT RIGHT. LASTLY AND
UNINTENDED. IS THAT SB TWO OH
THREE MANDATE A COURT SHALL
CONSIDER A VIOLATION OF IT AND
CHARACTER EVIDENCE AGAINST THE
POLICE OFFICER. THIS MEANS AS
LONG AS THAT OFFICER IS WORKING
THE YOUTH WILL BE CALLED
REPEATEDLY TO TESTIFY ABOUT
THIS POSSIBLE VIOLATION OF
THEIR RIGHTS IN THEIR PAST. BUT
YOU WHO SUPPOSED TO BE
BENEFITING FROM JUVENILE
JUSTICE REFORMS. PROMISED TO
SEAL THEIR RECORDS AS THOUGH
THERE THAT NEVER HAPPENED
INSTEAD THAT USE WILL BE.
DEEMED TO HAVE TO REPEAT THAT
AGAIN AND AGAIN THERE ARE NO
EXCEPTIONS TO AVOID THIS. NOW
PLEASE THIS WILL DELAY THE- AND
DID NOT EVEN ACCESS TO. SB TWO
OKAY MAKE FOR LAW PRACTICE AND
THE OUTCOME WOULD BE OFFICE OF
ITS PURPOSE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND CONSIDERATION AND FOR
THIS PRIVILEGE TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF THE CDA AND- CDA AND
ASK THAT YOU VOTE NO ON THE B.
Q. A THREE. Q. THANK YOU. ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES WITHIN THE
HEARING ROOM IN OPPOSITION. ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES ON A
TELECONFERENCING. CALLED UP IN
OPPOSITION. ARE THERE ANY
DIALING WITNESSES. THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK ON THAT MISTER
MODERATOR. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WHEN CAMP YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. CAN CURE
IN OPPOSITION THESE PRESS ONE
ZERO. WE DO HAVE ONE IN OUR
QUEUE- WE WILL GO TO NUMBER.
ONE FIFTY THREE. ONE FIFTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. A
LITTLE BIT CALIFORNIANS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. I ONCE AGAIN TURN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NONE
IN THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU WILL
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. THE BILL. HAS BEEN
MOVED TO SECOND HASN'T. YES
MISS RIP BAKER OUR QUE HAN
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- I JUST
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THE BILL I THINK THAT
I COULDN'T SAY IT AS WELL AS
THE JOURNEY DID IN TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT BUT ALL OF US
SITTING HERE TODAY TOOK AN OATH
TO UPHOLD THE CON CAN END OF IT
AND I THINK. THEY DID EXACTLY
DURING TODAY THIS. AGAIN THE
RIGHT COST. MEANING LESS WEEKS
PROTECT LIKE THOSE IN AROUND.
AND FOR USED TO BE INTERROGATED
WITHOUT UNDERSTANDING IS RIGHT
AND LIKE YOU SAID WE KNOW THAT
MANY ADULTS DON'T EVEN
UNDERSTAND RATES. IS JUST NOT
MEETING FOR APPLICATION OF THE
CONSTITUTION AND SO I THANK YOU
FOR DOING THIS AND MAKING SURE
THAT OUR YOUTH ARE PROTECTED IN
THE CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT. TO
GIVE. HER ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. CENTER BRADFORD YOU
MAY CONCLUDE. THANK YOU MISTER
MEMBERS AND I THINK THIS IS A
STRAIGHTFORWARD MEASURE I THINK
IT'S CLEARLY REPRESENTS THE
BEST OF WHO WE ARE AS A COUNTRY
WHEN WE LOOK AFTER. OUR YOUTH
IN THIS COUNTRY- IT'S AMAZING
THAT. INDIVIDUAL WHO ARE NOT
CONSIDERED AN ADULT UNTIL
THEY'RE EIGHTEEN. WE FIND OUT.
RESPONSIBLE ENOUGH TO BE
INTERROGATED BY THEMSELVES
WITHOUT FIRST CONSULTING AN
ATTORNEY. THIS ONLY PROVIDES A
CLEAR UNDERSTANDING FOR YOUTH
MANY TIMES AS- A- DO NOT. STAND
BILLS RIGHT BEFORE. THERE ANTI.
SILVA HOW DO WE PUT THE TWO. OF
A- AND- MINERS SIMPLY BE THEY
ARE IN THE CUSTODY OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT THIS IS A PROBLEM.
MEASURE THANK YOU. FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD THE- AND I. IN YOU
MAY CALL THE ROLL. SB TWO OR
THREE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER HI JOHN SIR IRAQI LACKEY
NO POWER CAN PARA QUE HANNAH
THANK YOU DEEP. DID NOT VOTING
KAMLAGER KAMLAGER HIGH COURT
WHEN I WORKED HI SAN DIEGO.
STONE STONE HI THAT MEASURE
PASSES THAT MEASURE PASSES
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS THANK
YOU. I LOOKING FOR SENATOR
DORADO BEFORE I SKIPPED IT.
OKAY SO WE HAVE TO RAZA. NEXT
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN IS THAT YOU
OR BUT THAT CENTAURO. ELEVEN
ELEVEN. SB ELEVEN ELEVEN. RT.
SAYS IT ROBBIE. IF YOU DON'T
MIND BECAUSE WE'RE WE'RE HERE.
WHO CAN WE ALLOW TO SENATOR
HERTZBERG. THE MAJORITY LEADER
TO COMMENT PRESENT RIGHT NOW SO
WE DON'T HOLD YOU UP. I KNOW
YOU'RE VERY VERY BUSY. I THERE
SEEMS TO BE A LOT GOING ON
RIGHT NOW TO THE PODIUM. IT WAS
A BIG POST OTHER. EVERYBODY SB
THREE ONE FIVE CREASE TO
CULTIVATE NINETEEN ALTERNATIVE
EDUCATION PROGRAM WHICH WOULD
RESULT IN THE DISMISSAL PENDING
CRIMINAL CHARGES AFTER A SIX
MONTH PERIOD FOR AN OUT OF
CUSTODY DEPENDING IF THE
DEFINITIVE VOICE FURTHER
CRIMINAL CHARGES AND MEETS
ADDITIONAL CRITERIA. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MAKE IT FAST THANK
YOU. WE JUST. WE'VE BEEN
HEARING I CAN GIVE YOU THE
SPECIFICS BUT I DON'T I DON'T
NEED TO DEALING WITH THE
EXTRAORDINARY BACKLOG IN THE
COURTS. BECAUSE THE COLD IT NOT
JUST THE PEOPLE BEING ARRESTED
FROM THE PROTESTS BUT ALSO JUST
GENERALLY AND SO THIS THIS IDEA
CAME TO ME ACTUALLY FROM THE
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE IN SAN
FRANCISCO IN A COALITION IN
ADDITION TO THOSE RECORDS THE-
SOCIAIS SHOULD A PUBLIC
DEFENDERS IN THE ACLU. AND I
JUMPED ON IT BECAUSE- YOU KNOW
WE HAVE REALLY BEEN GRAPPLING
WITH THIS COURT FUNDING
MANAGEMENT PROCESS FOR A LONG
TIME. TWENTY FOUR YEARS AGO
WHEN I WAS SIT IN YOUR CHAIR
VENTURE- CHAIRMAN- WE HAD THE
UNBELIEVABLE YOU KNOW WE
ADOPTED ACTUALLY THE TRIAL
COURT FUNDING ACT OF NINETEEN
NINETY SEVEN WE'VE GONE UP AND
DOWN AND IT'S REALLY DIFFICULT
AS WE TRY TO MANAGE THE THREE
BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT. AND ALL
THE CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE IN
THE DOWNTURN OF ONE POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS IN THE- IT DID
YOU DO BRANCH. TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT TWO THOUSAND TWELVE. SO
HERE WE ARE TRYING TO. BAIL
TRYING TO DEAL WITH THESE
EXTRAORDINARY BACKLOGS WHICH
YOU'LL HEAR FROM THE WITNESSES
IF YOU LOOK AT THE BUG WITH
THEY GAVE YOU. FORTY EIGHT
THOUSAND PENDING CASES AND SAID
DIEGO FIFTEEN THOUSAND CASES
SANTA CLARA. FOURTEEN HUNDRED
JURY TRIALS SO HOW DO YOU COME
UP WITH A THOUGHTFUL APPROACH.
THAT TO ME IS THAT AND IF YOU
OF THE PART OF LOW LEVEL OF. TO
WE HAVE A OF ALL THE THINGS
THAT ARE OTHERWISE INCLUDE. AND
WE MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE UP YOU
HAVE RESTITUTION TO PAY PEOPLE
BACK IF THERE'S A PROBLEM. BUT
IF YOU'RE NOT GET THE TROUBLE.
YOU HAVE TROUBLE YOU DON'T GO
INTO CUSTODY. AFTER SIX MONTHS
WE CAN DISPOSE OF THIS YOU KNOW
I KNOW THERE'S QUESTIONS ABOUT
HOW MUCH IT WILL COST HOW MUCH
IT WILL SAVE. YOU TO THE ASPEN
SO THE DOCUMENTS. COULD BE AS
MUCH AS TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS. BUT TURN ON PRESS.
TIMES WE ALL KNOW IT'S THIS IS
ONE OF THOSE SCOLDED RELATED.
MEASURES WHERE WE'RE TRYING TO.
COME UP WITH SOME THOUGHTFUL
APPROACH WHERE THEY USE YOU
KNOW A FEW YEARS YOU KEEP YOUR
NOSE CLEAN SO TO SPEAK YOU
DON'T GET IN TROUBLE FOR SIX
MONTHS. THAT YOU KNOW YOU DON'T
HAVE TO CALL UP THE COURT
SYSTEM I'VE GOT SOME WITNESSES
TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF. I CAN
ANSWER MORE QUESTIONS. WHAT
WILL WE GET THE QUESTIONS BUT I
WANTED TO JUST FIND THAT OUT
FOR EVERYBODY HERE GET TURNED
OVER TO THE WITNESSES. WHICH.
SHE CARED NEXT DOOR TO OPEN
WITH THE LOS ANGELES PUBLIC
DEFENDER IN CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UNDER DISCUSSION HAD. YEAH YEAH
I I'VE TWENTY OF THE WITNESSES
ARE. YEAH MADIGAN UNDER.
ANOTHER SEVEN YEARS YES. I'M
SORRY I CAN'T HEAR IF I'M IF I
SHOULD START I'M SORRY MY MIKE
WAS ANNOYED YOU MAY BEGIN. YOU
MEDICARE. MEDICARE AND MEMBERS
MY NAME IS NICK. NOT A LOT
ANGELA PUBLIC DEFENDER AND I'M
HERE TODAY ET ON BEHALF OF THAT
THE THREE FIFTEEN IS A MEMBER
OF THE BOARD CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDER ASSOCIATION. USING
METRICS ORIGINAL DESIGN BUT THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL THREE FIFTEEN
DIRECTED THE UNPRECEDENTED
BACKLOG OF CASES THAT OUR COURT
SYSTEM. AS A RESULT OF THE
CORONAVIRUS EMIC. THE BILL
MANDATED MEDICAL TOM NON.
NONVIOLENT CASES BUT ONLY IF
THE INDIVIDUAL HAS ALREADY BEEN
RELEASED FROM CUSTODY HAS
DEMONSTRATED THAT HE OR SHE CAN
AVOID FUTURE VIOLATIONS OF LAW.
AGREED TO PAY RESTITUTION TO
ANY VICTIM LIKE DEFENSE AND
INVALID BY A JUDGE. GOT A CALL
THE STRUGGLING RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE THE AND DEMOCRATS
CREATED A PREVIOUSLY
UNIMAGINABLE BACKLOG OF CASES.
THE BACKLOG INCREASE EVERY DAY.
I THANK YOU. BUYERS SHOULD THE
BACKLOG OF NOT ONLY GET ON. MY
TRACK PUBLIC HEALTH. BY YOUR-
ARE LARGE NUMBER OF PEOPLE TO
WORK CLOSELY TOGETHER A SMALL
SPACE. MAKING HEALTHCARE COSTS
IN COURTROOM DIFFICULT IF NOT
IMPOSSIBLE. A JURY TRIAL FOR
EXAMPLE OF WHICH I'VE DONE MANY
INVOLVED ACROSS. THE TEN.
CURRENT BACKLOG HAS RESULTED
CORONAVIRUS WOULD REQUIRE MORE
THAN FOURTEEN HUNDRED CASES TO
BE SET FOR TRIAL. IN A SINGLE
WEEK. COMING STANDARD THIRTY
SIX PERSON JURY PANEL THAT
REQUIRE MORE THAN. THOUSAND
JURORS TO APPEAR IN WALKING
WITH COUNTY COURT. A CLEAR PATH
HEALTH. CONSIDERING THAT THERE
ARE FEWER THAN TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY TRAVEL KNOWLEDGE A.
COUNTY. CONDUCTING THAT MANY
AND IS ALL. SIMPLY BECAUSE-
THANK OF GOD WORKED IN BECAUSE
THE DAM AND THEN ACCORDING
UNDER. COULD NOT TAKE. AND
WE'RE AGAIN. AND I DO WANT.
YOUR BACK IN AND YOU KNOW THE
ITS REALLY EASY FOR ALL OF US I
THINK TO GET LAW. INTO NUMBERS
AND THAT SOMETIMES WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT ACT PEOPLE. ONE
OF THE NUMBERS THAT WE'VE BEEN
TO BELOW TO A MAN IN SOUTH GADO.
HE WAS AT A DEAD PUBLIC
DEFENDER IN MY- HE WAS MY- EVEN
THE FONG. DAUGHTER HE KEPT
GOING TO WORK. AND ON MAY
TWENTY. AFTER BEING WITH. DIED
HE WITH THE FOR PUBLIC IN STATE.
MAKE AND SACRIFICING LIMITED
RESOURCES AND ENDANGERING
PUBLIC HEALTH TO PURSUE ONE
NECESSARY PROSECUTION CAN NO
LONGER BE ACCEPTED WE HAVE TO
REGROUP AND FOCUS OUR LIMITED
RESOURCES WE WOULD DO THE MOST
GOOD. I PROVIDING SERVICES THAT
SUPPORT AND PURSUING ONLY CASES
WHICH GENERALLY NEED TO BE
PURSUED. IN SHORT. SHARE AND
MEMBERS THIS BILL WOULD NOT
LEAD ANYONE GETTING OUT OF JAIL
WITH THE BILL WOULD NOT ALLOW
PEOPLE WHO ARE PUBLIC THANK YOU
READY TO HAVE THEIR CAKE THE
MATH AND THE BILL WOULD NOT
LEAVE ANY VICTIM WITHOUT THE
FROM APPLICATION- IF THE
NECESSARY AND THE POINT-
VITAMIN NEEDED. REFORM AT THE
END OF THE BACK LOT CAUGHT BY
COLOGNE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
C. NOW ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT EITHER IN
THE- IN THE ROOM. OR ON VIDEO
CONFERENCING. OR BY TELEPHONE
MISTER MODERATOR. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES MIGHT SUPPORT. JAN
LAYS IN GERMAN ON THE PHONE
LINE IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AGAIN ONE
ZERO IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT. AND
FIRST BILL GO TO NUMBER THIRTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. STE
CANACCORD ARE NOW ON BEHALF OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE AT PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF SB THREE FIFTEEN
ALTHOUGH I THINK THE PART ON
BEHALF OF THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE AND
SANTA CLARA COUNTY PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE. THANK YOU.
NEXT ONE OF THE TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THEY DROPPED- WILL GO TO NUMBER
ONE SIXTY FIVE ONE SIXTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
JIM WOOD BURKE ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION THE CALIFORNIA
STRONG SORT OF SB THREE ONE
FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
UP THE NUMBER THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MIKE A
DOCTOR OFF ON BEHALF OF THE
ACLU OF CALIFORNIA WE ARE A
COUPLE PROUD CO SPONSOR OF THE
LEGISLATION AND ALSO VOICING
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF REFORM
ALLIANCE CALIFORNIANS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE ON COMMON
LAW. SMART JEFF THIS CALIFORNIA
AND INITIATE. THEM THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU. NEXT WILL BE
NUMBER ONE SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LITTLE WITH CALIFORNIANS
FOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE AND
STRONG SUPPORT. NEXT WILL BE
TWENTY SEVEN NUMBER TWENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. EIGHT
HUNDRED YEARS WITH CUT FIFTY
PROD CO SPONSOR OF SB THREE
FIFTEEN HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR. NEXT
WILL BE NUMBER SEVENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CONGRESS WOULD
TALK ABOUT IT BE BUG IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NOW WE GO
TO NUMBER ONE SIXTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SEAN MCGILL COMMUNITY
COALITION MORE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. NEXT WILL BE ONE SIXTY
SEVEN NUMBER ONE SIXTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NUMBER ONE
SIXTY SEVEN LINES OPEN. MOVED
UP ONE THIRTY NINE NUMBER ONE
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. M.
CATHY COOK WITH IT AND SHE JEFF
AND JOHN. THANK YOU. NEXT WILL
BE NUMBER FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OKAY OF COURSE I WITHOUT
COMBINED WITH THE FACT THAT
FOUR ONE THIRD ENOUGH THE WAY
YEAH COUNTY. THANK YOU. NEXT TO
BE NUMBER SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. OKAY THE COALITION TALKS
ABOUT THANK YOU. NO ONE CAN
LAYS IN GERMAN IF YOU'D LIKE TO
VOICE SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I WILL GO TO
NUMBER ONE SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE
MAKE SURE NOT ON MUTE. THANK
YOU FOR CARRYING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO
NUMBERS SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RAJ SHAH THE SILICON
VALLEY DE BUG WHERE PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF SB THREE FIFTEEN AND
ALSO YOUR TO SHARE THE STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE ONLY MURDER
PROJECT MEANS YOU HAVE RESTORED
JEFF THE SILICON VALLEY AND OF
LACI P. SAMMA TAIL
PARTICIPATORY DEFENSE PROJECT
SAN DIEGO. THANK YOU THANK YOU
TOOK IN A LOT OF PEOPLE ONE
TIME DISCRETE. THE NEXT WILL BE
NUMBER ONE SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SENATE CONSERVATIVES
ARE CIRCUMVENT THE BOOK IN
SUPPORT THANKS THANK YOU. OUR
NEXT WE'RE GOING TO NUMBER ONE
SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FILE PHOTO BY METERS FROM AT
THE THREE- IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THE NEXT WHERE THE
NUMBER ONE SEVENTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. PRIVATE ROSY WITH
PHILIP ON VALLEY VIEW BUT AGAIN
ON ON STRUCTURE FOR. THANK YOU.
AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO NUMBER
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE NAY BAKER WITH PHILLIP CON
BALLY PETER WEREN'T STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. EXCELLENT
NUMBER ONE SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS PUBLICLY ET AND I'M
FROM SB FIFTY AND WOMEN CAN AND
WE ARE AND STRONG SUPPORTER OF
ATHLETES FOR OUTBACK THANK YOU.
ANEXO THE NUMBER ONE SEVENTY
THREE. ONE SEVENTY THREE PLEASE
MAKE SURE NOT YOU. HI THIS IS
TINA LOUISE I'M CALLING FROM S.
B. C. C. COMMUNITY WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR OH NINE.
THANK YOU. OUR NEXT WITH THE
NUMBER SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SIXTY TWO PLEASE MAKE
SURE NOT I'M YOU. WITH TWENTY
THREE AND WHAT. THANK YOU. NOW
WE'RE GOING TO NUMBER ONE
EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
OKAY THANK YOUNG WOMAN WHO CAN
CENTER WITH THEIR FREEDOM
COALITION ABOUT COPART. INC
ABOUT THE POLITICAL. AND ONCE
AGAIN LAYS IN GERMAN IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO
FURTHER IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE MR CAL. ANY NOT FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT I HAVE A-
MINIS NINA SOLANO. BATSMAN
ENDED GERALDINE WILLIAMS. IN
OPPOSITION I'M SORRY IN
OPPOSITION PRESIDENT OF CRIME
VICTIMS UNITED CALIFORNIA N. D.
D. A. FROM ORANGE COUNTY. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE TO FIFTEEN ONE
O'CLOCK MONDAY I'M THE
PRESIDENT OF CRIME VICTIMS
UNITED THAT I RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE EIGHTY THIRTEEN. THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF AB
CRICKET PAID WILL SEVERELY
IMPACT OF THE CRIME IN OUR
STATE AND PLACEMENT OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE IN JEOPARDY THE TWO
THOUSAND THANK CALIFORNIA WAS A
LEADER IN THE NATION WILL BE
ENACTED A CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT
TO CALL. WHICH IS NOT A- THE
RIGHT TRACK YOU SHOULDN'T BUT
THE RIGHT TO BE HER. THE RIGHT
TO KEEP. AND THE RIGHT TO HAVE
THEIR CASES ADJUDICATED. AB
THREE FIFTEEN NOT ONLY NORTH
DESPITE THAT ACTUALLY O'CLERY
BUT BY ALLOWING THE VICTIMS NOT
TO HAVE THEIR DAY IN COURT. AND
THE DISMISSIVE ATTITUDE THAT
THESE ARE ONLY LOW LEVEL CRIMES
THAT ARE GOING TO BE DISMISSED.
IS OFFENSIVE TO THOSE WHO ARE
VICTIMS OF CRIME DEVOTO. COULD
THEMSELVES IF YOU. TRAFFICKING
OF A CHILD AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENC THESE ARE NOT
VICTIMLESS CRIMES THAT WILL BE
DISMISSED IF THIS IS AN ACT. I
DON'T. JUST TO. THE RIGHT MARK.
THANK DAVIS COURT BUT IS
EXACTLY WHAT AB THREE FIFTY.
SECONDLY AT ALL PLAYS WHICH AND
L. WHO ARE MOST IN JEOPARDY
BECAUSE BY DOING AN ABSOLUTE
DISMISSAL MANY OF THESE CRIMES
THERE WILL BE NO RECORD OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE TRYING TO OBTAIN
POSITION COULD BE CARETAKERS OF
THESE PEOPLE PLACING THEM IN
JEOPARDY AND MAKING THEM
POSSIBLE VICTIMS. I STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB THREE FIFTEEN ON
BEHALF OF ALL CALIFORNIANS
CRIME VICTIMS AND I BURGEONING
NOVO RESPECTFULLY THANK YOU
THANK YOU. CHAU JODY WILLIAMS.
JERRY MORRIS CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES. AT THE WRONG NAME BECAUSE
YOUR VOICE IS PRETTY DEEP FOR
JODIE. WHAT. THANK YOU MISTER
LEARN MORE SO BE HAPPY
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE REGRETFULLY
OPPOSED SB THREE FIFTEEN UNLESS
IT IS AMENDED WHILE WE
RECOGNIZE AND RESPECT SENATOR
HERTZBERG'S MOTIVES IN
SPONSORING THIS LEGISLATION THE
PROPOSAL SIMPLY AND ARBITRARILY
WIPES THE SLATE CLEAN FOR THOSE
CHARGED WITH BOTH FELONIES AND
MISSED MISDEMEANOR EXISTING
MANY KNOWS THE PANDEMIC HAS
CREATED HAVE A COURT ROOM. CAN
HAVE BEEN WITH PLAYED ORDER
THAT. OF ALL JUSTICE PART. THIS
BILL THE OFFERS ON ACCOUNT. NO
OVER. PASSED THOSE CHARGED WITH
THEM WHY RANGE CLIENTS SHE
BECAUSE THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM HAS BEEN JUST READ
THROUGH NO FAULT OF THE TONE
AND THE DELIVERY PROCESS THESE
CASE. UNDER THE PROVISIONS OF
THE BILL THE CRIMES INCLUDED IN
THE SWEEPING PAST ARE SUCH
SERIOUS VIOLENT FELONIES A
SOLICITATION FOR MURDER HATE
CRIMES AND MAJOR FOR. MISSING
IT SO POLIO A COMPLETELY ORDER
PASSAGE OF TIME IN SOME CASES
YEARS AHEAD OF THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS THE NUYS VICTIMS
ARE CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO
CONFER WITH THE PROSECUTION.
AND TO HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HEARD BY THE COURT THE BILL
IS ALSO DISTURBINGLY SILENT ON
WHETHER A DEFENDANT CAN CREATE.
THE SIX MONTH PERIOD BY
SPEAKING TO CONTINUE A CASE.
CLEARLY INDEPENDENT SHOULD NOT
BE ABLE TO KICKED THE CASE DOWN
THE ROAD IN ORDER TO AVAIL
HIMSELF OR HERSELF. REALLY THE
BILL. WE JUST GOOD TO CENTER
HERTZBERG STAFF THAT CDA WOULD
REMOVE ITS OPPOSITION YEP THE
COKE NINETEEN ALTERNATIVE
EDUCATION PROGRAM WAS LIMITED
TO MISDEMEANORS WERE SPECIFIED
EXCLUSIONS INCLUDING DELIGHTS
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND- DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SEX OFFENCES. AND
CLEARING ON IN THE WEST BANK
WHICH WAS ADOPTED TO PREVENT A
DEPENDENT FROM MANUFACTURING TO
CONTINUE WANTS TO QUALIFY FOR
THE DUPES DISMISSAL. WE HOPE TO
CONTINUE THAT CUSTOMER RECORDS
BURKE YEAH WHAT. BILLS BY THE-
SOUTH OF HELP FOR HIS. USES
SHALL THE GROUP PUBLIC CREATE
BY THE COLBERT NINE PANDEMIC
OFF WHAT IS THIS A STATE AND
HAPPY GIVE OF ACCOUNT OF EVERY
FOR CONDUCT AND A FOR OF
CONSTANT RIGHT UNLESS AMENDED
CD RESPECTFULLY. AND ASK FOR
YOUR NOTEBOOK THANKS SIR THANK
YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IN THE
ROOM. ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ON THE
TELECONFERENCING. OR AND FROM.
ANY WITNESSES OPPOSITION ON THE
DIAL IN PHONE- MISTER MODERATOR.
HELLO YOU CAN JUMP ON THE
PHONES IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION. PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. I WILL GO TO NUMBER FORTY
FIVE OF FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS ANNA KELLY ON
BEHALF OF THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE WORK
CURRENTLY IN OPPOSITION AS WELL
WE HAVE HAD SOME CONSTRUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE AND HOPE TO CONTINUE TO
DO SO. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ONCE AGAIN AFTER ON THE PHONES
IN LIKE TO VOICE OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AT THIS
TIME THERE ARE NO FURTHER IN
THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU ARE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. MISTER BARKHANE. WE I
HAVE WELL THANK YOU SENATOR FOR
BEING HERE AND I HAVE TO
COMMEND YOU FOR SEEING A PRO
BRINGING A BILL TO ADDRESS THE
PROBLEM IN MY DISCUSSIONS
AROUND THIS BILL IT WAS
PRESENTED AS ONE THAT ALLOWS
FOR JUDICIAL DISCRETION I'M NOT
SURE I READ THE BILL THAT WAY
SO I WANNA. VERIFIES SO IT
ALLOWS FOR A JUDGE TO- NOT.
AVAIL THEMSELVES OF THIS
PROCESS IF THERE'S AN
UNREASONABLE RISK OF DANGER TO
PUBLIC SAFETY WHICH IS DEFINED
AS- AND REGIONAL WEST OF THE
PETITIONER WILL COMMIT A NEW
VIOLENT FELONY. NOW IF THE
JUDGE FINDS THAT'S THEN THE
INDIVIDUALS NOT ELIGIBLE. FOR
THIS PROGRAM IF YOU WELL. BUT
THAT SEEMS TO BE THE SOLE.
DISCRETION UNDER THE BILL THE
BILL SAYS THAT THE JUDGE SHALL
DISMISS THE CASE SO AS LONG AS
THE CRITERIA IT HERE MATT THE
JUDGE DOESN'T HAVE DISCRETION
IN THAT THAT DISCUSSION SEEMS
TO BE FAIRLY LIMITED. CAN YOU.
RESPOND TO THAT YEAH I THINK
THAT WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
IT'S A DELICATE BALANCE I CAN
**** ON THESE OTHER QUESTIONS.
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING IS
THAT LOOK. WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
COME UP WITH SOMETHING THAT'S
INTELLIGENT HERE GIVEN THE
CIRCUMSTANCES RIGHT THIS IS A
PERFECT FIT SECTION SHALL NOT
APPLY. RETROACTIVELY ANY
CHARGERS ALL BY CONVICTION
PRIOR TO JANUARY NE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND IT IS EFFECTIVE
ONLY UNTIL JERRY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO ZERO SHORT WINDOW.
AND YES THE JUDGE HAS
DISCRETION BUT THERE'S NO
DETERMINATION OF WHAT THAT IS
IF THE JUDGE IF SOMEBODY'S
REARRESTED IT DOESN'T APPLY
SOMEONE'S IN CUSTODY IT DOESN'T
APPLY. JUST UP WITH THAT WAS
MADE WITH RESPECT TO THE CRIME
VICTIMS. PRESENTED TO THE JUDGE.
OF COURSE AND THAT'S WHAT THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH IS FOUR TWO
RIGHT IT IS A SERIES OF LAWS
AND RULES SURROUNDING THE
JUDGES AND WHAT THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO DO. AND WE'VE SET.
THE AGREEMENTS THAT WERE MADE
WE'VE GOT A HOPE WE'VE LISTED
IT UNBELIEVABLY LONG LIST OF
EXCLUDED OFFENSES. IF YOU'RE IN
CUSTODY IT DOESN'T APPLY. TO
THE I THINK THAT WHEN YOU LOOK
AT IT IN TOTALITY ENTERTAINS OF
HOW IT OPERATES. I THINK IT
MAKES SENSE- BECAUSE WE TRY TO
GET PEOPLE WHO. ARE REAL
PROBLEMS AND HEART COMMITTING
PROBLEMS IN SOCIETY AND- THE
OTHERS. PRESSTITUTE THE LIKE
THOSE THINGS CAN BE TAKEN CARE
OF THE- DISTRICT ATTORNEY
SUPPOSED TO NOTIFY. WHAT TO DO.
THE SHIP GOES ON THE GIVING
THAT JUST YEAH THE PROJECT MAKE
A FINDING THAT NOT IT DOESN'T
APPLY SO I THINK IF AND WHEN
SAID COURT MAY DISMISS I WOULD
FEEL LIKE THERE'S MORE TO XIN.
DISMISSED TO ME IT IS THESE.
AFTER THAT. THAT'S MY RE OF THE
BILL SO GUESS ARE YOU A TO ON
LIKE IF I HERE FROM YOU AND I
WAS HERE THIS IS A FREE PRIOR
TO DOING THAT THE IDEA HERE
SHE'S. I DON'T THAT INTO WHICH
GET BECAUSE MY CONCERN. THERE
I'M HAPPY. THAT NOT THAT YOU'D
LIKE GOOD YEAH PLEASE I GET THE
IDEA OF A WITH. YES ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SO YOU'RE YOU'RE RIGHT
THAT IF CERTAIN CONDITIONS ARE
SATISFIED. THE AD JUDGE'S
DISCRETION IS LIMITED STATE
SITUATION WHERE THE DEFENDANTS
LIKELY TO COMMIT A VIOLENT
OFFENSE. HOWEVER ONE OF THOSE
CONDITIONS ONE OF THE PRE
REQUISITE CONDITION IS THAT THE
JUDGE HAS ALREADY ACTORS. HIS
OR HER DISCRETION TO RELEASE
THAT PERSON. IN OTHER WORDS.
BUT AT THE THANK YOU READ
ANYWAY SHAPE OR FORM AND HAS
DECLINED TO RELEASE THE PURSE
WON'T BE OUT AND THEREFORE
WON'T QUALIFY THE BILL. MY
SCRATCHING THEY DON'T GET AND
IF THE STRIKE ABOUT BETWEEN FOR
TRYING TO CAPTURE THAT THE HIGH
END CASES. WHILE AND ALLOW TO
HELP GOOD GRIEF ITS PRIORITIES
AWAY FROM WHAT. AND THAT. LET
ME ASK ALSO IT WOULD DOES NOT
DIRECTLY RELATED BUT YOUR
QUESTION INFORMS THE LAST FIVE
YEARS OF MY LIFE IN DETERMINING.
NOW THE ROLE THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH AND SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE IN THE
PROVINCIAL BRANCH I'VE
CERTAINLY FACE THAT THE BAIL
ARGUMENT. AS TO WHETHER THE
JUDGES WAX. QUESTION OR WHETHER
THEY'LL JUST PUT UP A BALLOT
SOME. AND THIS WHOLE DYNAMIC
ABOUT JUDGES. AT ITS HEART
QUESTION I'M NOT SUGGESTING IT
IS IT AND WE MADE THAT THE
SHALL. WE WANT WE DON'T JUDGE
IS JUST TO WORK OUT OF YOUR
CALL IF THEY DID THIS RIGHT. MY
GOD SOME. ONE OF THE STATE
REACHED STEP ANDERS IF YOU
HADN'T COMMITTED CRIME THERE
WAS NO OVER FIND WITH THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY AT THE END
THEY- COMES UP AND SAYS HEY
HERE'S A PROBLEM IT'S GOING TO.
YOU'RE PROBABLY PRETTY MUCH.
GREAT IS THERE TO THE DID THIS
PROGRAM ON APPLY. BUT TO TRY TO
MAKE IT MANAGEABLE AND- PART
ONCE YOU KNOW BECAUSE WE'VE GOT
THREE BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT WE
TRUST THE JUDICIAL BUT WE DON'T
REALLY TRUSTED. IN AWE I HAVE
GREAT REGARD FOR IT BUT IT'S
HARD RIGHT AND SO WE'RE TRYING
TO MEET THE BALANCES WE ARE
TRYING TO DO THIS NEAR THE BAY.
AND FIGURE A- SO. YOU KNOW. ALL
RIGHT GREEN GAINES RESTRAINT
ORDER DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SPOUSAL
RAPE STALKING FELONS THE WISE
ELDER ABUSE CHILD ABUSE LONG
LIST OF ALL THE THOSE THAT CODE
SECTION'S VIEW WE REFERENCE.
THE BILL SO WE'VE BEEN PRETTY
THOROUGH AND THAT STARTED WHERE
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL STARTED ON
THE COLBERT EXCLUSIONS IN WHAT
THEY WERE TRYING TO DO. SO IT'S
A ONE YEAR PROGRAM. IF WE ARE
SIGNIFICANT BORDERS AROUND TO
TRY TO MAKE IT WORK- THE PEOPLE
THAT CAME TO ME WITH THIS ARE
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN THE
COURTROOMS EVERY SINGLE DAY.
AND I AM THE AVERAGE YOU KNOW
PRETTY GOOD DISCOUNT. I THINK
IS A CITED BY THE MIDDLE SENSE
GIVEN THE CHALLENGES WE-
FACEBOOK SO BY. AM VERY.
DOESN'T LIKE IT SORRY MISTER
MORRIS MY FRIEND FOR A LOT OF
YEARS. BUT I THINK IT MEETS
BALLOTS THAT THAT IS A
RELATIVELY INTELLIGENT OF WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO UNDER THESE
VERY DIFFICULT CIRCUMSTANCES.
WHAT DO YOU. BRING FIFTY
THOUGHT. HOW DO YOU MEET THOSE
BACK. HOW DO YOU MAKE SURE THAT
YOU'RE PROTECTING PUBLIC
SAFETY. AND YET STILL HAVE
JUDICIAL BRANCH THAT OPERATES
YOU KNOW SO IT'S SO. IT'S BEEN
VERY CHALLENGING BUT I THINK
THE ALLERGIST. THANK YOU FOR
ELECTING. WELL I DON'T KNOW
WHERE TO BEGIN BUT THERE'S A
SONG ABOUT THAT. YEAH RIGHT NOW
OF THE TRAGIC SONG IN MY
OPINION ON THIS WHOLE.
CONSIDERATION I YOU KNOW I HAVE
DEEP RESPECT FOR YOU. MY
HEAVENS THIS SEEMS LIKE WHEN
YOU USE THE WORD BALANCE
CERTAINLY IN THAT BALLOT YOU
CAN'T. SOME OF THE STREET
FACING VICTIMS IN THIS PROPOSAL
BUT BECAUSE I HAD RESIDENTS
JUST LIKE YOU'LL PLEASE I DO
YEAH BECAUSE- THE CONSTITUTION
THE TUITION AS WAS SUGGESTED BY
THE OPPOSITION'S ARTICLE ONE
SUBSET OF THE CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTION. TALKS ABOUT
VICTIMS RIGHTS SECTION THREE
SECTION THREE B. I. BONTA THOSE
CONSTITUTIONAL PROVISIONS THERE
IS NOTHING HERE THAT PROHIBITS
VICTIMS RIGHTS THE WAY THE
PROCESS IS YOU KNOW FOR YOUR
PREVIOUS LIFE IS THAT THE DEBT
ATTORNEY FORM. AND THEN IT THEY
SHIP EVERY RIGHT TO BE HEARD
THERE IS. ISSUE HERE THAT
VIOLATES RIGHTS IT DOESN'T CALL
THEM OUT BUT YOU DON'T HAVE TO
CALL OUT FREE SPEECH EQUAL
PARTS OF THE LAW AT ALL
FRAMEWORKS THAT. HOUSTON EVERY
LOSS OF LIFE BY. SO THEY HAVE
TO BE NOTIFIED IF ANYBODY'S
NOTIFIED THE CONSTITUTION
APPLIES THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY
NOTIFIED US THAT THEY HAVE THE
RIGHTS THERE IS NO LIMITATION
HOWEVER. I WOULD BE THAT THE
FURTHERANCE OF JUSTICE ISN'T IT
IN VICTIMS RIGHT AND THIS IS
NOT BEEN NO WAY REPRESENTS THE
PREFERRED TO JUST JUST THING
AND- THAT IS. NOT BEEN DECATUR
AND BEING SUMMARILY DISMISSED
BECAUSE OF OVERCROWDING. THAT
TO ME IS A BUT DISMISSAL OF THE
BALANCE THAT- SHOULD TAKE PLACE
IN JUSTICE AND- THERE'S JUST A-
FOR EXAMPLE I MEAN THIS
UNREASONABLE RISK TO PUBLIC
SAFETY SOME STATUTES THAT ARE
REFERRED TO SPECIFIC. QUALIFIES
THAT DEFINITION IS NOT AS BROAD
AS- AS IF YOU'RE MAKING IT
SOUND IN MY OPINION BASED ON
WHAT I'VE BEEN TOLD. YEAH THIS
IS JUST VERY VERY SCARY TO ME
THAT SEEMS TO BE A DIRECT
ASSAULT AGAINST THE PUBLIC
SAFETY ASPECT CERTAINLY SIR.
IT'S A STRONG CONSIDERATION ON
RELIEVING THE COURTS OF THEIR
BACKLOG I SEE THAT BENEFIT. AND
I DON'T SEE THE BENEFIT AS FAR
AS GIVEN SOMEBODYA FREE PASS
BECAUSE WERE OVERCROWDED AYE
AYE. YEAH I'M I'M VERY VERY
SORRY THAT THIS IS. A GOOD
CHANCE OF PASSING. ALL OF MY
CLOTHES MISTER CHAIRMAN YES.
WHICH COME UNDER THE THANK YOU
SENATOR HERTZBERG FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD I- UNDERSTAND
THE REASONING FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD BECAUSE OF A CORONA
VIRUS. BUT I WOULD ACTUALLY
ARGUE THAT THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE SHOULD HAVE BEEN
LOOKING AT EVEN BEFORE THE- I
KNOW. ABOUT IN BELL IN- YOUR
STATEMENTS. THAT THIS WILL HELP
ALLEVIATE SOME OF THE BACKLOG
THAT'S HAPPENING IN OUR COURTS
AS ROADS ARE TO AS A RESULT OF
THE PANDEMIC. BUT I ALSO THINK
IT'S RESTING PLUGGING OF POOR.
THE REST OF THE DAY MAY BE
BECAUSE OF HOW WE USE THE
COURTS AT OPPORTUNITY IN A
SENSE TO KIND OF. TRY. I
NECESSARY. STOPPABLE CHARGES
USING THE SYSTEM TO FIGURE OUT
ALL OF THE DIFFERENT MOVERS
THAT CAN BE IMPLEMENTED TO
EIGHT HAVE MORE WILL GO TO
COURT SINCE WE RECOGNIZE THAT
IT'S PLOY. AND REVENUE
GENERATING SYSTEM AND ALSO TO
GIVE IN MY OPINION AND I KNOW
THIS IS BIASED DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS NUMEROUS BITES AT THE
APPLE WHEN IT'S ABOUT TRYING TO
CHARGE AND PROSECUTE- WELL I
ACTUALLY THINK THAT THIS IS. A
GOOD. OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO FIX
OUT HOW WE CAN CREATE GREATER
EFFICIENCY IN COURT SYSTEM. I
HAVE BEEN WITH NEW PEOPLE WHO
ARM THEMSELVES IN THE CAR
EVERYTHING DAY AND HAVE ALSO
HAD TO DURING THE PANDEMIC.
THEY TAUGHT ABOUT. THREE THESE
ARE THE FIRST HAS BEEN A LIMB
FROM THE PROCESS THESE THEY'RE
INVOLVED IN BAILIFFS CLERKS
JUDGES DISTRICT ATTORNEYS AND
DEFENSE COUNSEL ARE READING
WHAT THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO BE-
DELIVERING ARE MUCH MORE. THIRD
BECAUSE NOT TIME BASED BECAUSE
LIVES ARE AT STAKE AND IT'S
AMAZING THAT THIS KIND NATIONAL
PANDEMIC HAS BEEN NOTHING TO
ENCOURAGE THE COURTS TO GET
MORE OF FICTION AND THOUGHTFUL
ABOUT HOW THE SYSTEM IS USED I
THINK BECAUSE THEY WANT TO PUT
THE SPEECH WHAT. A SYSTEM BUT
AS I WROTE. ACTUALLY YOU JUST
FACT ONE DEFENDANTS WRITTEN IF
THEY ARE A CO BY CHARGED THANKS.
AND SO I THINK THAT'S ACTUALLY
WHERE WE SHOULD BE GULLWING
WITH HOW WE'RE TRYING TO
REIMAGINE JUDICIAL OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND I AM IDO
YOU FOR TAKING THE FUN YOU KNOW
I KNOW THAT. ON TOP OF ME PULSE.
BALLADEER'S INTO YOUR POINT
THEY- BECAUSE THEY ARE ALSO
SUBJECT TO THE SWEAT AS OF THE
POLITICAL AND CULTURAL WHIMS
AND THAT IS NOT WHAT SHOULD BE
USED WHEN YOU ARE DELIBERATING
SOMEONE'S FREEDOM AND CIVIL
LIBERTIES SO I STAY ALL SAY
THAT IS THE ARE WE SUPPORT THIS
OFF AND I. THEREFORE THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY BURKE ECONOMIST
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. YOU MAY
CLOSE MISTER THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I APPRECIATE
THE INSIGHT I LOOK. I WANT TO
ADDRESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LACKEY'S COMMENTS IN PARTICULAR
BECAUSE- I UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING. BUT WHEN YOU
WERE JUSTICE. YOU HAVE TO LOOK
AT THE TOTALITY OF THE
EXPERIENCE FROM THE BEGINNING
TO THE END. AND WE HAVE A WHOLE
HOST OF PUTTING CONSTITUTIONAL
CONSTRUCTS. ABOUT THE PEOPLE
ABOUT ENSURING JUSTICE AND
FAIRNESS ABOUT SPEEDY TRIALS.
AND ALL OF THE THINGS. AND SO
HERE WE ARE FROM THE
PROFESSIONALS IN THE COURT
ROOM- MY CONSULTED EITHER. THIS
LEAVE MYSELF WITH RIGHT I JUST
JUMPED UP. YEAH WHEN YOU LOOK
AT HOW IT'S CRAFTED RIGHT GIVEN
WHAT THE PRACTICAL REALITIES
ARE WHAT'S THE HARM TO PEOPLE
WHEN THEY'RE STILL SITTING
AROUND WHAT IMPACT ON THEIR
LIVES I DID HE HEAR IT SOMEBODY
NOT. SAFETY VALVE IN CASE
THERE'S A PROBLEM IN THE EVENT
THAT SOMEONE WHO HAS BEEN IN
CUSTODY THEY'RE NOT QUALIFIED.
CLEARLY VICTIM RIGHTS ARE BACK
TO THE CONSTITUTION IS NOW IN
POSITION THERE WE ADELINE HUJAN
CONCERNING RESTITUTION OF
SOMEBODY BUSTED SOMEBODY'S
WINDOW OR WHATEVER THE CASE MAY
BE TO MAKE SURE. THAT'S IN
FAIRNESS TO THE VICTIM AS- AND
SO I DON'T DISAGREE IT'S NOT
PERFECT. BUT WE ARE IN THE MOST
DIFFICULT OF TIMES WHERE IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE TO ADMINISTER
JUSTICE. ON THE COURT
CIRCUMSTANCES AS WAS AS WAS
ARTICULATED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COM OR- SO WHAT DO WE DO THAT
CREATES THE MOST BENEFIT TO THE
MOST PEOPLE. AN PROVIDE PUBLIC
SAFETY. AND ALL OF THE OTHER
BALANCING ACTS THAT WE HAVE TO
DO AND I DO THINK THAT THIS IS
A BALANCE AND THOUGHTFUL
APPROACH I'M NOT SUGGESTING
IT'S EASY. I'M NOT SUGGESTING
IT IS IN A WAY THAT COULD BE
THE CREDIBILITY CAN BE ATTACKED
ONE FORMER ANOTHER. BUT I THINK
I POSSIBILITY IN THIS JOB IS
LAWMAKERS IS TO MAKE THE TOUGH
CHOICES AND I THINK THAT THIS
DOES MAKE THE TOUGH CHOICE ARE-
AND FOR THAT I ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. SUCH THANK YOU. SHARES
AND I'M GLAD THAT YOU'RE
TALKING TO THE DA'S- WOULD LOVE
TO BE A FLY ON THE WALL WHEN
YOU AND MISTER MORRIS. GO
AHEAD- TO TRY TO MAYBE COME UP
WITH SOME SOLUTIONS THAT WILL
SATISFY BOTH BY THE BODIES BUT
I THINK THAT. WOULD BE A VERY
LONG DISCUSSION. AND PROBABLY
TAKE SEVERAL DAYS BUT I AM
COURAGE THAT THERE AT LEAST
SOME SOME OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
DIALOGUE AND IF YOU'RE WILLING
TO HAVE THAT SITUATION
RECOMMENDING. AND I SO THAT WE-
WE COULD. CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED.
MANCHESTER YOU MAY CALL THE
ROLL. ON SB THREE FIFTEEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER IRAQI.
LATINO BARRICADE HAN DEEP.
KAMLAGER QUIRK. SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO AYE STONE STONE HI
THAT MEASURE. IT MEASURES ON
CALL OKAY THANK YOU. SO WE WERE
GONNA GO BACK TO DIRAJA BUT
KAMLAGER IS NOT HERE NOW. GO
AHEAD BUT I WHAT I WANTED TO ON
BOTH. SO BUT BUILT MISTER
MCGUIRE MAYBE RIGHT AFTER
KAMLAGER GETS HERE. MAGUIRE'S
NEXT. YES MOVE THE BILL. SECOND.
THANK YOU SO MUCH A VERY
GRATEFUL I WILL BE BRIEF LAYS
IN GERMAN AND DO A TRUNCATED
VERSION IF THAT WOULD BE THE
WILL THE CHAIR YES ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU SO MUCH FIRST OF ALL
MISTER CHAIR- TO YOU AND YOUR
STAFF THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR ENGAGEMENT AND YOUR HARD
ON THIS ONE IS HOW GREAT WE ARE
TO BE IN FRONT OF YOU WANT TO
SAY THANK. IS THIS COULD. CAN
AND- I THANK THE MEMBER. FOR
HER PART. BILL ENGLISH HER IN A-
WELL. MY NAME IS ARE WE ALL
BENEFIT FROM THE FREE FROM THE
FREEDOM OF THE PRESS IS IT HELP
STRENGTHEN TO. KEEPS A CHECK
GOVERNMENT IN HEALTH INFORM OUR
DECISION. THAT'S IT NO THE
EARTH CRACKS YOU'RE IN THE IN
THE SICK TWENTY NOT HELPS THING
AMERICA'S. AMERICAN PEOPLE
EIGHTEEN. I I'M GONNA FACT
FORWARD HERE IN CITY CURRENTLY
IN STATE LAW REPORTERS ARE
GRANTED AUTHORITY TO ENTER
AREAS CLOSE BY LAW ENFORCEMENT
DURING NATURAL DISASTERS SUCH
AS- FIRES FLOODS AND
EARTHQUAKES IN ORDER TO. THEIR
INFORMATION. TO MADE TO THE
PUBLIC THEY CAN ALSO WATER
PERFUSED TIME TO NATURAL
DISASTER. THESE PER AT
PROTECTIONS HOWEVER DO NOT
EXPRESS THE EXTENT FIRST
AMENDMENT STRAIGHTENS. MARCH
RALLIES. AND TEST. AND WHAT SB
TWENTY NINE DOES IT EXTENDS
CRUCIAL PROTECTIONS A MEMBERS
OF THE- IS THE IN IN. EVENTS
PROTEC BY THE FIRST AMENDMENT
ADDITIONALLY THE BILL ALLOWS
REPORTERS TO CHANCE TO
CHALLENGE THE DETAINMENT OR
LACK OF ACCESS. BY WORKING WITH
POLICE OR LINE MANAGEMENT ON
SCENE AT THIS LANGUAGE PROVIDES
A NECESSARY SAFETY NET TO
REPORTERS WHO ARE NOT GRANTED
ACCESS OR INTENTIONALLY
DETAINED. MISTAKEN DETAINED. I
MISTER HERE I WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR TIME IN AND
IT WON A SAFETY YOU TO FOUR
THREE FOR THEIR ENGAGEMENT
EFFORT. MISTER WHO SINCERE HIS
TIME. THEIR RECENT REVENUE TO
THIS BILL WITH AMENDED THE BILL
TO REMOVE THE COMMUTER FOR
ATTENTION ASSAULTING
OBSTRUCTING OR- WITH NUMBER THE
MEDIA. HI THAT LANGUAGE TO SAY
INDIVIDUALS CARRYING
PROFESSIONAL BROADCASTING
RECORD. WOULD BE IDENTIFIED. AS
A MEMBER PRESS AND WE ALSO
REMOVE THE EVIDENTIARY
PRESUMPTION. IN THE BILL. I'LL
END IT RIGHT HERE AND YOU SAY.
MISTER CHAIR ON A KID ALONG.
I'M LITERALLY THE ONLY NON
POLICE OFFICER. IN MY FAMILY MY
DAD WAS A STETHOSCOPE A COP.
TWO GOALS ARE BOTH LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND MY- COUSIN IS A
BROTHER TO ME IS A DETECTIVE
SERGEANT WITH THE SANTA CLARA
SHERIFF'S OFFICE. AND I BRING
THAT FORWARD BECAUSE THERE
WOULD BE NOTHING NOTHING THAT I
WOULD EVER DO TO BE TO BRING
FORWARD LEGISLATION THAT THEM
IN TERMS WAY. AT THIS BILL
SUPPORT BASE. CALIFORNIA
NEWSPAPER PUBLISHERS. DIGNITY
SERVICES DEPARTMENT MEETING I
HAVE JIM WERE TURNED COUNSEL
CALIFORNIANS. PER IS. IT KEVIN
BAKER LEGISLATORS WITH THE- TO
BE TO BE ARE TO LEAVE WITNESSES
AGAIN MISTER CHAIR. OBS REALLY
GREW FOR YOUR ENGAGED THANK YOU
SO MUCH WHEN RESPECTFULLY ASK
HER ABOUT. THANK IN. NOW HERE
FROM YOU TO WITNESS IN SOME.
THANK A- MISTER MODERATOR. I
GUESS JIM YOU WORK IN KEVIN
BAKER WHICHEVER CAN GO FIRST C.
N. PA FOLLOWED BY KEVIN BAKER
ACLU. LIST BOTH ON THE PHONE.
MISTER CARE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TO SEE GIVE ME WERE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA NEWS
PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME TODAY
WOULD LIKE TO THANK. WIRING
YOUR STAFF THE TIME THAT THEY
SPENT. ON THIS IMPORTANT IF. WE
CHRONICLED MANY THE INTO THE IN
pCOMMITTEE THAT HAVE OCCURRED
SINCE THE- PROTESTS AFTER THE
ARE GEORGE WILL. AND SOME OF
THE PROBLEMS THAT DON'T SEVEN
COUNTY TRYING TO CHRONICLE
THOSE SITUATIONS- WHAT YOU HAVE.
YOU IS- BASED ON LAW THAT IS IN
EXISTENCE NOW AS FAR AS THE-
DEFINITION OF A- MEDIA.
REPRESENTATIVE IT'S BEEN YOU.
FOR DECADES- WHEN WRITING
SESSION TO IS OUR- FIRE. NO BY
WE CAN THIS IS A MARK PER. AND
.ORG ARRIVAL THANK VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. MISTER BAKER. YES
YOUR NUMBERS TO SCAN BAKER
CONNECTING CIVIL LIBERTIES
UNION OF CALIFORNIA I'LL BE
VERY BRIEF AS YOU MAY KNOW THE
ACLU HAS UNDERTAKEN TO
REPRESENT A NUMBER OF REPORTER
THAT HAVE BEEN THE VICTIM OF.
I'VE BEEN ATTEMPTING TO PROVIDE
COVERAGE FOR THE IN RECENT. YOU
MIGHT BILL SHOULD NOT BE
NECESSARY BUT REGRETTABLY IT IS
NEEDED BECAUSE REPORTERS HAVE
NOT ALL BEEN SUBJECT TO
EXCESSIVE FORCE. IT APPEARS
THAT IN MANY CASES THEY HAVE
BEEN SPECIFICALLY TARGETED IN
ORDER TO PREVENT THEM FROM
REPORTING ON THE INTERNET
ATTACHED. IS NOT IDLE A CLEAR.
A PART MANY AND THEY HAVE BEEN
REPEATED. PUBLIC OUTCRY. WE THE
BILL HAS FOR YOUR. THANK YOU.
NOW ARE ANY WHICH IS THE ROOM.
IF SUPPORT. ANY WITNESSES ON IT
IN SUPPORT AND IS THE MODERATOR
AND WITNESSES THERE ON DIALING
TELEPHONE IN SUPPORT. HAMLEYS
JOB IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
WE'LL GO TO NUMBER. TWO
HUNDRED. A LINE TWO HUNDRED
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE KEVIN PADRONE
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
BROADCASTERS ASSOCIATION WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX TWENTY
NINE THANK YOU SIR. THANK YOU.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO FURTHER
IN THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU NOW WILL
HAVE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION I
HAVE COREY SELLS IT FOR. A
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION BY PRODUCT AND RYAN
SURE. RIVERSIDE SHARES. THE
PROBLEM. THIS IS SOMETHING YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS. THANK YOU
THE TERM MEMBERS CORY CELLS ARE
LOW ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION-
REGRETFULLY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
SIX TWENTY NINE UNLESS IT IS
AMENDED- WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
WILLINGNESS TO HEAR OUR
CONCERNS- HE'S AMENDED THE BILL
AS HE NETTED- IN DIRECT
RESPONSE TO SOME OF OUR
CONCERNS. AND WE ARE VERY
GRATEFUL FOR. YES IF I START
WITH REMARK- BUT I WOULD. I
WOULD NOTE THAT THE BILL WOULD
STILL AFFIRMATIVELY ALLOW
MEMBERS OF THE PRESS TO ACCESS
AREAS THAT HAVE BEEN CLOSED. I
INCLUDING THE AREA AROUND THE
ANIMAL. AND POSTED A
DEMONSTRATION MARCH PROTEST
RALLY. CERTAINLY RESPECTING THE
RIGHTS OF THOSE WHO WISH TO
PROTEST IN THOSE WHOSE JOB IS
TO REPORT ON SUCH EVENTS. WE
RESPECTFULLY OBJECT THE
PROVISION THAT FURTHER- ALLOWS
ACCESS TO AN AREA THAT PEACE
OFFICERS DETERMINE NEEDS TO BE
RESTRICTED. SENSIBLY FOR PUBLIC
SAFETY. WE REMAIN WILLING TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHORED
COMMITTEE OTHER STAKEHOLDERS
BUT FOR THE REASONS STATED
ABOVE- WE RESPECTFULLY REMAIN.
OPPOSED TO SB SIX TWENTY NINE
UNLESS IT IS AMENDED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MISTER SHERMAN HM
YEAH MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
RANGE WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION- WE TO
REMAIN CALM OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL UNFORTUNATELY. IN CONTRA
TO WHAT SOME OF THE PREVIOUS
STUFF SUPPORTERS HAS FADED-
THIS BILL DOES NOT MAINTAIN THE
SAME DEFINITION OF WHAT A DULY
AUTHORIZED REPRESENTATIVE OF
NEW MEDIA YEAH IN FACT THIS
BILL SPECIFICALLY SPELLED OUT
THAT APPROACH TO HEAR EACH IN
GATHERED RECEIVING ARGUMENT.
INFORMATION APRIL SOME KIND OF
BILL CAR. EIGHT REPORTER AND
IT'S ITSELF IS THE A DO WE ARE
REP COULD CONCLUDE THAT THOUGHT
ATTENTION UP IN MY LOOK LIKE.
SURVEYING THE SCENE THEY HAVE A
CAR THERE ARE REPORTER THAT
THERE'S NO RISK THAT SUCH
PEOPLE ARE REQUIRE TO KERRY.
EIGHT OKAY PROVINCIAL OR
ANYTHING THAT WILL USUALLY JUST
THERE NEED TO BE THERE.
ADDITIONALLY HAVE THE PROBLEMS
WITH- HOW THE BILL WILL BE- IT
IN FACT. WORKING THAT THE BILL
WILL NOT ACTUALLY ADDRESS THE
ISSUE THAT THE AUTHOR IS HOPING
THAT IT WILL- IN THE FOR
EXAMPLE THE FIRST CITED BY THE
AUTHOR OF A NEED FOR THE BILL
COULD YOU AGENTS WOULD NOT HAVE
ARISEN- TO THE LEVEL OF
IMPLEMENTATION BECAUSE. B. R.
B. UNTIL. I'M PEOPLE ACTIVE
ACTIVITIES THEY ALWAYS WHERE
LAWS WERE BEING BUT- AND PEOPLE
WERE YOU KNOW BURNING CAR AND-
.COM CARS GOING LIKE THAT SO-
AND THERE'S ALREADY
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS YOU. CAN
DO THAT THE WILL. PROTECTIVE
TURN ARRIVE PERCIVAL RESCUE
WILL ONLY APPLIES. PEOPLE
DEMONSTRATE. AND WORKING FOR
THAT. THE DEATH CARE ARE MUCH
TOO- BROUGHT IN BETTER FOR
PROPORTIONATE AND WITH THAT- WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU IN OUR- SEIZE THE
AUDIENCE IN OPPOSITION. ANY.
VIDEO CONFERENCING ROOM. AND
NOW MISTER MODERATOR RT ANY
DIAL IN OPPOSITION. UNLADEN
GERMAN IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN ONE ZERO IF
YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION. OUR
FIRST TWO AGO TO NUMBER TWO OH
TWO A TO GO TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YOUR MEMBERS JONATHON
FELDMAN THE CALIFORNIA POLICE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION THE FIRST
ONE I THINK THE AUTHOR AND IT'S
BACK FOR ENGAGING WITH US ON
THIS ONE BUT UNFORTUNATELY OUR
CONCERNS REMAIN WE ARE POST
DISPATCHER. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
UNACCEPTED NUMBER ELEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR
SEAN RUN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PEACE OFFICERS ASSOCIATION ALSO
POSE FOR THE- VISION TO MENTION
BUT TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY IT
INDIGENOUS. BUT NEXT WE'RE
GONNA NUMBER TO FOURTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD MEDICARE MEMBERS
MATTHEW CYBERLINK ON THE APPLE
WATCH AND LOOK WE PROTECTED
LEGALLY CIRCUIT YOU'RE A LOT
AND LOOK AT SHARE ALSO PARK
THANK YOU. NEXT TO A NUMBER TO
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MEMBERS OF BRANDON UP ON BEHALF
OF ALL OF THE AND WEBER L. A.
COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
ALSO IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. HANNAH AGAIN IF YOU
ARE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. A NEXT WITH A NUMBER
TWO OF SEVEN TWO OF SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS EARN READ
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF AB WITHDRAWAL
AND THEN ALSO FOR ACT- I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING
WITH US. BUT WE HAVE MADE SOME
PROGRESS BUT WE STILL WOULD
LIKE TO SEE FURTHER AMENDMENTS
TO TIGHTEN UP THE DEFINITION OF
DULY AUTHORIZED ASSEMBLY AT
CLARITY AS- WE ALLOWED- WE
THINK THAT WE NEED. THE WAY
IT'S WRITTEN IT'S FAR TOO BIG
AND WE THAT. WE. LOOK WHERE.
THANK YOU. WELL ONE AGAIN IT'S
ARE NOT THE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. THIS TIME WE HAVE NO
FURTHER IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
OR ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS YES THIS
LACK. LET ME JUST SAY THAT
YOU'RE VERY CLOSE I'M GONNA LAY
OFF TODAY IN HOPES THAT YOU'LL
WORK CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THESE LAW ENFORCEMENT GROUPS.
AND DRIP WE ADDRESS THE- DULY
AUTHORIZED DEFINITION. YOU GOT
TO REMEMBER. IN THESE
CIRCUMSTANCES IT GETS QUITE
CHAOTIC. AND PEOPLE WILL MAKE A
LOT OF CLAIMS AND ESPECIALLY
NOW WITH WHEN EVERYBODY HAS A
CAMERA IT BECOMES VERY
DIFFICULT AND SO. I WOULD JUST
ASK YOU RESPECT. HOW WE'RE JUST
TRYING TO WHAT WHAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAS THAT DUTY THAT
THEY WANT TO BE COMPLIANT THEY
WANT TO BE PROFESSIONAL. BUT
SOMETIMES A DAVID AND-
SOMETIMES IT LOOKS WAY WORSE
THAN IT REALLY IS ANYWAYS.
SECOND PIECE WOULD BE THE
COMMAND POST RESTRICTION THE TO
GIVE THAT STRONG CONSIDERATION
BECAUSE THAT IS. PUBLIC SAFETY
COULD BE COMPROMISED THERE AND
I DON'T THINK THAT YOUR INTENT
SO- I'M GOING LEFT AND IF YOU
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH GROUPS.
YOU'LL YOU'LL GET ME UP FOR.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS. YES ALL WILSON FOR
MOVING THE BILL SAYS A PERSON
FOR PURPOSES OF THIS SECTION.
PRESIDENT OF. POSTED WHO
APPEARS TO BE ENGAGED IN
BATTLING RECEIVING FOR PROCESS
INFORMATION BUT THIS IS A TEST
CARD PRESS INTO WHETHER SIMILAR
POTENTIAL ALWAYS CARING
PROFESSIONAL BROADCASTING
RECORDING. YES DO WE OFFER FOR
OF SAID IF. ONE ONE NEWSPAPER
AND TELEVISION STATE AND LET I
THINK YOU COULD PROBABLY GO.
YES THEY HAVE PROFESSIONAL
EQUIPMENT OKAY OUR OFFICE
REPRESENTATIVE. WHAT'S
PROFESSIONALS. WILL NOT AND
IPHONE AND. AND GET PRETTY GOOD
WELL WE CAN GET IF. SO THINK.
ONE ME TELL YOU ABOUT THE
VOTING TODAY HAS TO BE IN
MOTION. YEAH YES WELL VOTING
FOR BUT I THINK THE TITANS UP
SO AND IT WOULD BE YOU KNOW THE.
OFFICERS SOMEWHERE THIS
NEWSPAPER ON EVERYBODY WILL
FRIENDLY BODIES FOR LIFE THE
THIS IS CARD. IF YOU COULD GET
AT LEAST SATISFIED WITH THE TWO
POINT SEVEN FIVE WILSHIRE. I IT
DOES TO BE TAUGHT FIVE. OKAY
ANYMORE BECAUSE OR QUESTIONS
YES. I DON'T NEED AN ANSWER
RIGHT NOW BUT I JUST WANT TO
ASK THAT YOU CONSIDER YOUR HARD
WORK TOWARDS ENSURING WHEN
THERE IS POTENTIALLY A BONAFIDE
SITUATION WHERE PEOPLE COULD BE
IN DANGER AND THERE IS THAT
NEED- TO REMOVE EVERYONE NOT
FOR THE SAKE OF NOT DISCLOSING
WHAT'S HAPPENING. IS A- B.
BONAFIDE REASONS ONE AP SHOULD
NOT BE OR ANY IN THAT IS NOT A
FIRST RESPONDER FOR THAT
MATTER- WHEN IT. IS WHEN A KID.
BECAUSE MORE TO THE PUBLIC
DANGER THAN SOME SO THAT'S MY
APOLOGY FOR A KNOWLEDGE IN THAT
AND KNOWING THAT. YOU CAN THINK
ROTH ON THAT I'D I'D BE MUCH
APPRECIATED THANK YOU OKAY. ANY
OTHER. YOU MAY CLOSE MISTER
REQUIRE. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
SECURE IF IT'S ALRIGHT MISTER
CHAIR OF THIS ADDRESS VERY
QUICKLY- QUITE BUSY TODAY-
FIRST OF ALL. ON THE FEDERAL.
RIGHT FOR THE QUESTIONS WITH A
VERY FEATURE YES. THE MUCH THE
FIRST OF ALL I THIS IS FINISH.
THAT WE'VE BEEN REALLY WORK ON.
ACCESS TO THE LANGUAGE IN THE
BILL'S IDENTICAL TO EXISTING
AUTHORITY- THAT WE HAVE
PROVIDED PRESS FOR OTHER
INCIDENCES. DURING ACTORS WE
LITERALLY DID THIS FROM A
SECTION. WHILE AREAS THAT ARE
GOING BE CLOSE THE AT THOSE
AFTER DISASTERS MEMBERS OF THE
PRESS ARE AUTHORIZED ENTRANTS.
ON THESE DISASTERS HERE NIGHT
EVEN DURING TIMES OF CURFEW.
STILL ON THE ISSUE OF THE- OF
THE COMMAND POST IN THIS IS
BEEN AN ISSUE THAT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON. FUND IS WELL REALLY
TRYING TO- SEE THERE'S A
ABILITY TO COMPROMISE. FIRST
AND FOREMOST THERE IS NO
EXPECTATION WHEN EITHER OF US
ARE ON TIS DIET FOR MYSELF
WE'RE WALKING FOR EXAMPLE TO A
POLICE DEPARTMENT OR A MEMBER
OF THE PRESS FOR THAT. MATTER
WALKS INTO A LOBBY THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT IN DEMANDS ACCESS TO
THE EVIDENCE ROOM OR TWO
CUBICLES WERE OFFICES OR CITY.
AND BE GRANTED THAT ACCESS. IT
WOULD BE SAID FOR COMMAND CODE
THAT OUR FIRST AMENDMENT- EVENT.
I'M WE WOULDN'T BE GIVEN
UNFETTERED ACCESS WHETHER IT'S
A MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC OR PRESS
AND I THINK THAT THE SAME
ASSUMPTION WILL HAPPEN HERE
WHEN IT COMES ON THE- COMMAND
POST. THE RIVER THE MAX THE
PRESS ALREADY. UNDER NOW.
MISTER REPLY TO THIS BILL ON
THE DOOLEY AUTHORIZED. IN JUST
THIS IS BEEN A BIT OF A STICKY
WICKET IF I COULD BE CANDID-
EXIST. ALREADY STATE JULIA
REYES NUMBERS CAN HAVE ACCESS
TO CLOSE AREAS. BUT HERE'S THE
CHALLENGE REGARDS THE DULY
ACCESS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SO THE BOTTOM LINE
DEFINITION IS BROAD AND HAS
DROPPED. BECAUSE OF THE CAR
ANYTHING. BURKE IN BRAD IS TO
PROTECT OUR THAT FIRST IN FREE
OF THE PRESS YEAH THERE'S BEEN
A TEN THROUGH YEARS AND GOD
BLESS THE CHP BY THE WAY
BECAUSE THEY HAVE TRIED TO.
ZERO THIS ISSUE OF
CREDENTIALING- IN IT EACH
ATTEMPT HAS FAILED NOW THIS
BILL COMES ALONG AND ACTUALLY
TIGHTENS UP THE DEFINITION. OF
ST PRESS MUST HAVE CREDENTIALS
THE FIRST IS WHAT THE STATUTE
IN AND WE DO DEFY PROFESSIONAL
BROADCASTING EQUIPMENT A REPORT
RECORD. DEVICE MICROPHONE CAN
EXCEPT FOR A WITHIN THE BILL
BUT HERE'S THE BOTTOM LINE AND
ALL IN IT RIGHT HERE IN
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I THE
CHALLENGES WE NOW A FEW OF
THOSE FEET. YAHOO NEWS BOX ALL
ON. IS IN THE COUNTRY IS
INTENTIONALLY BROAD RIGHTFULLY
SO TO ENSURE THAT THOSE MEMBERS
OF THE PRESS- HAVE ACCESS THAT
TOO WHETHER IT'S AN APP IS
ASTRID THIS BILL FIRST AND IN
THE EVENT. SO YOU HAVE MY CAN-
WE WORK CLOSELY WITH SAYS FROM
STATE SHERIFFS. I THIS. GONNA
THEIR EGGS
THE WEEKS TO COME THINKING
STRUCTURE THINKING YOUR STAFF
THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIRMAN RISK
FASTER AND VOTE IN AN ONLINE TO
THANK. CENTER REQUIRED FOR. AND
A MAN STATE GET US TO THAN. I
LIKE MY BY CHAIR SAID I THINK
CLOSE GET THE THING WE'LL SEE
YES IS TO. FUNNY AND BETTER
ACTS THIRD WHETHER NOW
INDIVIDUALS KNOW WHAT THE ARE
READY OF WHAT YOU NEED TO DO WE
YOU GET TO A CRIME WHEN YOU TO
HAVE A SITUATION THAT EVERY IS
LAW ON. THAT DATE EVERY EVEN IF.
HOW YOU. BEING DECIMATED
DECADES WITH OF ALL THE TIME SO
WHEN THEY SHOWED UP ON THE
SCENE. YOU KNEW WHO THE WHO HE
OR SHE WAS A GOOD TEAM.
TOGETHER MAYBE FOR SEVERAL
DECADES IT'S SO YOU COULD TALK
TO ALL THE RULES AND
REGULATIONS. IS IT NOW TALK TO
A YOUNGEROFFICER WERE IT HAS
EXPLODED AS FAR AS THE NUMBER
OF MEDIA OUTLETS. THAT ARE OUT
THERE AND SO I WHILE THE
CONSTITUTION MAY SAYS SOMETHING
IN A CERTAIN DEDICATED TIME. IT
MAY NOT BE. APROPOS AS MUCH AS
NOW AND- OBVIOUSLY WE CAN'T
CHANGE THE CONSTITUTION BUT WE
SHOULD. JUST SOME OF OUR
THINKING TO THE EXPLOSION OF
CHANNEL SO IT TOO IS BUT YOU
GET FIVE THOUSAND CHANNELS
RIGHT NOW TO. HOW I'M GOING TO
HAVE ANY MEDIA OUT. THERE ARE
JUST PEOPLE ABOUT- WON'T EVEN
GET. HOW MANY. PARQUET OTHERS
THAT ARE CONSIDERED MEDIA BASED
NEED TO BE TRAINED ON HOW TO DO
THIS AND SO MAYBE THERE'S
SPARKASSE LUCIEN MIGHT BE
TRAINING IN AWARENESS TO HELP
SO THAT WE DON'T IMPAIR. YOUR
WHAT ARE FORTUNATE AS WE TRY
TO. DEAL WITH ANY OF THESE
EMERGENCIES AND I THINK THAT
FROM FROM WHAT I'M HEARING FROM
BOTH SIDES. THAT SEEMS TO BE-
MAYBE MAYBE JUST MAYBE THIS IS
ABOUT HOW DO YOU UPDATE. WHAT
THE PRICE IS RIGHT NOW SO. WE
WERE WITH BOTH SIDES YOU CAN
COME UP WITH SOME BETTER
DEFINITIONS. SO THANK I THANK
YOU FOR EVERYTHING YOU DO INTO
TO GET THIS DONE I THINK YOU
SUCH AS YOUR VERY GRATEFUL SIR
AND CHAIR RECOMMEND. MAY CALL
THE ROLL. SB SIX TWENTY CHOIR
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER HI JOHN SIR HI LACKEY
LACKEY NOT VOTING FOR OUR CAMP
OKAY HAVE YOU DEEP. KAMLAGER HI
KAMLAGER I WORK WORK AT A SAN
DIEGO SAN DIEGO I STONE STONE I.
THE MEASURE PASSES THANK YOU SO
MUCH THINKING AND NOW WITH THE
PORTANTINO US TO COME UP NEXT.
AND THEN AFTER THAT WE'LL HAVE
PRODUCED SEVEN ITEM SEVEN EIGHT
A RISE OF. US SB ONE ONE ONE
ONE AND THEN GARAGE OR SB
TWELVE NINETY ARM SO RIGHT NOW
WILL DO PORTANTINO S. B. ONE
FOUR. THANK THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS APPRECIATE THE
QUICK MOTION- SB NINE FOURTEEN
REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO VERIFY THE VALIDITY
OF A HUNTING LICENSE SAYS HE
SAW WITH THE TRAGEDY IN THE
PENTAGON THE SHOULD ABLE TO GET
A LICENSE THAT WAS NOT A VALID.
LICENSE I'M SIXTY CLOSE THAT
LOOP. AND PROTECT AGES
INDEFINITE AND WITH THAT I
RESPECT ASKS FOR AN AYE VOTE.
YOU KNOW. CAN YOU HAVE A
WITNESS AT ASHLEY THERE'S
DEPARTED JUSTICE. YOU MAY
MISTER MODERATE YOU MAY LOOK
ALLOW HER TO COME IN AND
TESTIFY. THANK YOU MEDICARE
BACK THERE THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE ON BEHALF
OF THE TOURNEY GENERAL HOW THE
ADDRESS. I WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
EIGHT HUNDRED AND ELEVEN WITH
THE FOR CENTER PORTANTINO FOR
INCLUDING EVEN IF NINE ONE. AT
THE HEROES AND EIGHT TO YOU
KNOW. EIGHT TWO THREE THERE ARE
ISSUES THAT WERE RAISED TO ADD
REPUBLICAN. I THE NATIONALRIFLE ASSOCIATION LAST YEAR AND
WE'RE TO QUICKLY UP THE
INTERACTION WILL HANDLE OKAY
PENAL CODE ZERO THREE ZERO. OUR
ISSUE IN END IT THANK YOU AB
BACKGROUND BANNING ANY HUSING
TECHNOLOGICAL CODE THREE ZERO
FOUR SEVEN ZERO ISSUES ARISING
FROM THE EIGHT SEVEN NINE
FRAZIER PARK UP HERE BYE AS A
MEMBER GET. MINOR IMAGINE
TRANSACTION ELEVEN TEN AND
ELEVEN O'CLOCK OPEN CRACK BUT
THEY THE KING OF THE CARE ACT
CHANGES MADE LAST YEAR THE IN
AB ONE SIX SIX NINE WEEKS ARE
IN SUPPORT OF THE VISION THAT.
REFLECT BACK WHEN I BOUGHT.
THANK YOU. I THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESS THEN THE ROOM IN SUPER
I SEE A HAND IN A ROW. YES I'M
HERE IN IN THE COULD BECAUSE
THIS IS A THE LOW ISSUE BECAUSE
AND THE TRAIN ISSUE OF THE MY
IS WE THAT AS UP TO RID SB SIX
EIGHTY THREE WHICH ASSEMBLY MEN
STONE CHIP IN ON THE BOOKS FOR
MARTY BLOCK IN TWENTY THIRTEEN.
AND THE FIGHT ON THAT ISSUE WAS
WHETHER OR NOT THIS BILL IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE NEWS CLEAN
UP. AND THE VIEW OF THE HUNTING
GROUPS AS WELL AS THE- LET'S
COUNSEL BEFORE THIS EVEN WENT
INTO THE BILL BECAUSE WE DON'T
WANT ANYTHING SUBSTANTIVE IN MY
THE WHOLE. CODE THING THAT THIS
IS MERELY BEING UP. DOES THE
VIEW OF EVERYONE WHO'S LOOKED
AT THIS OUTSIDE OF THE NRA AND
AS A RESULT OF THAT IT'S NOT
YOU THIS SUBSTANTIVE IT'S
SIMPLY CLARIFYING LANGUAGE.
WITH THAT ALL DEFERRED TO MR.
SKEWS ME SIR COULD YOU GIVE US
YOUR NAME YOU KNOW WHO I AM NOT
WITH NO WORK- AND I WANT TO
MAKE A QUICK I'M HERE IN MY
TRIP. OFFICE YES IT. DOES NOT
TURN THE- JEFF. I ALSO SAY IT'S
WITH IT. GOOD TO BE BACK IN THE
BILL EIGHT MONTHS IT UNDER
WESTERN IDEALS. THANK YOU I
KNEW THE COMMITTEE WHERE IRWIN
I WANT MAKE SURE. WE BROUGHT
HIM BACK WELL THIS WAS
SOMETHING WILL WORK ON SOME
TWENTY SEVEN TO WHEN THE ARRAY
ASK ELEVEN HOW CAME UP IN THE
WAY THESE COM. AND THAT THAT WE
WERE URGED TO FIX THEM BUT
WITHIN WE WANT TO DO MORE
RESEARCH SO WE WOULDN'T. PUT
ANY ONE POSITION WHERE IT WAS A
SUBSTANTIVE THING. THEN WHY WE
WAITED NOW BANK YOUR- YES SIR.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS- MARC
SMITH ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA WATERFOWL
ASSOCIATION WE DON'T HAVE AN
OFFICIAL POSITION ON THE BILL
THERE'S A LOT OF PIECES AS
IRWIN ALLUDED TO WHAT WE WOULD
LIKE TO SAY TO THE OKAY POINT
THE TRYING TO GET EVERYONE.
WHAT WHAT WE WOULD LIKE TO SAY
TO THE AUTHOR WE HAVEN'T A
CHANCE TO SOME PRETTY COMMITTEE
AS WE HAVE IS RECOGNITION OF
THE SPORTSMAN'S WOMEN'S
COMMUNITY THE ADDITIONAL
TRAINING THOSE FOLKS TAKE IN
ORDER TO GET A HOLDING LICENSE.
AT THAT THIS IS A GUY OF. TO
GET PEOPLE HUNTING AND FISHING.
AND THAT THESE EXEMPTIONS ARE
VERY HELPFUL AND RECOGNIZING
THAT- WE WANT TO THANK HIM FOR
HIS PATIENTS ARE WORKING
THROUGH THESE EFFORTS WHAT
THESE EXEMPTIONS TO BE
MEANINGFUL AS WELL AN
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE DOING
HERE TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
OTHER ANY OTHER. WHICH ISN'T
SUPPORT FOR. I GUESS ENTER TWO
WINNERS OR- ON THE VIDEO
CONFERENCE OR ANY. ON THE
ISLAND MISTER MODERATOR ERNIE
DIALING IN SUPPORT. OF SB NINE
ONE THREE. WILLIAM ON THE PHONE
LINES IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. OUR
FIRST RODEO NUMBER TWO TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. REBECCA
MARKETS ON BEHALF OF BRADY
UNITED AGAINST GUN VIOLENCE AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ONE CENTER IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AT THIS TIME OF
NO FURTHER IN SUPPORT PLEASE
CONTINUE MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
ARE ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
I HAVE DAN READ AN ARRAY AND
RIGHT DIRECTION SHE R. PA. YOUR
MEDIAN READER YOU READY FOR ME
YES YOU MAY PERCY. OKAY YOUR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE RECORD THE
AND READ THE NATIONAL RIFLE
IT'S- I'M ALSO YOU'RE- GONNA
CALIFORNIA NATIONAL PARK
FOUNDATION TODAY- ALL IN
OPPOSITION- CAL THE LAW WHICH
CHANGED A FEW YEARS BACK
REGARDING PURCHASE OF LAW AND
BY INDIVIDUALS UNDER THE ONE.
WE OPPOSED THAT ON BILL. ADDED
LIMITED ABILITY FOR LAW ADULTS
GOT PURCHASED ONE GONE FROM THE
STATE WITHOUT LIGHT. THIS BILL
COMPOUND THE PROBLEM BY-
REDEFINING WHAT IT CONSIDERED A
VALID HUNTING LICENSE HUNTING
LICENCES IN THE STATE OR FROM.
FOR THROUGH THE THIRD. AND THIS
BILL FIRST. YOUNG OLD WHO IS
GOING OUT PREPARING FOR SEASON
THEY THEY PURCHASED ON LIGHT IN
MAY. THEY'RE NOT GONNA BY A
HUNTING LIKE FOR BACKSEAT AND
THEIR GONNA BUY ONE UP SEASON
AND SO. UNDER THIS ALLY AND
THAT IS NOT X. HE'S NOT GOING
TO FIGHT. YOU LOOK AT THE UNDER.
REASON THAT. TRANSACTION WE
HEARD THEY ABOUT TRAINING AND
HERITAGE AND WHAT THE LAW. IS
CURRENT GOOD FOR CURRENT THAT
THEY ARE AND ONE MONTH HAS TO
DO UNDER TRY THE THAT'S
REQUIRED FOR THE HUNTERS
CERTIFICATE IS A ONE PORTS AND
WE FEEL THAT THIS IS JUST.
RIGHT THEN ADDITIONAL TAP. I
DON'T MY- BYLINE. ONLY BE GOOD
FOR YOU. IN ORDER TO THAT. TO
PREPARE FOR THAT I'M COMING HE
DIDN'T MAKE SURE THE THEY'RE
FAMILIAR WITH THE GOING TO THE
FIELD. BUT I'M ALSO WE'RE NOT.
TO THE SECTOR. REYES IS. THAT
BEAT ON ELIGIBLE CHECK THOSE
WITH A. TO BUT IT TEARS FROM
DEPARTMENT OF IN AB PICKING
PICKING THERE WERE. SOME ISSUE
THAT CHANGE OUR WAY THE DRAW
THESE ARE. IN THE CHANGING.
STATEN COUNTY PROPERTY WOLD BE
DOWN TO ONE DOLLAR PER THE
NORMAL TO COUNTY CREATING A
PUBLIC. IN. AT PART OF THE JOB
IS BEEN A CHARGING BE THE DOUBT
HELLO OF THE L. CHECK ON.
PROBATE THE ELIGIBLE CHECK WE
DID A LETTER THE AG MAKING THEM
A OF THE- AND WE FEEL THAT.
THIS IS WOULD BE ON THOSE THE
PROVIDED A SEPARATE BY THAT
GREAT BECAUSE CONTROLS ALL THE
WAY UP TO THIRTY ONE A NIGHT
CENTS. AND THIS IS TO THE USING
BY LAW BACK AT THAT LANGUAGE
FROM TWENTY NINETEEN. AND WERE
WERE OPPOSE TO THAT I WERE THE
ON CHOI SYSTEM THERE. AND
WITHOUT I WE ARE NOT
PROVISIONAL TURNOVER MR.
REMEMBER THE TIME SPEAKING ON
HAPPY CARE RIGHT PISTOL
SOLUTION ARE. OF MEMBERS FROM
CAL. IT IS A REALLY SUBJECT
MATTER SPENT THREE TWO YEARS IN
LOT FOR WHILE TWENTY WITH
CALIBER DEPARTMENT. FISH AND
WHILE A LOT FOURTEEN WHICH WAS
OVER THE STATE'S HUNDRED FOR
THOSE MYERS. MY STAFF RSPONSE.
TO REINTERPRET FARM LAWS OF
NATURE UP AND KEEP THEM SAFE TO
COME WITH THE- I'M BY NO OF
EXPERT. BUT I GOT MY WHERE FAR
ROAD YOU. CAL SB NINE FOURTEEN
I'M NOT TWISTED ALLEGE LOOKING
FOR COST JUST UP THIS IT MIGHT.
WHEN I LOOKED AT ALL THE ARE
NOT. SURE YOU A LEGISLATION
TELL ME WHETHER I ANY LICENSE
VALOR NA I ALSO WORKED WITH
pACROSS WITH THESE I THE ISSUE
TO ON THE X. DATE ALIVE CLEAR
AND THE MEETING IN A NEW A
MANNER SB FOUR LEMONADE ALONE
ALONG TO MINE LETTER PARENT IS
STANDING RIGHT. THIS ALONE WILL
DEVASTATE THE STUDENTS YOU
SHOOTING SPORTS ALREADY CATION
OTHER YOUTH OPPORTUNITIES.
CALIFORNIA WE SOUGHT HELP FROM
THE ALTAR UNDERSTAND THE GOALS
THIS BILL REFERRED TO THIRD
GOES. WHO ALSO COULD NOT.
REDUCE OUR TO. THE NATIONAL.
POP EXISTING LAWS FURTHER. TO
RECRUIT OF THE NEXT GENERATION
CALIFORNIANS ARE
CONSERVATIONISTS FOR ALL THE
REASONS WE STAND STRONG
OPPOSITION AS BEING ON
FOURTEEN. THANK YOU SIR FOR
YOUR TIME. I THANK IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE CHAMBERS WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. OF THIS BILL. RIGHT
SIGNAL IS ANY ONE IN THE VIDEO
CONFERENCE ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION THIS
BILL. RESEARCHER AND MR
MODERATOR IS THERE ANYONE ON
THE PHONE WHO LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. MAYES GERMAN ON THE
PHONE IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN ONE ZERO IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION. THE FIRST
ORDER NUMBER TWO TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MEMBERS WHICH READY
MY NAME'S MICHAEL AND THE
REPRESENTING THE NATIONAL
SHOOTING SPORTS FOUNDATION WE
ARE OPPOSITION THE BILL THANK.
THANK YOU. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU'RE
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. WE DO HAVE ONE MORE IN
OUR QUEUE- NEXT WE WILL BE
GOING TO NUMBER SIXTY SEVEN.
SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER OR MISTER
MCMAHON I'M THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
JOBS SOUTH SACRAMENTO- CHAPTER
OF THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND
PISTOL ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
NUMBER AND STRONG OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. THANK YOU. AT THIS
TIME THERE ARE NO FURTHER IN
THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE MR
WILL BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OR ANY QUESTIONS MR
SANTIAGO. I DO THINK THIS IS A
MUCH NECESSARY ABILITY GOOD
BILL IT'S A LONG OVERDUE NO
ABSOLUTELY CLEAR UP PREVENT
PEOPLE HAVING GUNS IT SHOULD
HAVE IT AND THERE'S NO REASON.
WHY NOT THE CASTING AS LONG.
THANK YOU. MISS I WANT TO
REFLECT ONE COMMENT THE%
OPPOSITION MADE WHICH IS THAT
YOUR THEY CLAIM ADDRESSING A
PROBLEM THAT DOESN'T EXIST AND
I WANT TO SPEAK FOR THE VICTIMS
AND HOW IT WOULD VERY MUCH
DISAGREE WITH THAT STATEMENT
THAT THERE WAS A BOMB WE SAW
OUR CONSTANT AND I THINK
CORRECTING IT AND I RESPECT TO
BE A CO AUTHOR. THANK YOU. I'M
SORRY ONE MAKE YOU MAY CALL.
I'M NO I THINK THEY ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS COMMENTS ARE VERY
APPROPRIATE TO HAD THIS BEEN IN
PLACE THAT SHOOTER WOULD NOT OF
HAD A GUN AND PEOPLE WOULD NOT
HAVE BEEN SHOT. IT'S THAT
SIMPLE ANDSO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR. ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENTED AND- THE COMMITTEE
FOR SUPPORTING AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
WON'T THANK YOU COMMITTEE. WE
HAVE A- CHECK IT. IS
RECOMMENDED I I'M SECTOR CALLED
THE WORLD SB NINE FOURTEEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER JONES I LACKEY NOTE
FLAGGING NO BARRA CAN ACTUALLY
HANNAH I DEEP. KAMLAGER
KAMLAGER HI CORK CORK I
SANTIAGO. SAN DIEGO I STONE
STONE I. THE MEASURE PASSES
GRADUALLY CHAIRMAN IF I MAY
FIRST SECOND TO EVEN THOUGH IT
INVOKE FOR THE BILL IT IS GOOD
TO SEE MR LACKEY- JUST DOING SO
WELL IF SHE GOT LAST YEAR.
THANK YOU. AND SO NOW WE GO
BACK TO ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AND%
EIGHT. DOURADO S. B. ONE ONE
ONE ONE. I BELIEVE YOU'RE-
KEVIN SURE. ALL YEAH. WE DO A
TWELVE NINETY. I THINK. SEVEN
ELEVEN. SO REDUCED TO ELEVEN
FIRST. THE MONITORING PERCENT
YOU CAN PREVENT FOR THERE ARE
ONE ROOM YOU THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION I HAVE RIGHT NOW ON
RECORD. BREVITY THANK YOU COULD
ALWAYS GET IT WILL HI ON BEHALF
OF SENATOR DORADO I AM PRESENT
AS ELEVEN ELEVEN WHICH WILL THE
COW LAW TO PREVENT TO PRESENT
PERMIT YOUTH TO STAY IN
JUVENILE FACILITIES. PENDING
THE OUTCOME OF THEIR JUVENILE
COURT CASE UNTIL AGE TWENTY ONE
SPECIFICALLY IT CREATES A
PRESUMPTION FOR KEEPING YOU IN
JUVENILE FACILITIES AND
REQUIRES THAT A JUDGE DECIDE
WHETHER IT'S JUST OUR YOUTH
MAYBE AND PROVIDES GUIDANCE FOR
A JUDGE'S DECISION. LOSS
DOESN'T REALLY OFFER THOSE
KINDS OF STANDARD. I HAVE.
THANK SAY IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME I WILL NOT WITH ME I HAVE
SIMILAR EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT. AS WELL
AS ELIZABETH CALVIN FROM HUMAN
RIGHTS WATCH AND SUE BURRELL
FROM THE PACIFIC JUVENILE
DEFENDER CENTER ON THE LINE TO
HELP ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS IF
THERE ARE ANY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. OUR ANY IN THE
AUDIENCE IN SUPPORT. ANY
WITNESSES BOB I WENT TOO FAST
SO I LIKE TO HEAR FROM ST LOUIS
ELIZABETH CALVIN SUPERMALL
AGAIN I WANNA RIDE EACH OF YOU-
THERE IS SO FAR HAVE NO
OPPOSITION SO. YOU MAY BEGIN
MISTER LEWIS AND THEN WE'LL GO
MISS CALVIN AND EMUS BRO WELL
MISS BROWSE HERE FOR TECHNICAL.
THANK YOU MATURE GREATLY
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME- MISTER
CHAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS I DON'T
KNOW MY NAME IS SAM LEWIS NON
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION ARISTEIA
AN ORGANIZATION COMPRISED OF
ABOUT A HUNDRED MEMBERS WILL
FORMING PARTS READY YOU. FOR
THE LAST FIVE YEARS I'VE SPENT
ALMOST EVERY SATURDAY MORNING
WITH YOU YOU WILL ALL. WANT TO
TURN EIGHTEEN EVEN IF THE CASE
STARTED USING ALL MANY OF THESE
YOU GET REMOVED AND TRANSFERRED
TO THE TO THE MEN'S CENTRAL
COUNTY JAIL. FOR LITTLE OR NO
REASONS WHAT HAPPENED HAPPENED
TO THE JEWS LEADS ME TO BE A
STRONG SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL
ELEVEN ELEVEN. IF PASSING A
BILL ELEVEN ELEVEN WOULD ENSURE
THE YOUNG PEOPLE CONTINUE TO
GET EDUCATION TREATMENT IN
JUVENILE HALL WHETHER CASES OF.
WHAT THEIR CASES ARE PENDING.
ISN'T IT A DAHLE. HAD EIGHT
ONLINE EDUC. COUNTY AND OTHER
HELP STOP. YEP BIG FOCUS ON
ALSO. THE VERY HARD TO. IN THE
MEN'S CENTRAL KERR JAIL. I
HEARD MANY STORIES BY THE
HEARTBREAKING A. R. C. MEMBERS.
OTHERS ACROSS THE STATE. I'D
LIKE TO SHARE A WOULD YOU THAT
I PERSON SHOULD. CONTINUE TO
THAT ARE NOT ON THE J. AGAIN
MET TWENTY. JORDAN JUVENILE
WHEN HE WAS SIX AND I WALKED IN
THE- OF. YOU'RE GOING TO TAKE.
PLACE CHOICES ON. REALLY A PLAN
EDUCATION. HE TURNED EIGHTEEN
AND FOR DAYS LATER JORDAN CLASH
WITH THE DOG. A .COM JAIL.
ALMOST IMMEDIATELY WATCHING
EIGHT YEAR OLD SEVERELY THIS.
WE LIVED VERY WHAT IT HAPPEN TO
HIM THANK YOU MIGHT HAPPEN TO
HIM ALSO. IT IS. YOU BLOCK
RESOLVED HE WAS TO DO OF. JUDGE
BUT- YET THEY HAD TO HEAR FROM
ALL THE DRAMA EXPERIENCE RIGHT
NOW THE- IS A VERY MEANING. BUT
DISCIPLINE FREE AND ALSO UP
HERE MENTOR AND THE JUDGE OUR
ARGUMENT TO KEVIN WHEN HE WAS.
INITIALLY W. WOULDN'T PERTAIN.
HE REFUSE TO READ OR WRTE OR
EVEN SPEAK. AFTER MAY TWENTY
FOUR WHILE THE CAC AND CURSING.
HE TRIED ANY BEGIN TO REALLY
APPLY HIMSELF SCHOOL CLASSES.
KEVIN EVEN BEGIN ASK IS
TEACHERS TO GIVE EXTRA WORK TO
DO IN THE STUDIO. SOON AFTER
THE EIGHTEEN THEY GIVEN THAT
EXTRA. TEACHER TOLD HIM. YOU
CAN RETURN TO A JUNIOR. AFTER A
LOT OF CRAZY CAMPUS MEMBERS
DOOR. ONE ACTUAL. WOULD GIVE US
DON'T. BASED ON CAN WAS
TRANSFERRED TO THE GEO KEVIN
TOLD ME TO. FOR DAY TO HE
ENTERED THE COUNTY JAIL SOME
PUT IN PLACE TO IN THE FACE NO
READ. YOU DESCRIBE AT THIS TIME
THE COUNTY. AS THE WORST AND
SCARE TIME IN HIS LIFE. HE
STILL DOES UNDERSTAND WHY WAS
TOO JONES REALLY. OUR SCHOOLS
ARE WORKING HARD TO GET BETTER.
SOON THESE KIDS TO ADULTS.
TURNS AROUND HIS THE
INTERRUPTER TO HEAR GROW AND
EXPECT WE- URGE YOU TO VOTE.
HOW YOU TO VOTE YES ON THIS
BILL KEVIN ALSO A MENTOR AND-
YOU JUST. AND WE COMMUNICATE
WITH THEM ON A- BASIS VIA ZOOM
WE PUT PROVIDE MENTAL TO AND
GUIDANCE FOR THOSE YOU THANK
YOU FOR TIME. THANK YOU. NEXT
JUST. KAREN JOHNSON THIS SUPER
RALPH THE FIFTH YOU LOCKED UP
CENTER OBVIOUS CAL NINE WE'RE
NOT PLANNING PRESENT AND WE ARE
HERE I HERE TO ANY QUESTIONS
THE COMMITTEE MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU MUCH NOW. ARE THERE THE
ANYONE IN THE OF LIKE TO. DOES
SEEN NONE ANYONE A VIDEO. WORKS
SEEING NONE AND NOW MISTER
MODERATE- ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. ALIEN JUMP ON THE
PHONE LINE IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME AGAIN ONE ZERO IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT. AND WILL
FIRST START WITH NUMBER ONE
THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
PROTECTED GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NEXT TO A NUMBER
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME THEIR HARDWOOD SILICON
VALLEY DEPAKOTE COSPONSORED THE
BILL- WEREN'T STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT TO BE NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON YES
WITH CUT FIFTY- IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR.
NEXTRA NUMBER TWO THIRTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SURE MEN GOING
TO UPON THE ARE YOU BACK WORK
CLICK ONTO THE BILL AND WE'RE
TRYING TO PUT. NEXT TO BE
NUMBER TWO THIRTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT
THE GYM WHEN BURKE ON BEHALF OF
THE FRENCH COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION TO CALIFORNIA AND
DEPORT THANK YOU. THE NEXT WILL
BE NUMBER SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. DEMOCRATS ROMERO WITH
ACLU OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
NEXT WE NUMBER TWO THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI CAROLYN
DEAN OF THE ALLIANCE FOR BOYS
OF COLOR AT POLICY HEARING IN
STRONG SUPPORT. NEXT TO THE
NUMBER. EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN YOUR
LINES OPEN. KIRCH I JUST RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT TO BE NUMBER TWO TO
THIRTEEN PLEASED AT. DAVID
HAVEN'T WITH INITIATE DEFINITE
IN STRONG SUPPORT. RIGHT NOW.
GOOD NUMBER TWO THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIRTY THIRTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THIS IS GOING TO TREAT. BECOME
COALITION PROUD COSPONSORED.
BUT THE NEXT TO GO TO NUMBER
SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TELL YOUR TRAVIS CO SPONSOR-
WITH THE COMPETITIVE A CO
SPONSOR OF THE BILL AND STRONG
SUPPORT. NEXT TO A NUMBER TWO
THIRTY SIX WE'VE GOT A LITTLE
WITH CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY
AND JUSTICE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
NOW THE NUMBER ONE EIGHTY FOUR
IS GOOD. DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
IN SUPPORT. NEXT WE KNOW WHAT
THE TEAM YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON DOMINIQUE NELSON
THE CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
NO GOOD NUMBER EIGHTY FIVE
EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AND IS THERE THE CATHOLIC BUT
THAT SOMEBODY DID BACK IN THE
COURT OF THE. NEXT TO A NUMBER
TWO THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS AMANDA LEVEL WITH HUMAN
RIGHTS WATCH CO SPONSORING THIS
BILL IN STRONG SUPPORT AND I'LL
BE SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
PACIFIC JUVENILE DEFENDER
CENTER WHICH IS SPONSORING AN
INCONSEQUENTIAL. THE NEXT WILL
BE NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YOUR HONOR DEFINITELY
WOULD STILL COME BALLY DEEPER
COOK BONTA MATTEL AND ITS
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT
TO A NUMBER ONE SIXTY PLEASE AT.
BUT ONE SIXTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THAT THE WORLD WILL DO JUST
BECAUSE YOU DON'T SUPPORT.
UNEXPLODED NUMBER TWO FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M AND YOU
GET BACK HERE WITH THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT YEAR
THE NUMBER TWELVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MARCO GEORGIA MY HALF OF
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. NEXT
WILL BE NUMBER FIFTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AT EIGHT FORTY FIVE
FORTY THE CORPORATE. MANAGER
PARTICIPATORY DEFENSE AND
OCTOBER A COMBINED DEEPER CLOUT
TO CO SPONSOR. BE FOUND. UP
NEXT TO BE NUMBER. PLEASE GO
AHEAD YEAH. CAN I GET YOUR
PROGRESS IN SUPPORT. NEXT WILL
BE NUMBER TWO FORTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. DANIEL MULLAH SILICON
VALLEY GIVE US CONSTRUCTION
FIELD STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NEXT TO BE NUMBER TWO SIXTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. EARLY WITH
THESE DATA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THE NEXT ORDER THE NUMBER TO
FORTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
YOUR THAN EVER READY WITH
INITIATE TRAFICANT SUPPORT
THANK YOU. AN EXCELLENT NUMBER
TWO FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FIFTY YES FOR EUROPE IN YEAH IT
YEAH THIS IS DOUG JEFF UP HERE
ON BEHALF OF A. R. C. I'M ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION I SUPPORT
SB ONE ELEVEN OR ELEVEN ELEVEN.
BUT ONCE AGAIN IF YOU'RE IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
YEAH WE'LL GO TO NUMBER TWO
FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS RIGHTS DIED OF SILICON
VALLEY DE BUG CROWD
COSPONSORING TRANSPORT. AND
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. WE DO
HAVE ONE MORE IN THE QUEUE TO
BE JUST A MOMENT.
AND NEXT WILL
BE GOING TO NUMBER TWO FORTY
SEVEN TO FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THIRTY FORTY SEVEN.
LOOKS LIKE THEY HAVE DROPPED AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NO FURTHER IN
THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE MR
THANK YOU ORDER ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. ANY WITNESSES ON
THE TELE CONFERENCE. ANY
WITNESSES IN THE AUDIENCE IN
THE HEARING ROOM. NOW WILL GO
TO MISTER MODERATOR TO ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. THEY
ARE DIALING IN. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. I GOT A ONE ZERO IF YOU
WERE IN OPPOSITION. ONCE AGAIN
IT'S ONE ZERO IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION. AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE KNOWN IN Q. PLEASE
CONTINUE MR THANK YOU. STILL
DON'T KNOW WHY THIS WAS NOT PUT
ON CONSENT BUT ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. WE HAVE A MOTION. THE
COME RECOMMENDED I WE CALL THE
ROLL. ON SB ELEVEN ELEVEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER HI JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY. LACKEY AND LYFT BARRY
KEOGHAN BACKING HANNAH DEEP.
KAMLAGER KAMLAGER I. CORK I SAN
DIEGO SAN DIEGO I STONE STONE
AYE THAT MEASURE PASSES THAT
MEASURE PASSES UP MR SANTIAGO
WE'RE GONNA LET MR NUMBER COME
IN CASES WE- SO COULD HAVE A
SEAT. WHICH ONE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO DO FIRST- TO BILLS SB ELEVEN
NINETY SIX AND SB TWELVE TWENTY
ONE WE START WITH SB TWELVE
TWENTY OKAY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY WITH FS
THAT'S GOOD BUT THIS ONE. YOUR
HEAD I DON'T WANT TO SCREW IT
UP. BUT LET ME LET ME JUST
BRIEFLY EXPLAIN THE PURPOSE OF
THE BILL SB TWELVE TWENTY DEALS
WITH AN ISSUE CALLED THE BRADY
LIST I THINK MOST IF NOT ALL OF
YOU ARE FAMILIAR WITH. THE
OBLIGATION IMPOSED BY BRADY
VERSUS MARYLAND THAT A
PROSECUTOR MUST DISCLOSE THE
DEFENSE ANY EXCULPATORY
INFORMATION THAT WOULD INCLUDE-
INFORMATION THAT MAY BE IN THE
TESTIFYING OFFICERS FILE
CONSERVE MISCONDUCT THERE ARE A
VARIETY OF OTHER ISSUES. SADLY
SOME LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
ARE NOT COMPLETELY COMPLYING
WITH IN THE STATE THIS REQUIRES
THEM TO DO SO TO PROVIDE THAT
LIST UPON REQUEST OR ANNUALLY
TO THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY THE
PROSECUTING AGENCY- THE FAIR TO
DO SO MEANS THAT. IF YOU DON'T
HAVE THAT INFORMATION DEFENSE
COUNSEL DOES HAVE INFORMATION
TO EXAMINE THE OFFICER AND CAN
ULTIMATELY RESULT IN A REVERSAL
OF A CONVICTION OR EVEN AND
SOMEONE GOING TO PRISON WHO
SHOULDN'T GO TO PRISON. THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL TRIES TO ADDRESS
THE SECOND PART OF THE BILL. IS
IT PROVIDES A MINIMAL AMOUNT OF
DUE PROCESS TO AN OFFICER WHO
IS GOING TO BE ON THE BRADY
LIST. THAT DUE PROCESS MEANS
THAT THEY'RE NOTIFIED THEY'RE
GOING TO BE ON THE BRADY LIST
OR THAT THEY'RE ON THE BRADY
LIST. AND AN OPPORTUNITY TO
TALK TO THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY
ABOUT BEING REMOVED HOWEVER IT
DOES NOT REMOVE THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OBLIGATION TO.
NOTIFY THE DEFENSE COUNSEL THAT
SOMEONE IS ON THE BRADY LIST IT
DOES NOT DELAY TRIAL. IN IN
FACT IN ALAMEDA. SAN FRANCISCO
COUNTY THIS IS THE PROCESS THE
RATHER COUNT AS WELL GOOD IN
VENTURA COUNTY. OF AYE URGENT
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU AND YOU
HAVE TO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
LESLIE YOUR- DON'T SPECTRUM.
ONE WOULD. JUST BROKE JEFF YEAH
HE HAS GOOD TURN TO SANFORD. I
BELIEVE THE PHONE. WITH ON THE
PHONE. WITH STE MODERATE CHECKS
THAT WITNESS SINCE. YOUNG CARE
AND SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME THIS. THIS IS
FOR THE- THE WITNESS JUST A
BOAT. DAY TO SPEAK ON A ON THE.
I THINK HE'S ON THE PHONE. HE'S
ON THE PHONE OKAY AND I'M
INFORMED AS SUCH. I THINK HE'S
TIRED. WELCOME TO BLUE. RIGHT.
WELL IF YOU CAN'T BE FOUND HERE.
SOON MISTER CHAIR I COULD GO TO
MY SECOND BILL IF YOU LIKE FIVE
BECAUSE THAT'S THE GREW UP YOUR
PROCESS YET YOU YOU MASON
APPLES AND ORANGES. THIS THIS
SYSTEM IS NEW AS IT IS. SO WHAT
WE CAN DO. OKAY WHAT WE CAN DO
IS GO AHEAD AND LISTEN TO
ANYONE IN THE AUDIENCE IN
SUPPORT. ANYONE IN THE VIDEO
CONFERENCING IN SUPPORT. AREA
AND THEN. MISTER MODERATOR YOU
CAN OPEN UP THE LINES FOR ANY
SUPPORTERS THAT HAVE DIALED IN.
ALL RIGHT- LEAD GERMAN CARE AND
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
AGAIN ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT. AND THEN I WILL START
WITH NUMBER FORTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ANNA KELLY ON BEHALF
OF THE ALAMEDA COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE THE PART OF
THE BILL. NEXT WE GO TO NUMBER
TWO FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE COLD WARMAN ON BEHALF OF
THE ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT. NEXT TO
A NUMBER EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS WITH THE
SKILLS TO WORK ON BEHALF OF
SUMMER STEPHAN DANTE A GO
DISTRICT ATTORNEY WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF F. B. TWELVE TWENTY
THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE NO FURTHER IN
SUPPORT. OKAY PLEASE CONTINUE
TO CHECK THANK YOU WE WILL GO
TO ANY WITNESSES. TO WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION MARGO GEORGE FOR
CPD EIGHT AND PROCESS PROFESSOR
ACT ABLE UC HASTINGS LAW SCHOOL.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS MARCO GEORGE
FOR THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION WE
APPRECIATE WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND THE AMENDMENTS THAT
HE HAS TAKEN THANKFULLY WE CAN
CONTINUE THE DISCUSSIONS BUT AT
THIS POINT WE OPPOSED PROFESSOR
ABLE WILL EXPLAIN THE PROBLEMS
WITH F. B. TWELVE TWENTY
PROFESSOR JONATHAN ABLE OF UC
HASTINGS HAS RESEARCHED AN
WRITTEN EXTENSIVELY ABOUT
BRADY'S APPLICATION TO POLICE
MISCONDUCT RECORDS. INCLUDING A
NATIONWIDE STUDY PUBLISHED IN
THE STANFORD LAW REVIEW HE HAS
ALSO SERVED AS COUNSEL FOR ME
BECAUSE LAW PROFESSORS AND THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT MOST
RECENT BRADY VERSUS PITCHES
CASE A LADS VERSUS COURT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU IT HELLO THIS IS
JONATHAN ABLE I WANT TO START
BY THANKING YOU VERY MUCH FOR
CONSIDERING THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE. THE COMMITTEE DESERVES A
LOT OF CREDIT FOR TAKING BRADY
SO SERIOUSLY. BUT THIS BILL IS
DEEPLY FLAWED. IT'S NOT JUST A
MISSED OPPORTUNITY IT'S
ACTUALLY GOING TO MAKE THINGS
WORSE. THE BASIC PROBLEM. IS
THAT THE PREVIOUS. BILL IS MUCH
NARROWER MUCH NARROWER THAN
WHAT BRADY REQUIRES. IF YOU'RE
GOING TO MAKE IT A FEDERAL
CONSTITUTIONAL LAW LIKE BRADY
INTO A STATUTE. YEP MAKE SURE
THE STATUTE SWEEPS AT LEAST AS
BROADLY AS BRADY. THE PREVIOUS
HERE FELT THAT PASSED. HERE A
FEW EXAMPLES OF CONDUCT IT
SHOULD LAND AN OFFICER. ON A
REAL BRIEF THE LAST. BUT NOT
THE LIST TO FIND IN THIS BILL.
FOR EXAMPLE AN OFFICER
TESTIFIED THAT A SUPPRESSION
HEARING. THE JUDGE FINDS THE
OFFICER LIED AND TO SUPPRESS
THAT THE EVIDENCE. THAT SHOULD
PUT THE OFFICER ON THE BRADY
LIST BUT IT WOULDN'T IN THE WAY%
THE BREEDING AT IS DEFINED. IN
MIGHT FIND OFFICER LIABLE. FOR
VIOLATING SOMEONE'S CIVIL
RIGHTS BY FABRICATING EVIDENCE.
FOR A PROSECUTOR DURING TRIAL
PRESS MIGHT DETERMINE THAT AN
OFFICER IS NOT TELLING THE
TRUTH AND DECIDE NOT TO CALL
THE OFFICER AS A WITNESS. IN
THESE INSTANCES THE OFFICERS
CONDUCT SHOULD WIN THE OFFICER
ON A PREVIOUS. BUT A PROSECUTOR
FOLLOWING YOUR BILL DEFINITION
OF THE PREVIOUS WITH MISTY AND
OTHER EXAMPLES OF READING
MATERIAL. THE BILL CONTAINS
SOME OTHER WORRISOME CARGO.
BREEDING MUST BE TURNED OVER
CONTINUOUSLY BUT YOUR BILL
ALLOWED JUST YEARLY UPDATE. THE
PROCESS FOR NOTIFYING OFFICERS
AND ALLOWING THEM TO APPEAL
PRETTY DETERMINATION. IF THAT
AT ALL INTERFERES WITH THE
PROSECUTOR'S JUDGMENT ABOUT WHO
SHOULD BE ON THE LIST WHAT THE
F. I WOULD REDUCE WELL. IN AN
OFFICER WHO LEADS THE
DEPARTMENT. UNDER INVESTIGATION
AND GOES TO ANOTHER DEPARTMENT.
WOULD LIKELY BE ABLE TO EVADE
DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS MIGHT
NOT APPEAR ON EITHER
DEPARTMENTS FREEDOS. SO YEAH
THERE ARE FLAWS IN YOU MAY BE
THINKING WELL THE BILL BETTER
THAN NOTHING. IN I REALLY WISH
I COULD AGREE WITH THAT. BUT
THE TROUBLE IS THERE'S
BASICALLY NO BENEFIT TO A U. S.
BASED ON THE MATERIAL DESCRIBED
IN SUBDIVISION G. TO. BECAUSE
THE CURRENT GET ACCESS TO ALL
THAT INFORMATION ON THEIR OWN
THROUGH PUBLIC RECORDS REQUESTS
FOR COURT SEARCHING. SO WHEN
YOU HAVE SUCH A MARGINAL
BENEFIT IN TERMS OF WHAT THE
BRADY WHAT IS GOING ON COVER IF
THE THINK ABOUT WHAT THE COSTS
ARE AND- I THINK. THE
PRESIDENTIAL ONE. AT FIRST WHAT
WELL INTENTIONED PROSECUTORS
WHO BASED THEIR RESPONDENTS
DEFINITION IN THIS BILL WILL
END UP VIOLATING BRADY BECAUSE
OF. THE BILL'S NARROW
DEFINITION OF WHAT COUNTS.
BORING ON THE BRIDGE LIST. IN
THERE'S THE ADDITIONAL ISSUE
THAT ANY PROSECUTOR WHO IS NOW
FOLLOWING BRADY BY LOOKING AT
THE FULL RANGE OF MISCONDUCT
MATERIAL YOU KNOW BEYOND WHAT
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE. WELL
THAT PROSECUTOR IS IMMEDIATELY
GOING TO FACE PRESSURE FROM
POLICE UNIONS. WHO ARE GONNA
SAY JUST STICK TO WHAT THE
STATUTE REQUIRES THE GONNA.
ATTACK THAT A PROSECUTOR BUT
POLITICALLY- IN TERMS OF
LITIGATION. M. THEN REALLY
WORST OF ALL THERE ARE BAD
ACTORSWHO WILL SUPPRESS
READING MATERIAL AND HIDE
BEHIND THE EXCUSE. THAT THEY'RE
JUST FOLLOWING THE STATUTE. ON
TOP OF ALL THIS. I THINK THIS
BILL IS GOING TO KEY UP ABOUT
HALF A DOZEN CONSTITUTIONAL
CHALLENGES AND IT WILL BE A
REAL MESS. SO I DON'T WANT TO
CLOSE I THINK THERE IS
LEGISLATIVE ACTION THAT COULD
IMPROVE PRETTY COMPLIANCE. I'M
CONFIDENT YOU'RE GOING TO GET
THERE. BUT FIRST YOU HAVE TO
VOTE AGAINST THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU- ARE THERE. ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
IN THE HEARING ROOM. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION- VIA
CONFERENCING. THAT NUMBER IS A
MODERATOR COULD YOU DO TO DIAL
IN OPPOSITION. THE LADIES ON
THE PHONE LINES HERE IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. THE END OF
YOUR IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO WILL FIRST GO TO
NUMBER TWO SIXTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER MISTER CHAIR- IF
WE DO LOCATE- MISREPORTING THEN
THE VIRTUAL UNIVERSE IF WE CAN
HAVE HIM TESTIFY AS WELL THAT
WOULD BE GREAT. RIGHT THANK YOU.
ONCE AGAIN NUMBER NUMBER TWO
FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON TO MARK TOOK OUT ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE IN SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE
TWENTY THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
DOESN'T LOOK. NUMBER SEVEN FIVE
FOOD ON THE FAMED. I THINK THE
CREE HOURS. THE. THANK YOU YOUR
NAME AND I'M GOING TO BE A
WITNESS BUT HAVE TO WAIT FOR
THEM TO GET TO THE BILL THEM.
THIRTY FIVE ON THE ALBUM. HELLO
NAME MMHM THIS IS S. B. TWELVE
TWENTY- BURKE OUR UNIT RIGHT
BILL. BUDGET WE'LL GO DO-
NUMBER ONE EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
RESPECT WHEN OPPOSITION. WILL
NOW GO TO NUMBER TWO SIXTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
MIGUEL LEYVA I'M WITH THAT B.
C. C. N. I. SUPPORT BEGINS.
FOUR NINE. BUT NEXT TO A NUMBER
SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DENIS CUEVAS ROMERO WHAT THEY
FEEL YOU'LL CALIFORNIA
REGRETTABLY OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED WE APPRECIATE AUTHORS
WORK ON THE BILL BUT- BELIEVE
THE BILL STILL NEEDS A LITTLE-
SOMEWHERE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOGLE THE NUMBER THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BANNEKER
DHARMA ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE ALSO REGRETTABLY AND IN
AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION AT AND ALSO HAPPY TO
BE A PART OF FURTHER
DISCUSSIONS ON THE BILL. THANK
YOU. IT ONCE AGAIN IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO
FURTHER IN Q. PLEASE CONTINUE
MISTER CHAIR. AND BRING IT WELL
BEFORE WE BRING YOU BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE IS. YOUR WITNESS. IT
IS JUST SUBJECT LOCAL DIDN'T IT
BODINE SAN FRANCISCO DA IS A-
IS HE AVAILABLE. WE CURRENTLY
DO NOT HAVE- JUST BOOTING
DIALED INTO THE CALL. SO ALL
RIGHT BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS. MISS
BAR KAY AND THEY MISSED THE
COURT. WELL I PROBABLY WON'T DO
JUSTICE WITH THE DA WOUD HAVE
DONE BUT I'LL DO MY BEST I'M SO.
I IN MY PRACTICE REPRESENTED A
GENTLEMAN WHO WAS WRONGFULLY
CONVICTED AND SPENT TEN YEARS
ON DEATH ROW AS A RESULT OF A
BRADY VIOLATION. DOCUMENTS THAT
WERE AS ONE OF THE OPPOSITION
WITNESSES MENTIONED. PURPOSELY
WITHHELD BUT NONETHELESS WITH
FROM MY CLIENT. AND WE WERE
ABLE TO GET HIM OFF BUT HE
NEVER GOT THOSE TEN YEARS OF
HIS LIFE BACK AND SO I THINK
THAT THAT SEEKS JUST TO WHAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT WHICH IS
THE- THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO HAVE.
THAT EXONERATING EVIDENCE
AVAILABLE TO THE DEFENSE AND
DEFENSE COUNSEL IN ORDER TO PUT
ON THE BEST DEFENSE POSSIBLE
WHICH IS REALLY THE
FUNDAMENTAL. PROTECTIONS THAT
ARE. SUPPOSED TO BE BUILT INTO
OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
AND BY NO MEANS DO I READ THIS
BILL AND I WOULD ASK IF YOU
AGREE WITH ME TO LIMIT ANY WAY
SHAPE OR FORM THE RIGHTS
GRANTED. MEDIA SUGGEST BY THE
OPPOSITE GEN. BUT INSTEAD TO
PUT FORTH A PROCEDURE THAT WILL
HELP INSURE FOR THE DEFENDANTS
GET. THAT MATERIAL BUT IF
SOMETHING IS NOT. WITHIN THE
SCOPE OF THIS BILL BY NO MEANS
DOES THAT MEAN NDA DOESN'T HAVE
TO TURN IT OVER. DO YOU AGREE
WITH ME. SO ASSEMBLY WOMAN ARE
QUE HAND. APPRECIATE YOUR
EXAMPLE THAT IS EXACTLY CORRECT
THAT THAT. ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT SOME SADLY SOME
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES ARE
NOT COMPLYING WITH THEIR BRADY
REQUIREMENTS THIS CODIFIES IT.
THIS LEAVES IT SHOULD LEAVE NO
AMBIGUITY AS THE THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY- LET ME RESPOND
TO THE PROFESSORS WRONG
HEADEDNESS- WITH RESPECT TO-
FOR EXAMPLE HOW OFTEN. THE
BRADY LIST NEEDS TO BE PRODUCED
UPON REQUEST MUST BE PRODUCED
AS WELL AS ANNUALLY IT'S NOT AN
EITHER OR- SITUATION. IN TERMS
OF WHAT MUST BE LISTED. IT IS
ANY. ISSUE OF MORAL. IS
DETERMINED BY AN APPELLATE
COURT IN CALIFORNIA AND SO. IT
IS IT IS QUITE BROAD. IT ALSO
REQUIRES IF THERE'S A SUSTAIN
FINDING OF GROUP BIAS. WHICH IS
DIFFERENT SO THE EXAMPLE THAT
I'VE USED IS THE MARK FUHRMAN
EXAMPLE- IN THE OJ SIMPSON
TRIAL WE'RE CLEARLY HE
EXHIBITED. EVIDENCE OF GROUP
BIAS WHICH SHOULD HAVE BEEN
REVEALED TO THE DEFENSE AND
THEY FOUND IT I THINK
SERENDIPITOUSLY BUT MANY OF
AND- SO THAT WOULD NOT WELL. IF
COMPLIED WITH THAT SITUATION
WOULDN'T EXIST. ALSO THIS
SIMPLY CODIFIES THE PRACTICE OF
ALAMEDA AND SAN FRANCISCO
ANOTHER COUNTY VENTURA COUNTY
THAT THAT'S EXISTED FOR SOME
TIME SO TO THE EXTENT THAT
THERE ARE CONSTITUTIONAL
CHALLENGES. THAT THAT BOAT HAS
BEEN MISSED FOR A VERY LONG
TIME WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS
THIS PROVIDES EIGHT IN CODIFIES
REQUIREMENTS TO MAKE SURE THE
CIRCUMSTANCE THAT YOU
DESCRIBED. IF IT HAPPENS IT
HAPPENS BECAUSE OF- SOMEONE A
PROSECUTOR SALIH WHO WILLFULLY
DISOBEYED THE LAW. MISTER CLARK
GEN MISTER LUCKY. HELLO ONE
CONCERN. WAS MOVED INTO THE
OPPOSITION. EXOME IS THAT YOUR
NOT FOLLOWING AND PROTECTIVE
WITH THE YEAR LIMIT FOR THE
CONDITIONS AS WELL WOULD YOU
LIKE TO RESPOND TO THAT SO IT
DOESN'T THE BRACE REQUIREMENT
IF HIS ACCOUNT IS A
CONSTITUTIONAL REQUIREMENT. BUT
BUT IT IT IS A CONSTANT
REQUIREMENT THAT. EVIDENCE THAT
WOULD BE USED FOR EXAMPLE IN
CROSS EXAMINATION B. B. TURNED
OVER SO THERE IS MEAN THAT THIS
IS AGAIN THE LONG STANDING
POLICY OF A NUMBER OF DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS OFFICES THAT THAT HAS
NOT BEEN CHALLENGE THAT HAS NOT
BEEN SUCCESSFULLY CHALLENGED.
THERE ARE ISSUES WITH THE
PITCHES MOTION SO. IF FOR
EXAMPLE THERE'S AN OFFICER THAT
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY IS TOLD
HAS POTENTIAL BRADY MATERIAL
POTENTIAL- MISCONDUCT IN THEIR
PERSONNEL FILE. THEN IT'S
TURNED OVER THE DA THAN SIMPLY
SAYS THE DEFENSE COUNSEL
THERE'S SOME MATERIAL HERE THAT
YOU MAY WANT TO- BE AWARE OF
AND THEN A COURT. EXAMS IT AND
INTERNS AT ALL EXCEPT
DISTINCTION. BY THE WAY IF
THERE IS SOMETHING QUITE
EGREGIOUS IF THERE'S SOMETHING
LIKE A FELONY CONVICTION FOR
PERJURY THAT FIVE YEAR LIMIT IS
NOT A LIMITATION ON THEIR
OBLIGATION. CLAIMING THE WORLD
WILL HAVE MOVEMENT-O'DONNELL
YEAH. HELLO THE IT IT IT
DOESN'T IT DOESN'T- IT IT IT
REQUIRES THAT WITHIN THAT FIVE
YEAR PERIOD SUSTAINED FINDINGS
OF MISCONDUCT FOR EXAMPLE THAT
MIGHT NOT RESULT IN A CRIMINAL
CONVICTION MUST BE TURNED OVER
BUT A PERJURY CONVICTION WOULD
HAVE TO BE TURNED OVER
IRRESPECTIVE OF THE TIME LIMIT.
THE WELL ONLY UNDERSTAND
ROBINSON SIX. THIS IS A LOT
HARDER. I'M NOT SURE I'M GOING
TO VOTE ON THIS THANK YOU.
FIFTY S. THE I'M READY WHEN YOU
YES YOU MAKE. OKAY OFF LET ME
THINK YOU FOR A HOLDING TRUE TO
YOUR AMENDMENTS THAT YOU'VE
TAKEN. THAT MAKES THIS BILL AS
SOON AS REASONABLE. AS IT IS
NOW- I DO HAVE CONCERNS WITH
THE BILL AS A- YOU'RE PROBABLY
AWARE THE AMBIGUITY OF MORAL
TURPITUDE GIVES ME LITTLE
CONSTERNATION. AND THE
INCONSISTENCY FROM COUNTY TO
COUNTY OF. HOW YOU DEFINE THAT
IS THIS A DIFFICULTY HOWEVER I
DO SEE THE ATTENTION. TO BE
NORMAL FOR WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO ACCOMPLISH AND BY THE TIME
WE NEED TO BUILD BACK. PUBLIC
TRUST. I THINK THAT THIS IS A
REPORT MEASURE FOR US TO HELP
SUPPORT AND HOPEFULLY WE GET TO
A PLACE TO WHERE. PEOPLE WILL
SEE THAT FOR WHAT YU'RE
INTENDED TO TRY TO ACCOMPLISH
SO. YOU'LL GET MY SUPPORT TODAY
THANK YOU SOMEONE MEMBER- WE
ARE CONSCIOUS OF THE FACT THAT
THERE FIFTY COUNTIES WITH MAYBE
FIFTY DIFFERENT STANDARDS
THAT'S WHY WE'RE TRYING TO
CODIFY AND STANDARDIZED SUCH
THAT IT IF THE APPELLATE COURT
IN CALIFORNIA TO FIND SOMETHING
IS- IMPACTING MORAL TURPITUDE
THAT APPLIES TO ALL THE COUNTS.
BY STATEWIDE. THANK YOU FOR ANY
OTHER COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. YOU MAY CLOSE MISTER
AMBER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND YOUR
STAFF FOR WORKING SO DILIGENTLY
ON THIS I REQUEST AN HONORABLE.
AND I AND I THANK YOU I KNOW
YOU'VE BEEN WORKING VERY. VERY
HARD IS THE NUMBER. NUMBER
CALLS WE'VE HAD IT BEEN
NUMEROUS AND WE'VE GOT ALL THIS
AND I COMMEND YOU FOR WORKING
COMMITTEE FOR PUTTING THE
MEMBERS TO TRY TO GET AS CLOSE
OR CLOSER- I REALLY THINK WE
NEED TO GET THIS OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE SO THAT. THAT AND I
ALSO KNOW YOUR COMMITMENT TO
CONTINUE WORKING THAT THIS
ISN'T THE LAST STOP. AND
OBVIOUS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
BILL AS WAS SAID EARLIER PEOPLE
GETTING PROSECUTED. BECAUSE THE
FALSE EVIDENCE AND THINGS OF
THAT NATURE AND I GREW UP WITH
MY VICE CHAIR IT COULD START TO
BUILD. SOME CONFIDENCE IN OUR
LEGAL SYSTEM WHEN WE START TO
UNVEIL ALL OF THOSE. OUR I
WOULD LOVE TO CALL CRIMES THAT.
MISINFORMATION IT SENT PEOPLE
TO JAIL THE MESSAGE THEIR LIVES
THEIR LIVELIHOOD AND KEEPING
THE CAR SERRATED- THAT WE NEED
THE STATE. DA'S AND NEED ALL
THE EVIDENCE THAT THEY NEED TO
KNOW YOU TO TURN IT OVER TO
PUBLIC DEFENDER SO THAT THEY
NEED TO KNOW AND SO BUT- WE
NEED TO GET THERE. SO THANK YOU
THANK YOU. WE HAVE A MOTION AND
SECOND. VENTURE GLOBAL. ON SB
TWELVE TWENTY THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER HI JONES
SAWYER HI LACKEY LACKEY HI
BARRICADE HAND HOW CAN I DEEP.
DEEP I KAMLAGER KAMLAGER NOT
VOTING COURT OBERNOLTE CORP NOT
VOTING SANTIAGO. SAN DIEGO HI
STONE. WITH THE MEASURE PASSES
THANK REFORM. I OFTEN SAY THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SO I'M MORE
DISCOUNT SO RIGHT RIGHT I. I'VE
BEEN SAYING THAT FOR THIRTY
YEARS SO OF THE NEXT MEASURE IS
SB ELEVEN NINETY SIX SB ELEVEN
NINETY SIX SIMPLY CODIFIES THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER ON
PRICE GOUGING AND ADDS A
ANOTHER PROVISION THAT CLOSE A
LOOPHOLE FOR. THOSE WHO ARE NEW
SELLERS TO THE MARKET SO FOR
EXAMPLE IF YOU WEREN'T SELLING
HAND SANITIZER AND THEN AS A
CONSEQUENCE OF THE EMERGENCY
YOU GET. ON THAT- THAT HAND
SANITIZER SOAP I URGE A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU. ARE THERE ANY IT D.
OF WITNESSES RIGHT I KNOW THAT
THEIR. WHEN SHE HIT ON THE HEAD
WITH. MAYBE MR BOTH I HAVE KNOW.
I HAD LESLIE YOUNG SAID TOM
PUBLIC YOUR I'M SO IF THERE THE
ON THE LINE. THEY NOT WE TAKE A
LITTLE OF WARD IF THEY'RE ON
THE TO BE BUT- OKAY. LET FOR
YOUNG. YOU MAY MONTH DIRECT AT
THAT RIGHT HERE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR IN COMMITTEE
THAT MY NAME IS LESLIE YOUNG
AND I IN THE AT THE IF YOU'RE
ATTORNEY CHARGE OF THE FRAUD
UNIT OF THE ORANGE COUNTY JUST
ATTORNEY OFFICE. ON BEHALF OF
ORANGE COUNTY DIST ATTORNEY
SPITZER I WOULD LIKE TO. SO
BYRD FOR. TO FILL. WE LEARNED A
FEW THINGS QUICKLY THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THE BRICK AND
MORTAR BUSINESSES WE CONTACTED
RELATING TO PRICE COMPLAINTS.
WERE GOOD CITIZENS WHO WANTED
TO DO THE RIGHT THING AND WHEN
THEY HAVE RAISED THEIR PRICES
IT WAS BECAUSE THERE COSTS HAD
INCREASED HOWEVER WE ALSO
LEARNED THAT THERE IS A SEGMENT
OF THE SELLERS OUT THERE WHO
WOULD JUMP INTO THE BUSINESS OF
SELLING THAT ITEM FOR THE
PURPOSE OF PROFITING FROM THE
CRISIS. UNFORTUNATELY THESE
WERE NEW SELLERS WHO WERE NOT
COVERED BY THE CURRENT PRICE
GOUGING LAW IF YOU'LL CODE
SECTION THREE NINETY SIX. SB.
ELEVEN NINETY SIX AMEND PENAL
CODE THREE NINETY SIX YOU MAKE
IT APPLY TO NEW SELLERS.
CREATING A PRESUMPTION THAT A
NEW SELLER WHO CHARGES MORE
THAN 50% ABOUT THEIR COST FOR
THE PRODUCT IS GETTING PRICE
GOUGING. THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
STEP THE STOCK PROFITEERS FROM
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF OUR
CITIZENS DURING A CRISIS. WE
THINK THIS COMMITTEE FOR
CONSIDERATION AND STRONGLY URGE
AN ITEM. ON SB ELEVEN NINETY
SIX. AND MEDICARE IS POP GEORGE.
FROM THE SAN DIEGO OFFICE CAN
YOU HEAR ME. I SURE CAN. THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. ON TOM PAPA GEORGE
FROM SAN DIEGO D. A. I'M IN
CHARGE OF THE SAN DIEGO CA
CONSUMER PROTECTION UNIT. AS
YOU HEARD OUR CURRENT LAW
PROHIBITS PRICE GOUGING EVER DO
THIS AGAIN. DURING DECLARED
EMERGENCIES I'M PROUD TO SAY
THAT I DRAFTED THE ORIGINAL
PENAL CODE SECTION THREE NINETY
SIX. ASSEMBLY MEMBER RICHARD
KATZ AFTER THE NINETY FOUR SAN
FERNANDO EARTHQUAKE. AND OVER
THE YEARS- THE LAW HAS PROVEN
TO BE A VERY VALUABLE TOOL TO
HELP US. PROTECT CONSUMERS FROM
THIS KIND OF ABUSE BUT OUR
CURRENT OVER THE VIRGIN SHE HAS
SHOWN THAT WE NEED TO UPDATE
THE LAW. IN SEVERAL WAYS AT
FIRST THE BILL CLARIFIES THAT
PRICE GOUGING APPLIES TO ALL
DECLARED EMERGENCIES. INCLUDING
PANDEMICS AND EPIDEMICS. AND
YOU ALSO INCLUDING ONLINE
SELLERS- THAT'S NOT SPECIFIED
IN CURRENT LAN THIS ELIMINATES
THAT UNCERTAINTY. MOST
IMPORTANT THE CURRENT LAW DOES
NOT COVER THOSE WHO DID NOT
SELL BEFORE THE DECLARATION
EMERGENCY. THE REASON FOR THAT
IS BACK IN NINETY FOUR- THE
INTERNET MARKETPLACE FOLKS
JUMPING INTO OFFERED IN NINETY
FIVE MASKS RIGHT RAISES PRICES
SIMPLY WASN'T OF MARKETPLACE
PHENOMENON BUT TODAY IT MOST
DEFINITELY IS. WE NEED TO
ADDRESS THE NEW SELLERS TO POP
UP OVERNIGHT THIS BILL X.
STANDS A LOT OF COVER NEW
SELLERS AS WELL AS EXISTING
SELLERS SO THE LOP PLIAGE
EQUALLY TO ALL BUSINESSES. IT
ALSO GIVES YOU THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR THE RIGHT TO
EXTEND THESE PROHIBITIONS. FOR
MORE THAN THIRTY DAYS IF NEEDED
WE'VE NOW SEEN AT A DECLARE
CRISIS CAN LAST MONTHS SO WE
THINK THIS IS IMPORTANT
FLEXIBILITY TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC ADEQUATELY. WILL BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
WE THANK YOU FOR ATTENTION AND
HOPE YOU WILL BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT THIS IMPROVEMENT TO OUR
PRICE GOUGING LAW. THANK YOU
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES OF IT THERE ARE NO
OTHER WITNESSES BUT MISTER
CHAIR I WANT TO NOTE THAT WE
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE'S MOMENTS.
ARE SPENT ASHA SO. YOU FOR X.
COMMITTEE. I'M AMENDMENTS. ARE
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESS WITHIN
THE COMMITTEE HERE. ARE ANY
WITNESSES DURING THE VIDEO
TELECONFERENCING MISTER
MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES THAT ARE DOWN IN
DIALING THAT ARE AND UP THERE
IN SUPPORT. HYLLISIA MANIFOLD
MONIKER IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN
ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN INSTRUMENT
GROUP SAID SHE EXPECTATIONS AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. YEAH WE'LL
GO TO NUMBER TWO FIFTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MISTER KAREN MEMBERS BY
APOLOGIZING BECAUSE THE FIGHT
EARLIER ACCIDENTALLY NICOLE
PERLMAN ON BEHALF OF THE ORANGE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN NINETY
SIX. THANK YOU. NEXTRA NUMBER
TWO SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WE'RE BACK ON MARKET
I'LL BE HAPPY TENER PUBLIC
INTEREST LAW SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
NEXA NUMBER FORTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ANNA KELLY ON BEHALF
OF THE ALAMEDA COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NEXT TO BE NUMBER
ONE EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND ON BEHALF OF
TURN THE UTILITY REFORM NETWORK
BOTH IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. BUT
NEXT TO THE NUMBER TWO SIXTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS ANTHONY LEASE ON BEHALF OF
ATTORNEY GENERAL JAVIER BECERRA
WANTED THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
WORKING WITH THE PHONE BILL WE
ARE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT
WILL BE NUMBER TWO EIGHTY TWO
EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
MARKET ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. NEXT TO THE NUMBER TWO
SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON TO MARK LOWCOCK
ON BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WELL NOW GONNA
NUMBER TWO SEVENTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. DANIELLE
COUNTERCULTURE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME CONSUMER
COALITION IN SUPPORT. AND ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. ZERO ONE
ZERO IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT. AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NO FURTHER IN
SUPPORT PLEASE CONTINUE MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. I
THINK I HAVE A DENNIS ALBION NY.
SAYS CALIFORNIA'S SEED
ASSOCIATION. THERE ARE IN
OPPOSITION. YEAH OKAY. WE
SHOULD BE ON THE PHONE MISTER
MODERATOR. FOR YOU SAID A
DENNIS TELL BE ANI YEAH THAT'S
WHAT I HAVE HERE AND- ON MY
RECORDS. ONE MOMENT. A DENNIS
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD HELLO I WANT TO THANK YOU
OF THE CHAIR AND MISTER ON
BURKE THIS IS DENNIS ALBION THE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SEA
DISASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA GRAIN
AND FEED CALIFORNIA- PACIFIC A
POULTRY ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
WAREHOUSE ASSOCIATION AND A
GROUP OF COMMODITIES THIS ISSUE
WE HAVE WORKED WITH THE- OFFICE
OF SENATOR- AND WE'RE INFORMED
THAT THEIR WORK ON THE
AMENDMENT WE HAD A FOUR. AND WE
REMOVE UNITS OUR OPPOSITION AND
APPRECIATE THE WORK BY THE
COMMITTEE- THE STAFF AND MR
BURKE TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE AND
WE APPRECIATE THAT AND WILL. BE
REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER. OTHER
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM IN OUR
HERO. ANY BETTER ON THE VIDEO
CONFERENCING. AND OF COURSE ARE
THERE ANY DIAL IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL. PLEASE JOIN ME ON
THE PHONE LINE IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. HE HAD ONE ZERO IF YOU
WERE IN OPPOSITION. ONE TEN ONE
ZERO HERE IN OPPOSITION. AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NO ONE IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE CONTINUE
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU ARE
THERE ANY BRING BACK TO
COMMITTEE OPPORTUNITY I JUST
HAVE A MEMBERS I'M A LITTLE
CONFUSED BY. THE REMARKS OF
THE- REMOVED OPPOSITION IS
THERE ANOTHER AMENDMENT THAT
WE'RE NOT AWARE THAT IT WILL
THIS IS LATE BREAKING- YEAH YES
OF. MISTER ROBBIE ANI AND HIS
CLIENTS WERE CONCERNED THAT FOR
EXAMPLE IF A BUSHEL OF WHEAT ON
THE CHICAGO MERCANTILE
EXCHANGE. OF INCREASED IN PRICE
BY MORE THAN 10% THAT THAT
THERE MIGHT BE A POSSIBILITY
THAT A DISTRICT ATTORNEY
CALIFORNIA WOULD PROSECUTE I
THINK THAT POSSIBILITY IS
EXTREMELY REMOTE. BUT RATHER
RATHER THAN. WORRY ABOUT THAT
POSSIBILITY- WE'VE AGREED THAT
IF THERE IS A COMMODITY THAT'S
LISTED ON A NATIONAL OR
INTERNATIONAL EXCHANGE. AND
THEN THE PRICE FLUCTUATION IS A
IS SORT OF A NORMAL COURSE OF
ACTIVITY THAT THAT IS NOT
SUBJECT TO PRICE GOUGING. THANK
YOU YES YES OUR FEDERAL NUMBER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR TAKING
A MOMENT I DID HAVE THE SAME
CONCERNS AS THE SEASON FARMERS
AND OTHER AGRICULTURAL GROUPS-
AND- MUCH SUPPORT TO BUILD
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS YES. MISTER
TYLER D. THANK YOU MATH OF
SENATE NUMBER OF THE- THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO. A CO
SPONSOR THIS MEASURE SOWITH
YOU- I JUST WANTED TO RAISE A
POINT- IT IN TERMS OF- THIS
MEASURE. BEING RETROACTIVELY
APPLY I KNOW THAT YOU SAID YOU
TOOK THE COMMITTEE MEMBER AND I
HAVE I'M NOT SURE WHAT. IF THAT
AMENDMENT ADDRESS- THAT CONCERN
BUT- WOULD YOU COMMENT. THE
FACT THAT. YOUR BILL WOULD.
RETROACTIVELY PENALIZE PEOPLE
WHO MAY BE- CHARGE A HIGHER
PRICES BECAUSE THE TO THE
PANDEMIC SO THIS. IN ESSENCE
CODIFIES THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER SO TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOMEONE IS ENGAGING
ACTIVITY IT'S VIOLATIVE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER THEY
WOULD BE SUBJECT TO POTENTIAL
PROSECUTION. HOWEVER YES TO THE
NEW PROVISION WHICH IS THE
PROVISION THAT PROVIDES IF
YOU'RE A NEW ENTRANT IN THE
MARKET PLACE AND YOU INCREASE
PRICE ABOVE 50% BOB YOU WOULD
NOT BE SO YOU CAN'T BE SUBJECT
TO A CRIMINAL PENALTY FOR A LAW
THAT'S OT AFFECTED THE TIME
THE ACT OCCURS SO- THIS IS NO
DIFFERENT THAN ANY OTHER.
CRIMINAL. PROVISION PENAL CODE
PROVISION RIGHT. THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS YOU MAY CLOSE MISTER
AMBER AYE URGENT AYE VOTE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THE NEXT YEAR
SHARES RECKON MINION I VOTE
ESPECIALLY FOR ALL YOUR HARD
WORK OF MEDICARE WHAT. DO YOU
CALL THE ROLL. ON SB ELEVEN
NINETY SIX THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER HI JOHN SO YOUR IRAQI.
JACKIE H BARRICADE CAN
BARRICADE HAND DEEP. HI
KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER I WORK ONE
QUICK HI SANTIAGO SAN DIEGO I
STILL. AS A THE MEASURE PANIC
YOU IT MR BODY CALLS PLEASE
GIVE. AND NOW DO ITEMS EIGHTEEN
IN NINETEEN SB SEVEN SEVEN SIX.
AT S. B. TEN SIXTY FOUR- THAT'S
SKINNER WHICH SERVICE SEVEN SIX
EXPERIENCE THE CATEGORY OF
PEACE OFFICERS RELEASE OF
RECORDS. AND IN SIXTEEN SIXTY
FOUR CONFIDENTIAL INFORMANTS.
WHICH EVERYONE YOU WANT TO DO
FIRST. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M HERE TO
PRESENT THAT SB SEVEN SEVEN
SIX- AS SOME OF YOU ARE
FAMILIAR. FOR FORTY YEARS
CALIFORNIA HAD A COMPLETE BAN
TOTAL SECRECY ON ALL POLICE
RECORD. THAT CHANGED IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WITH THE PASSAGE OF SB
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE AND SB
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE ALLOWED FOR
A LIMITED SET OF RECORDS- TO BE
ABLE TO BE ACCESSIBLE TO THE
PUBLIC IN A VERY LIMITED SET- I
THINK WHAT WE HAVE SEEN IN
RECENT MONTHS IS THAT. OUR
COMMUNITIES. DEMAND MORE. AND
THAT ALL OF US DESERVE TO KNOW
ABOUT THE CONDUCT OF THE
OFFICERS WHO WERE ON THE BEACH
IN OUR NEIGHBORHOODS. AND WHILE
SOME OF OUR POLICE UNIONS
FOUGHT AGAINST FOURTEEN TWENTY
ONE VERY STRENUOUSLY. THERE IS
A VERY DIFFERENT ATTITUDE
AMONGST OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
COMMUNITY TODAY AND PORAC HAS
RECENTLY THOSE LARGEST UNION
HAS RECENTLY PUT OUT THEIR
STATEMENT OF PRINCIPLES WHERE
THEY INCLUDE. SUPPORT FOR MORE
TRANSPARENCY. AND SO WHAT SB
SEVEN SEVEN SIX DOES IS IT
BUILDS ON FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE.
AND IT STRENGTHENS OUR CURRENT
LAW BY EXPANDING ACCESS TO
RECORDS ON A WIDER RANGE OF
USES OF FORCE. IT ALSO ALLOWS
US TO FIND OUT ABOUT ANY
OFFICERS THAT MAY HAVE A
HISTORY OF ENGAGING IN RACIST
OR DISCRIMINATORY ACTIONS. IT
ALSO ALERT SAYS FIND OUT ABOUT
INFORMATION ABOUT OFFICERS WHO
HAVE A HISTORY OF CONDUCTING
WRONGFUL ARRESTS OR WRONGFUL
SEARCHES. AND SO THOSE ARE SOME
OF THE WAYS IN WHICH THE
RECORDS ARE EXPANDED.
ADDITIONALLY WHAT WE HAVE FOUND
IS THAT IN SOME CASES AN
OFFICER WHO MAY HAPPENED WHERE
THERE MAY BE THE AGENCY MAY BE
INITIATING INVESTIGATION THAT
THE OFFICER CHOOSES TO RESIGN.
AND THEN THE INVESTIGATION
THERE'S NO REAL PAPER TRAIL.
AND THEN THE NEXT AGENCY WHO
MIGHT HIRE THAT OFFICER HAS NO
INFORMATION ABOUT THAT CONTACT
SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS ALSO
REQUIRED THAT A RECORD BE
COMPLETED IF AN OFFICER RESIGNS
PRIOR TO ANY COMPLETED
INVESTIGATION. AND THEN IF- IF
YOU ARE THE HIRING AGENCY IN
YOUR HIRING SOMEONE WHO WAS A
FORMER OFFICER THAT YOU REQUEST
THE FULL ARRAY OF RECORDS SO DO
YOU HAVE FULL KNOWLEDGE OF THE
BACKGROUND OF THE OFFICER THAT
YOU'RE HIRING BECAUSE THE OTHER
THING THAT WE HEAR VERY
COMMONLY AS WE SOMETIMES HEAR
EITHER MAYORS POLICE CHIEFS
RATHER SAY WE DID NOT KNOW. THE
HIS THIS BACKGROUND ABOUT THIS
OFFICER. SO IT HELPS ENSURE
THAT WE KNOW. IT ALSO ALLOWS
FOR THE HOLDING OF RECORDS
LONGER THAN FIVE YEARS NOW THE
RECORDS OR ELECTRONIC OUR
STATUTE THAT ONLY REQUIRED FIVE
YEARS OF RECORDS ONE WAS REALLY
APPROPRIATE WHEN OUR RECORDS
WERE JUST PAPER NOW ALL OF OUR
RECORDS OR ELECTRONIC THERE'S
NO REASON TO HAVE THEM.
ELIMINATED AFTER FIVE YEARS
ONLY FINALLY IT DEALS WITH THE
FACT THAT SOME AGENCIES WERE
VERY RELUCTANT TO RELEASE
RECORDS AND EITHER. DID NOT
FOUR CHARGED EXORBITANT FEES TO
THE PUBLIC- REQUESTING THEM SO
THE BILL HAS SOME PROVISIONS
REGARDING THAT. AND I WOULD
NOTE THAT THE BILL DOES NOT GO
AS FAR AS THE LAW THAT NEW YORK
PASSED RECENTLY WHEN THEY
REPEALED THEIR LAW FIFTY EIGHT.
BUT I THINK THIS IS A VERY IT
BRINGS CALIFORNIA MUCH CLOSER
IN LINE WITH MANY MANY OTHER
STATES THAT HAVE MORE
TRANSPARENCY AROUND POLICE
RECORDS AND I THINK THAT IT
FITS. THAT APPROPRIATE- THAT
APPROPRIATE RIGHT OF THE PUBLIC
TO KNOW. WHILE STILL PROTECTING
OUR OFFICERS FROM HAVING
FRIVOLOUS OR- OR YOU KNOW
COMPLAINTS THAT ARE UNFOUNDED
BEING RELEASED THERE'S NO
REASON FOR SUCH THINGS LIKE
THAT. BUT WE CERTAINLY ALL
DESERVE TO KNOW IF AN OFFICER
HAS ANY KIND OF HISTORY OF-
CONDUCT IN THE IN THE AREAS
THAT I DESCRIBED- I HAVE SOME
WITNESSES TECHNICAL WITNESSES.
WHO ARE FAMILIAR WITH
INVESTIGATIONS AND- IN WHO WILL
WHO ARE- OFFERED THEIR INSIGHT
ON THE BILL. OKAY SO IS THIS
GOING TO BE LESS YES AND SUSAN
LEFT YES. RIGHT WE CAN. I THINK
IT MODERATOR. WE GET THE
LOTTERY. ARE YOU READY I'M
SORRY MY MIGRATED. KELLY OF THE
LIST LAW OFFICES OF KELLY OF
THE LIST AND SUSAN LEFT- CITY
PA THEY MAY COME IN NOW
MODERATOR. JUST A MOMENT HERE.
BUT USING YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MODERATOR AND THANK
YOU TO CHAIR JONES SAWYER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND THE
SENATOR SKINNER FOR AUTHORING
THIS IMPORTANT BILL. I MOSTLY
HERE TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE ABOUT SB
SEVEN SEVEN SIX I'M AWARE OF
THE LATENESS AND HOW LONG WE'VE
BEEN GOING- MY EXPERTISE IN
THIS AREA COMES FROM MY UNIQUE
EXPERIENCES. BOTH AS SOMEONE
WHO'S WORKED ON POLICE POLICIES
I'VE ADMINISTRATIVELY
PROSECUTED POLICE OFFICERS AT
THE SAN FRANCISCO POLICE
COMMISSION- AND I'VE BEEN A
PUBLIC DEFENDER ATTORNEY AND
I'M ON THE BOARD OF CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION. I
DO KNOWN AS SAID SKINNER JUST
DISCUSS IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN SB FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE
MADE A VERY SPECIFIC. LIMITED
AMOUNT OF INFORMATION ABOUT
CALIFORNIA LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS. BECOME PUBLIC RECORDS.
YET EVEN AFTER SB FOURTEEN
TWENTY ONE OTHER IMPORTANT
INFORMATION IS STILL HIDDEN
BEHIND POLICE SECRECY RULE.
SENATORS JUST SPOKE A MOMENT
AGO ABOUT HOW RECENTLY NEW YORK
STATE PASSED A SWEEPING NEW
REFORM LAW REFER TO IT FIFTY
EIGHT AND THAT BUILT MAKES ALL
POLICE INFORMATION AVAILABLE AS
PUBLIC RECORDS. THE PROBLEM
THERE IS THAT NEW YORK'S BILL
IS NOW GOING TO BE HELD UP IN
SIGNIFICANT ABOUT LITIGATION
BECAUSE THE POLICE OFFICERS ARE
CHALLENGING IT. HERE IN
CALIFORNIA THOUGH WE'RE IN A
DIFFERENT PLACE THE POLICE ALSO
CHALLENGED SB FOURTEEN TWENTY
ONE BUT EVERY SINGLE TIME THE
COURTS RULED THAT SB FOURTEEN
TWENTY ONE IS CONSTITUTIONAL.
SO THIS BILL IN FRONT OF YOU
TODAY SB SEVEN SEVEN SIX IS A
MUCH MORE MODERATE AN
INCREMENTAL APPROACH THAN WHAT
NEW YORK IS DONE. SB SEVEN
SEVEN SIX WITH EXPAND THE
CURRENT CATEGORY THAT SENATOR
SKINNER JUST TALKED ABOUT AND
HOLD OFFICERS ACCOUNTABLE FOR
BROADER SPECTRUM OF MISCONDUCT
INCLUDING RACIST HOMOPHOBIC
ANTI SEMITIC OR OTHER
DISCRIMINATORY BEHAVIOR. ANY
USES OF FORCE AND WE PAUSE FOR
A MOMENT- THE CURRENT BILL SB
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE PAUSES ON
THE AREA OF GREAT BODILY INJURY
BEING BEING OUT FORCED ON
SOMEONE FOR ON GAS. WHAT IT
DOESN'T TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
THOUGH IS SIGNIFICANT AS SORT
OF THE TIP OF THE ICEBERG
BECAUSE YOU HAVE LOTS OF
SITUATIONS WHERE. COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR ARE DEALING WITH AN
OFFICER WHO PULLED A GUN ON
SOMEBODY NOBODY AT THE END OF
THAT ENDS UP WITH GREAT BODILY
INJURY OR DEATH. BUT THAT KIND
OF BEHAVIOR IS THE USE OF FORCE
AND PATTERNS OF OFFICER
COMMITTING THAT KIND OF BE
MISCONDUCT. SHOULD BE THE KIND
THAT WORK WE'RE ABLE TO KEEP
AND NOT THE KIND OF BROAD
BROADER- INFORMATION WE WOULD
GET UNDER SB SEVEN SEVEN SIX
THAT IS NOT CURRENTLY CAPTURED
UNDER FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE.
SENATOR SKINNER SAID OUR
COMMUNITIES DESERVE MORE AND-
REALLY THE ONLY WAY TO GET. THE
PUBLIC TO HAVE CONFIDENCE IN
OUR LEGAL SYSTEM AS CHAIR JONES
SAWYER SAID IT EARLIER WITH
TWELVE TWENTY. IS THROUGH
TRANSPARENCY IT'S THE ONLY WAY.
TO ENSURE THE INTEGRITY OF THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. I
REMAIN AVAILABLE ON THE PHONE
TO ANSWER ANY OF YOUR QUESTIONS
AND I HOPE THAT YOU WILL OF
PROVIDED AYE VOTE ON SEVEN
SEVEN SIX. THANK YOU. AND NOW
SUSAN LEFT SHE- YEAH THAT WOULD
I THINK WE'RE WAITING FOR KELLY
KELLY I'M SORRY. HI THERE THIS
IS KELLY IN THE LEFT HAND SIDE
ARE YOU ABLE TO HEAR ME YES. A
GREAT ADVENTURE NEED
SPECIALIZING IN THE PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT MY CLIENT GOOD NEWS
ORGANIZATIONS. AND MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC. HISTORIC PASSAGE OF
SB FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE MANY OF
US HAVE FACED UNPRECEDENTED
HEARD ALL GETTING A TO BE
COMPLY WITH THE LAW. ALTHOUGH
THE LEGISLATIVE INTENT WAS
CLEAR THAT IT CAN'T HAVE BEEN
LARGELY IGNORED EVERY WORD IN
THE STATUTE HAS BECOME A
BATTLEFIELD BEING READ BY
AGENCIES IN A WAY THAT ATTEMPT
TO LIMIT OR AVOID GETS CLOSER.
EVEN IF YOU ARE FREQUENTLY
IGNORING DEADLINES AND REQUIRE
INSTEAD OF THE PUBLIC AGENCIES
HAVE DESTROYED THEM I EVEN WANT
THE CLOSER BECOMES INEVITABLE
THE RECORD THE HEAVILY REDACTED.
SB SEVEN SEVEN SIXTEEN CHANGE
BACK IF THE MUCH STEP FORWARD
IN CLOSING THE LOOPHOLE THAT
HAVE BEEN EXPLOITED IT REQUIRED
WORK TENSION OF RECORD
PROVIDING AGENCIES FROM
SHOOTING DESTRUCTION OVER
DISCLOSURE AND EXPAND THE
CATEGORY OF THE GLOBAL
INCIDENT. AREAS WHERE WE KNOW
WE HAVE PROBLEM I INTO UNDER
WARRANTY YOU COULD THE FOURTH
REGARDLESS OF THE EXTENT OF
DAMAGE IN TWO AREAS OF RACISM
BIAS DISCRIMINATION AND
WRONGFUL PURCHASED IN IRAQ. IT
ALSO CREATES A GREATER PARITY
BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
OTHER PUBLIC EMPLOYEES WHO
ALREADY HAVE INFORMATION ABOUT
COMPLAINTS INVESTIGATIONS
ROUTINELY GET PLUGGED. IT ALL
STOCK RESIGNATION FROM BEING
USED AS AN AVENUE TO
NONDISCLOSURE AND PREVENT HIM
FROM CONTACTING THE WAY THE
PUBLIC RIGHT BY AGREEING TO
REMOVE THE THING FINDING IN A
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT FOR
EXAMPLE. BY PENALTY THEN HE
RECOVERING ALSO HELPS FAMILIES
RECOUP AT LEAST SOME OF THE
COSTS THAT THEY'RE FORCED TO
INQUIRE WHEN FIGHTING FOR
ACCESS FOR EACH RECORD BUT ALSO
WILL PROVIDE AGENCIES WITH
GREATER TRANSPARENCY TO COMPORT
WITH THE GREATER INCENTIVE. TO
COMPLY WITH THE TIMELINE. AT
THANK BY REMOVING THE SAME
FINDING. IT ALLOWS THE PUBLIC
UNDER THAT. BY WHICH COMPLAINTS
OR YOU CAN LOOK FOR ARE
INVESTING. FOR Q. THEY'VE BEEN
TO BLINDLY ACCEPT AND WE'RE-
BUT- BUT HOW TO BE STUCK BACK
OF A PROFIT STATE. HAVE BEEN
PER. FROM BEING. AT THE TEN SIX
TO THE NET. THAT PAGE THAT THE
HAD OVERSIGHT OF THE GRAY
PRACTICE THAT WE PLAYED IN THE
HANDS OF LIVE NEXT AND WE ASK
FOR YOUR BOATS THANK YOU AND I
AM HAPPY. ANY QUESTIONS THE.
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE. OKAY OF.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN THE ROLE
IN SUPPORT. EIGHTY WITNESSES ON
VIDEO CONFERENCING IN SUPPORT.
AND NOW DIALING MISTER
MODERATOR- ANY OTHER WITNESSES
THAT ARE CALLING AND DIALING IN.
OF LATE IN GERMAN ON THE PHONE
LINES IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AGAIN IF
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. FIRST WE'RE GOING TO
NUMBER ONE THIRTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. REBECA GONZALEZ
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. NEXT WILL BE NUMBER
TWO EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING KAREN MEMBERS PLAN
TO CARE WHAT THE CALIFORNIA PAN
ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK IN
SUPPORT. NUMBER TWO EIGHTY
SEVEN PLEASE GOOD. DEMOCRATS
ROMERO WHAT THEY FEEL YOU OF
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
NOW GO TO NUMBER EIGHTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIRD CHILD
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. NEXT WILL BE NUMBERED
TO NINETY FOUR TO NINETY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
THE CHRISTIAN ONE BURGUNDY
HAPPENED A FRIEND COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION THAT CALIFORNIA THE
COURT THANK YOU. NEXTRA NUMBER
TWO THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIRTY THIRTY SIX RUNNING LOCAL.
WILL MOVE TO NUMBER FORTY EIGHT
FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING THE DISNEY OF THIS
NEW YORK FROM THE LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NEXT TO THE NUMBER ONE
EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND SUPPORT.
WELL NOW GO TO NUMBER TWO
NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD. JOANNE
TICKET FROM AUSTIN FEDERAL LAW
POVERTY AND. NEXTRA NUMBER ONE
TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NUMBER ONE TWENTY SIX PLEASE
MAKE SURE NOT YOU. SHE. REMOVE
THE NUMBER TWO EIGHTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
THIS IS BURDENED BY STUDY THAT
THE CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC SHARES
WITH SO CREATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT. NEXT WILL BE NUMBER
EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS EVAN MEN CAN I'M A CRACK IN
THE PRIORITY SUPPORT AT VOICES
FOR PROGRESS AND MARK JACKET
AND I'VE BEEN ASKED TO CONVEY
THAT THE PORT AT ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JACKET THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS EQUAL
RIGHTS ADVOCATES AND THEALLIANCE OF CALIFORNIANS. FOR
COMMUNITY EMPOWERMENT OR EIGHT.
NEXTRA NUMBER THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CANACCORD ANNA
ON BEHALF OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE AND
STRONG SUPPORT. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. WHAT ARE THE NUMBER
ONE TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE TWENTY SIX PLEASE MAKE SURE
NOT ON MUTE. AT THE TIME- WE DO
HAVE NO FURTHER IN SUPPORT
PLEASE CONTINUE MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. I HAVE
COREY CELL SILVA- CALIFORNIA
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION. AND
I JUST HAVE CALIFORNIA PEACE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION NO NAY.
MISTER MODERATOR YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBER. GO AHEAD I'M
SORRY MEAN CUT YOU OFF. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN BURKE
SHAUN RUNDLE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION OR CTO AT THAT WE
ARE A NON UNION LEADERSHIP
DEVELOPMENT ASSOCIATION
APARTMENT TWENTY TWO THOUSAND
COPS WHO WANT TO BE A MEET THE
BEST COPS. BUT WHILE THERE ARE
VARIOUS- POLICING AND RECORD
REFORM EFFORTS OF LATE
INCLUDING MEASURES THIS YEAR
THAT WE HAVE NOT ONLY SUPPORTED
BUT PUSHED OUT FOR SB SEVEN
SEVENTY SIX IS REGRETTABLY NOT
ONE OF THEM. THE ARGUMENTS IN
SUPPORT NEAR ANALYSIS NOTES
THAT THE BILL WOULD PROVIDE THE
PUBLIC WITH ACCESS TO PROVEN
INCIDENTS OF SEXUAL ASSAULTS
WERE. PLANTED EVIDENCE PERJURY
EXCEPT FOR. OUR BY REMOVING THE
SUSTAIN STANDARD IN THE BILL
WHICH IS THE LEGAL THRESHOLD IS
NO WE'RE NEED TO IT'S PROVEN BY
A PREPONDERANCE OF THE EVIDENCE
AND REPLACING IT WITH. THE
DETERMINATION OF COMPLAIN WAS
WHAT NOT PRIVILEGE PER NO BASIS
FOR THE INCIDENT TO BE CLEAR
ABOUT. AND THAT WOULD BE TURNED
ON. NUMBER OF COMPLAINTS
AGAINST DEPARTMENT WITH SUCH A
LOW THRESHOLD. IT WOULD
ESPECIALLY CRIPPLE SMALL AND
MEDIUM SIZED DEPARTMENTS WHICH
ARE QUITE COMMON THROUGHOUT
YOUR DISTRICT. IT'S A FAILURE
TO REPORT DUE PROCESS OF LAW BY
REQUIRING ALL ALLEGATIONS OF
PURCHASE A DISCRIMINATION BE
DISCLOSED. WITHOUT A LEGAL
FINDING OF THE FACT GIVE ME
MAKING SUCH DETERMINATION
BEYOND A REASONABLE DOUBT. THAT
MAKE NO MISTAKE THAT THE FIRST
PERSON TO WISH FOR THE BALLOT
IN SUBSEQUENT ACCOUNTABILITY OF
A BAD COP IS A GOOD COP- THAT'S
WHY AGENCIES INSTITUTE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
TOOLS LIKE BODY WORN CAMERAS.
YOU BEFORE YEARS BEFORE RECENT
HEADLINES WHY BRADY EXCEPT THE
INITIAL JUST DISCUSSED. MANY
PEOPLE TO AND THE REPORTING
BURDEN BY LOWERING THE
THRESHOLD FOR REQUESTING ACCESS
TO SUCH RECORDS WHILE LOCAL
OFFICIALS AND MANY AREAS ARE
ARE PROPOSING SHIFTING FUNDS
AWAY FROM LOCAL POLICING AGENCY
THAT'S NOT A SOUND. QUALITY TO
LOOK UP TO APPROACH TO REACH A
COMMON GOAL THAT WE ALL SHARE.
WHICH IS THE PRESERVATION OF
THE COMMUNITY STRUCK IN THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY PERSONNEL
WHO SWORE AN OATH TO PROTECT
THEM. THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES IN THE
CONSTITUTION THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AGENCIES NEED TO BE
ABLE TO COMPLY WITH THE MANDATE
THE TRANSCRIPTS REQUIREMENTS TO
REACH THAT COMMON GOAL BUT THEY
WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO IN OUR
OPINION UNDER THIS BILL. AND SO
FOR THE SAKE OF PEACE OFFICERS
ENGAGING WITH AND KEEPING YOUR
CONSTITUENTS YOU STAY CLEAR AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO SB
SEVEN SEVEN SIX THANK. THANK
YOU. IN SEVILLA COREY. MISTER
MODERATOR. REALLY FOR COREY'S
DIGITAL. LOOKS LIKE THEY HAVE
DROPPED FROM THE CALL THEY'RE
NOT CURRENTLY DIALED IN. OKAY
THANK YOU SO WE'RE NOT OPEN UP
TO ANYONE WITHIN THE ROLE WHO
WOULD. LIKE TO OPPOSE ANYONE ON
THE TELECONFERENCING THAT WOULD
LIKE TO OPPOSE. SENAD MISTER
MODERATOR COULD YOU DO THE DIAL
IN LINE. AND LATEST GERMAN ON
THE PHONE LINE IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WHEN CAN IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. WELL HERE YOU
GO TO USE. YEP THE STOCK PRICE
SHOW THE RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
LOCATION- WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE PUBLICATION OF
UNSUBSTANTIATED COMPLAINTS AS
WELL AS MR OBERNOLTE POINTED
OUT- WE DON'T KEEP IT
UNSUBSTANTIATED I'LL GET. OKAY.
THANK YOU ANY NAME IN ORDER TO.
THAT. THE NEXT WITH THE NUMBER
TWO EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GRANT%
PERRY WITH THEIR RECONSTRUCTED
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF TRAUMA AND PORAC.
ACTUALLY OPPOSED THE MEASURE
HOPE TO KEEP WORKING WITH YA
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT TO
BE NUMBER TWO NINETY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR MEMBERS
JONATHAN FELDMAN OF THE
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION ALSO OPPOSED THANK
YOU THANK YOU. EXHIBIT NUMBER
FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MY
NAME IS DAVID MISTAKE ME I'M-
LABOR ATTORNEY REPRESENTS
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES AND THEIR
UNIONS. AND I WAS HOPING TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF SACRAMENTO
COUNTY. DEPUTY SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION FOR A FEW MOMENTS.
IT IS TIME PERMITS DOESN'T THIS
ORGANIZATION WE HAD INDIVIDUALS
THAT WERE SUPPOSED TO SPEAK AND.
AND THAT WAS UNFORTUNATE
HAPPENS ARE ONLY TIME SORRY. SO
YOU NAME AN ORGANIZATION NOW.
HE ALSO LAW FIRM ON BEHALF OF
THE SACRAMENTO COUNTY DEPUTY
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION OPPOSED IN
THE BILL AS WRITTEN BUT HOPING
TO WORK WITH THE CHAIR AND THE
AUTHOR. THE REMINDED THANK YOU.
NEXT WILL BE NUMBER FIFTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
MATTHEW EASLEY REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL PEACE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. NEXT TO
BE NUMBER THREE HUNDRED PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI DEAR LUCIEN- HERE
ON THE AFTER THE LOS ANGELES
POLICE PROTECTIVE LEAGUE IN THE
SAN FRANCISCO POLICE OFFICERS A
SO CREATION IN STRONG
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT WILL BE NUMBER TWO NINETY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CAREY MEMBERS MATTHEW CYBERLINK
ON BEHALF THE ASSOCIATION FOR
LOS ANGELES DEPUTY SHERIFFS IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT WILL BE NUMBER TWO EIGHTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. MEMBERS
WE SHOP MUCH WE'RE HERE ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION I THOUGHT THE
CALIFORNIA LAW ENFORCEMENT
EXHORTATION OF RECORDS TO
PROVIDE YOUR I RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION TO AT. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT TO BE NUMBER TWO EIGHTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. SECURE
MEMBER SAYING LEVINE ABOUT THE
SAN BERNADINO SHERIFF'S
EMPLOYEES BENEFIT ASSOCIATION
ORANGE COUTY DEPUTY SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION LONG BEACH POLICE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION KERNEL OR
POLICE IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT TO BE NUMBER
ONE TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ON TWENTY SIX JULY AND OPEN
PLEASE MAKE SURE NOT YOU. I CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU. I THINK YOU TURN MEMBERS I
APOLOGIZE I WOULD THINK YOU FOR
SUPPORT BUT I WOULD HAVE
PROVIDED NUMBER- MY NAME IS
JENNIFER TO DAY ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF ALAMEDA IN SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL AGAIN APOLOGIZED
FOR BEING OUT OF ORDER. THANK
YOU THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO FURTHER IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE CONTINUE MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU BRING YOU BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MISTER CARE
I DID NOT OPEN WITH THAT I AM
TAKING THE AMENDMENT THAT
CLARIFIES THAT THE COMPLAINTS
MUST BE WELL FOUNDED THE THANK
YOU ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT WAS
RAISED IN THE CALLS WAS THAT IT
PREVIOUSLY JUST- SAID THEY
WOULD NOT BE FRIVOLOUS BUT-
WITH YOUR COMMITTEES ASSISTANCE
WE OF CLARIFYING NOW THAT THE
COMPLAINTS MUST BE WELL
FOUNDED.THANK YOU FOR THE
CLARIFICATION OCTOBER. THANK
YOU. OKAY. I JOIN YOU AND
WANTING TO. MAKE REASONABLE
TRANSPARENCY AVAILABLE TO THE
PUBLIC WITH AS IT RELATES TO
MISCONDUCT HOWEVER. I HAVE SOME
STRONG CONCERNS ON THE LANGUAGE
OF THIS BEEN SELECTED I REALLY
TRULY WISH THAT THE TERM
SUSTAINED. WOULD HAVE BEEN.
YOUR UP AND THAT SOUNDS LIKE
WHAT WAS THE TERM YOU JUST USED.
WELL FUNDED- IF I COULD DEFINE
TO THE CHAIR IF THAT'S THAT'D
BE HELPFUL YES SIR SO. THE
FIRST VERSION OF THE BILL OR
THE BILL WITHOUT THIS AMENDMENT
JUST LEFT AT THAT THE
COMPLAINTS COULD NOT BE
FRIVOLOUS BUT THE ADDITION OF
THAT THEY MUST BE WELL FOUNDED
IS THE SAME STANDARD DELETE
SAME LEGAL STANDARD THAT WE USE
CALIFORNIA USES FOR THE PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT AFFECTING OTHER
PUBLIC OFFICERS FOR EXAMPLE
TEACHERS SO IN OTHER WORDS THE
WELL FOUNDED IN THE DEFINITION
AND IT'S AN WITH THE AMENDMENT
WILL BE DEFINED IN THE BILL.
THE INVESTIGATION MUST CLEARLY
ESTABLISH THAT THE ALLEGATION
IS NOT TRUE SNOWBIRDS UNFOUNDED
MUST ESTABLISH THAT IT'S NOT
TRUE SO WELL FOUNDED. OBVIOUSLY
IS THE OPPOSITE. OKAY LET LET I
HAVE A COUPLE OF CONCERNS I
NEED TO JUST KIND OF SHARE WITH
YOU- FIRST OF ALL THE TERM
COMPLAINT. IS ALSO A LITTLE
CLEAR DOES NOT LIMIT THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF THE RELEASE
ABILITY ARE LEAST THE
PROTECTION THAT YOU JUST
INDICATED TO CITIZENS
COMPLAINTS. OR WE TALKING ABOUT
INTERNAL INVESTIGATIONS LIKE
ADVERSE ACTIONS INVESTIGATIONS
WHICH ARE COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
SET OF CIRCUMSTANCES BECAUSE
ARE USUALLY DRIVEN THROUGH THE
AGENCY THAT SHELTERS ARE
INITIATED THROUGH THE AGENCIES.
AT AROUND- THE BILL WOULD ALLOW.
FOR COMPLAINTS BUT ALSO FOR
INTERNAL DOES NOTREQUIRE SO IN
OTHER WORDS IF THE AGENCY
ITSELF HAS FOUNDED THAT THE
OFFICER HAS ENGAGED IN THESE
INCREASE RECORD THEN THAT'S AN
AVAILABLE RECORD. BUT WHAT IF
THEY'RE FOUND. DIFFERENTLY AND
FOUND THERE IS NOT IF IT IS
FOUND UNFOUNDED THEN THE RECORD
WOULD NOT BE AVAILABLE BECAUSE
THAT THAT SEEMS TO BE REALLY
AMBIGUOUS AND CAUSE RIGHT. AND
THIS PARTICULAR BELT AT THAT
TALKS ABOUT. THE RECORD OF THE
CIVILIAN COMPLAINT AND YOU'RE
STRUCK THE WORD CIVILIAN. AND
JUST INDICATED COMPLAINT BUT I
JUST THINK IT'S REALLY.
CONCERNING THE WAY THAT IT'S
CURRENTLY WRITTEN AND- I WOULD
HOPE THAT MAYBE WE CAN CLARIFY
THAT TO MAKE SURE THAT- C. H.
HERE'S WHERE LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND MYSELF SHARE OF DEEP DEEP
CONCERNS I MEAN. WE HAD SENATE
BILL FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE WHICH-
I FELT WAS NEGOTIATED AND- IT
WAS AN ISSUE THAT. WAS TRYING
TO IT CAME WITH SOME RESISTANCE
NO QUESTION BUT I THINK THAT
THE MOTIVATION WAS WAS IN THE
RIGHT AREA AND I THINK THAT WE
ARE MOVING IN A WAY THAT. THE
PUBLIC WAS BENEFITTED AND NOW
WE'VE GONE TO AN AREA THAT'S
CREATED SO MUCH UNCERTAINTY.
AND HERE'S WHERE THE ROBINS
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT AND I KNOW
I KNOW IT'S PERCEIVED
DIFFERENTLY BUT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE BECAUSE THERE ARE. LISTEN
I WAS THE FIRST LINE SUPERVISOR
FOR EIGHTEEN OF MY TWENTY EIGHT
YEARS. AND I'VE INVESTIGATED
MANY MANY MANY CITIZENS
COMPLAINTS. SOME WERE WELL WELL
WELL FUNDED AND- WE'RE THANKFUL
THAT THEY WERE BROUGHT FORWARD.
BECAUSE THEY- THEY WERE PART OF
THE HEALING PROCESS AND THEN
WERE PAR ALSO PART OF MAKING
SUPERVISION AND THE DEPARTMENT
AWARE OF MISCONDUCT. AND THAT
ISN'T THE ONLY WAY WE'RE GOING
TO BUILD BACK TRUST WITH OUR
WITH OUR PUBLIC. HOWEVER THERE
ALSO ARE SOME. HIGHLY MOTIVATED
INDIVIDUALS WHO JUST WANT TO
DISCREDIT. PEOPLE IN UNIFORM.
AND I KNOW THAT SOME MAY FIND
THAT TROUBLING SOME MAY NOT
EVEN CARE BUT I WILL TELL YOU
THAT. THE INTEGRITY THAT'S
ATTACKED UNFAIRLY ALSO NEEDS TO
BE GUARDED. AND I'M I'M JUST
TELLING YOU THAT- THERE'S TOO
MANY AMBIGUITIES IN THIS
PARTICULAR BILL THAT MAKES ME
FEEL COMFORTABLE THAT THOSE ARE
NOT GUARDED. AND IF WE CAN GET
TO A POINT TO WHERE WE COULD
KNOW THAT THOSE FALSE
ACCUSATIONS BECAUSE- ESPECIALLY
NOW. WHEN THE SENTIMENT TAZ
BECOME WHITE ANTI POLICE THAT'S
PROBABLY THE MORE LIKELY THAT
THERE'S GOING TO BE SOME OF
THOSE ALLEGATIONS BROUGHT
FORWARD AND- PEOPLE WHO ARE IN
LAW ENFORCEMENT WHO ARE JUST
TRYING TO SERVE THE PUBLIC AND
ARE DOING THEIR LEVEL BEST BUT
YET. THEY HAVE. THE FIERCELY
MOTIVATED PEOPLE. TO BRING
THESE ALLEGATIONS FORWARD THERE
NEEDS TO BE SAFEGUARDS TO
PROTECT THOSE OFFICERS. AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL GOES IN
THE WRONG DIRECTION. AND I KNOW
THAT'S NOT YOUR INTENTION. BUT
WE HAVE TO FEEL AT LEAST DIED I
CAN'T SPEAK FOR THEM BUT I KNOW
I NEED TO FEEL MORE COMFORTABLE
BUT THOSE ARE PRETTY. BECAUSE
WE'RE WE'RE NOT AFFORDED THAT.
THAT COMPANY COOPER RIGHT NOW
SO- YEAH I WON'T BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY. BUT
HOPEFULLY WE CAN AMENDED TO A
POINT TO WHERE. WE CAN FEEL
LIKE THOSE. UNFAIR ALLEGATIONS
CAN BE PROTECTED. YEAH ANY
OTHER COMMENTS. OKAY YOU MAY
CLOSE CENTER THANK YOU CHAIR IN
ADDRESSING- THE ISSUE THAT
ALLOWED MUCH OF THE OPPOSITION
RAISED AND ALSO- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. I SHARE THAT CONCERN
BECAUSE IT IT IS ABSOLUTELY THE
CASE NOT ONLY I MEAN OBVIOUSLY-
ARE LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
CAN BE TO TARGET CERTAIN PEOPLE
BUT IF WE THINK ABOUT. ANYONE
IN PUBLIC SERVICE THERE CAN BE-
INDIVIDUALS ARE RESIDENTS WHO
HAVE A BONE TO PICK AND CAN.
MAKE A CONTINUOUS. UNFOUNDED
FRIVOLOUS WHAT HAVE YOU
COMPLAINTS AND CERTAINLY I
SHARE YOUR CONCERN AND THE
CONCERN THAT WAS A REFERENCE BY
THE OPPOSITION THAT I DO NOT
WANT FRIVOLOUS OR I DO NOT WANT
TO RELEASE RECORDS RELATED TO
THAT WHAT I WANT IS FOR ONLY
RECORDS FOR THAT ARE ACTUAL.
THAT GIVE US THE INFORMATION
ABOUT WHETHER AN OFFICER HAS
BEEN FOUND IN AN INVESTIGATION
HAS BEEN FOUNDED TO HAVE AN
OFFICER ENGAGE IN THE BEHAVIORS
THAT COVERED BY THIS BILL SO
AND I DON'T HAVE TO REPEAT THEM.
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
STAFF OF THE COMMITTEE HELPING
US BECAUSE WHEN WE WERE
STRUGGLED WE WERE. WE FOUND IS
THAT SUBSTANTIATED HAD A
CERTAIN. LEVEL THAT WAS ALMOST
SO HIGH THAT IT DIDN'T UNCOVER.
THE SOME OF THESE ACT- SOME OF
THIS LEGITIMATE INFORMATION AND
SO WE WERE TRYING TO GET AT
STILL A PROTECTION OBVIOUSLY
FOR OUR PUBLIC EMPLOYEES ARE
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS AND
YET STILL RESPECT THE RIGHT. OF
RESIDENTS TO HAVE INFORMATION
AND THAT'S WHERE THE COMMITTEE
STAFF REALLY HELPED US WITH
USING THAT IT MUST BE WELL
FOUNDED. NO CERTAINLY AS THE
BILL MOVES THIS IS A
CONVERSATION I'M WILLING TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE BECAUSE- I WAS
VERY HEARTENED BY FOR EXAMPLE
FOR A STATEMENT OF PRINCIPLE
I'VE BEEN VERY HEARTENED BY-
THE KIND OF THE INTROSPECTION
THAT ALL OF US I THINK ARE
GOING THROUGH- IN RECENT
MONTHS. ABOUT PEOPLE WHAT WHAT
HOW HOW POLICING AND PUBLIC
SAFETY IN OUR COMMUNITIES NEEDS
TO BE CHANGED. AND SO I WANT TO
STRIKE THAT- THAT GOOD BALANCE
AND SO I COMMIT TO WORKING ON
IT- IT MAY BE THAT. THAT WILL
HELP I HOPE THAT WE CAN COME UP
WITH THE PLACE WHERE PEOPLE ARE
COMFORTABLE. WE'LL SEE WE'LL
SEE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY
OTHER. YOU YOU YOU MAY CLOSE A
DESERT SHE CLOSED I ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU AND I WILL
MAKE THE AND I'VE ABSOLUTELY
MAKE THAT COMMITMENT OKAY THEN
I AM I'M HEARTENED TO HEAR THAT
BECAUSE EVEN. EVEN A AMENDMENTS
THAT WE WERE MOVING TOWARD THAT
YOU'RE YOU'RE TAKING WAS
ADDRESSING EXACTLY WHAT YES
WHAT NOT ONLY LAW ENFORCEMENT
BUT MR BY CULTURE MAY HERE WAS
TALKING ABOUT AND INDIVIDUALLY-
AS A PUBLIC SECTOR UNION
EMPLOYEE. I BEEN A MESSAGE
WHERE THE RESPONSIVE STATED.
ALLEGATIONS THAT PROVED TO BE
ABSOLUTELY FALSE AND I ALWAYS
TELL EXAMPLE OF- EMPLOYED IT
WASN'T WORKING BUT IN DOING
THEIR WORK VERY WELL EXCUSE ME
OF BEING RACIST TOWARDS BLACK
PEOPLE. OF BUT I HAD TO GO TO
AN INVESTIGATION. OBVIOUSLY WAS
UNFOUNDED AND BUT DURING THAT
TIME OF THE INVESTIGATION YOU
HAVE THAT CLOUD OVER YOUR HEAD
AND I'M PRETTY SURE THERE WERE
PROBABLY SOME PROMOTIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES THAT MISSED OUT
BECAUSE I WAS UNDER
INVESTIGATION AND SO I ALSO
UNDERSTAND HOW. YOU COULD BE
TARNISHED. JUST BY AN
ALLEGATION OF FRIVOLOUS
ALLEGATION- THAT COULD BE VERY
DIFFICULT TO DEAL WITH AND SO
IN SOME WAYS PERSONALLY I WANT
TO MAKE SURE WE GET THIS RIGHT.
SO THAT AS WE MOVE FORWARD- I'M
WILLING TO HELP IT SOUNDS LIKE
MR LACKEY AND I ARE BOTH
WILLING TO TRY TO COME UP WITH
BUT DO. AS CLOSE TO THE WORDING
WE NEED YES LIKE I SAID-
EVERYBODY USED TO HAVE A
THESAURUS WILL NOW YOU NOW
THERE'S AN APP WITH THE
THESAURUS OR WEAKENED WE WORSE
MISSED THIS TO A PLACE THAT WE
CAN ALL BE COMFORTABLE AT. AND
SO A BIT AS IT MOVES FORWARD
WHICH I HOPE MOVES FORWARD-
FIVE I WOULD LIKE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THAT DISCUSSION
AND IT SOUNDS LIKE BY THE STATE
VICE CHAIR. OF PUBLIC SAFETY
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO GIVE INPUT
AND THAT'S WHERE I THINK WE GET
TO A BETTER PLACE IF. SITES ARE
TALKING AND LOOKING AT IT FROM
THERE VIEW AND GETTING TO WHERE
YOU YOU REALLY WANT IS. TO MAKE
SURE WE CARRIED OUT. I MANY.
BAD AND- AS POSSIBLE. SO JURORS
RECOMMEND I BECAUSE I THINK WE
CAN GET THERE SO THANK YOU.
CALL FOR VOTE. THE BILL'S
EMERGENCY ON S. B. C. SEVEN SO
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER HI JONES
I LACKEY LACKEY NOW BARRICADE
CAN PARA QUE HANNAH HI DEEP.
KAMLAGER KAMLAGER I WORK. QUIRK
I SANTIAGO. STONE STONE AYE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES. CONSIDER
MY SECOND ROW YES- SB TEN SIXTY
FOUR SO. THANK YOU- I THINK IF
I CAN JUST- HAVE MY WITNESS AND
THEN ANSWER QUESTIONS. YOUR
WHICH WITNESSES YES OKAY SO UPS
MODERATOR PAUL READ THE
AMERICAN FRIENDS SERVICES AND
KEITH WORTLEY AND COMMON. LAW
ON. STOP BOTH PAULAND KEITH
ARE ON THE LINE YOUR LINES ARE
OPEN.HERE'S SOME FOR REAL. YOU
MAY BEGIN MR READ. MY NAME IS
PAUL RARE THAT WOULD PUT
AMERICAN FRIENDS SERVICE
COMMITTEE A PROUD PART OF THE
BROWN'S FLOWSERVE IS B. KIDS
TEACHERS WILL PUBLIC RELATIONS
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
CORRECTION AT THE FORTY FOUR
YEAR OLD MAY TWENTY FIRST THIS
YEAR BOTH MEN OVER THIRTY FIVE
YEARS OF SOLITARY CONFINEMENT.
MY THIRTY FIVE PLUS YEARS SPENT
IN BEARS THIRTY HOUSING WILL
BASED ON THE RODIUS
CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION IN ONE
CASE THE EMPLOYMENT DID NOT
EXIST ANOTHER TH THE STAFF
MEMBER DOCUMENTED DOCUMENTED
NOR BEST IT INFORMATION AND
THEN ANOTHER THEY NEVER
PROVIDED ME WITH ANY TEN THIRTY
COMPANY TO DISCLOSURE FORMS
RIDES IN THE INCIDENT. IT
WASN'T UNTIL NINETEEN EIGHTY
NINE THE APPEALS CORONATED BY
THE NAME OF MIRACLE WOULD
DISCOVERED THE VIOLATION IT
ONLY HAD THE ABILITY TO GO BACK
TO NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT SO
WHATEVER WAS IN THE FILE FROM
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN TO
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE WITH
MEMBER WE DO. L. LOST ALL THOSE
YEARS IN TWO THOUSAND AND FIVE
W. GENERAL ORDERED
INVESTIGATION OF BRIBERY WILL
GAIN VALIDATION MATERIAL THAT I
HAD NOT HAD ACCESS TO IT WAS
COMPANY TO DOCUMENT THAT IS
BEING USED TO SEVERAL YEARS
DEVELOP THEY KEEP ME IN THE
SALAD AND THEN IN THE SECURITY
HOUSING UNIT. DEFAMATION ACCUSE
ME OF KILLING A MAINE INSTEAD
QUIT ALTHOUGH I WAS NEVER
CHARGED WITH THAT OFFENSE SIX
YEARS LATER A NEW INVESTIGATION
FOUND THE INFORMATION DID NOT
IDENTIFY BE APPEALING ANYMORE.
IT WAS REMOVED FROM PINE
VALIDATION GREG ABBOTT THE
DEMIGOD SEVERAL NEWS INFORMAL
WITH THE I CAN GIVE MANY
EXAMPLES FROM US WELL WE'RE
RONI IS UNRELIABLE ENDORSEMENT
COVERAGE WAS YOU WITH THE HELP
OF THE STAFF DIRECTLY AND
INDIRECTLY. ALLOWED IT TO
HAPPEN WOULD KNOW CONTABILIDADE
THAT THAT WAS RELEASED TO THE
GENERAL POPULATION. THE USE OF
EFFORT. GRODZISK THROUGH THE
ABUSE OF COMPANY TO HAVE. THIS
IS PROGRESS TAX. FROM HAVING A
BREAK TO A. PEOPLE BASED ONLY
ON OF OUR THE COLLABORATE
GALLAGHER. IT IS LOW OVERDUE
AND I WILL BE AT DANCE ANY
UESTION. THANK YOU. NEXT WELL.
BIRDS THAT GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD
AFTERNOON KEITH WHAT LEAD ON
COMMON LAW HERE AND STRONG OF
SB CONFIG FOUR I MET MISTER
RICH THE OTHER DURING ONE MY
FIRST VISIT THE PELICAN STATE
PRISON TWELVE TWO YEARS AGO.
THAT I HAD COURSE WITH AND
LITIGATING ALL BEHALF OF MANY
OF THE TOP OF PEOPLE IN BLOCKED
UP AT THE PRISON AND SOLITARY
UNITS THROUGHOUT THE STATE THAT
OFTEN TELL. THERE WAS NO RULE
OF WORLD THEIR HEARING THEY
WERE TO SOUTH TO COMPLY. FOR
MANY OF THEM EVEN YEAR AFTER
FROM SAW AND- CONTROL BOARD
DENIED RELEASE PRISON BASEBALL
OLD UNDERLIE COAL INFORMATION.
OUR SYSTEM OF THE CAN ALLOW
THIS TO CONTINUE BECAUSE OF
FUND COOKING OF BECAUSE-
NOTHING IN THIS THE DISCLOSURE
OF THE I'D OF COMPETENT. NOR
DOES IT INTERFERE WITH THE MANY
PUT THAT IT IN THE NORMAL DOES
PROCESS IN PRISON WE SIMPLY
KEEP IN PRISON A YEAR OR-
BASEBALL INFORMATION THEY HAVE
NO ME OP. TO CHALLENGE I'M IN
MY COMMENTS WILL A NOTE FOR
FROM A QUIET OF MINE NAME IS.
OKAY I WAS THE DIRECTOR OF
PUBLIC SAFETY WHEN THERE WAS
NOTHING I COULD SAY OR DO ABOUT
IT I'M GRATEFUL TO BE HOME NOW
BUT I CAN'T GET BACK TO FIFTEEN
YEARS I LOST WITH MY FAMILY.
THE CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON
BEHALF OF LESLIE AND PAUL READ
ABOUT OF OTHERS LIKE THEM I
HEARD YOUR I'VE BUILT ON SB TWO
SIX PEOPLE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ORDER ANY OTHER WITNESSES
SUPPORT IN THE ROOM. IN A ROW
ANY WITNESSES SUPPORT A NEW
VIDEO CONFERENCE. AND MISTER
MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY DIALING
IN SUPPORT. QUICK JUMP ON THE
PHONE LINES AND SO PLEASE PRESS
ONE. AGAIN IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. THERE
WILL WITH NUMBER THREE OH NINE
THREE OH NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS THERE ARE NO IT
DOES NOT WITHOUT WE DEVELOP IN
STRONG SUPPORT THE BILL THANK
YOU. NEXT WILL BE NUMBER TWO OH
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. SENATOR
FIRST MAJESTIC CALIFORNIA
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT WE
NUMBER NUMBER TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT'S BEEN A
VERY HARD WITH TELECOM VALLEY
YOU BET AND WEBER STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL ALSO ADDS
THAT- IMPACTED WHITE IS WHILE
ON THE STRONG SUPPORTER THE
BILL YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT WILL
NUMBER THREE NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS PAMELA ON
BEHALF A FRIEND COMMITTEE WHAT
THAT. IN STRONG OF THAT CAN
SIXTY THANK YOU. X. NUMBER
FIVE. THIRTY FIVE. MY GOD OFF
ON BEHALF OF THE OF. STRONG
THANK YOU. NEXT WE NUMBERS TWO
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MARKERT
GEORGE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG SUPPORT.
NEXT WILL BE NUMBER THREE
TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS ALEX THE TRAVIS
WOULD SUCK ON VALLEY VIEW BUT
IN. THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
TO BE NUMBER THREE TWENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
THERESA MANGO IT'S OUR COMBAT
ET BACK IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT THE NUMBER THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CANACCORD ARE
NOW ON BEHALF OF BATTLE THE
GAME'S A COUPLE ABOUT DOT IN
STRONG TO ENSURE NOT. LIKE WHAT
ARE MR READ AND HAPPEN AGAIN.
THANK YOU. THANKS WILL BE NO
THREE TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AB CHATTED WITH INITIATE THAT
IN STRONG SUPPORT. NOW GO TO
NUMBER. ONE OH THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YES MY NAME IS MARY
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL TEN FIFTY FOUR MY HUSBAND
WAS JUST THE NIGHT LAST WEEK
PEARL FOR YEAR. AND THE ONLY
REASON HE WAS GIVEN WHAT
BECAUSE HE HAD TO TEN THIRTY
WHICH IS A COP. BONTA ON HIS
FILE AND THEY WERE VERY RECENT
AND NOW- HE HAVE TO SAY IN
THERE FOR ANOTHER FIVE YEARS
COCKING THE TOP OF OVER A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS- FOR THE FIVE YEARS
THAT HE WAS DENIED. SO I HOPE
THAT YOU CAN REALLY CONSIDER
WHY THIS BILL IS VERY IMPORTANT
AND I THINK. YOU ARE VERY MUCH
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY. YOU. THE
NUMBER THREE OH ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO COMMITTEE MEMBERS
OF THE CAN YOU GIVE ME A TOUGH
YOU WERE DRUNK. FOR THANK YOU.
NEXT WILL BE NUMBER THREE
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NUMBER THREE TWENTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU. OKAY I DID ALL THE
VIOLENCE OF THE COMBAT WOULD BE
BURKE AND I MEAN OVER STRONG OF
THIS BILL. NEXT WILL BE NUMBER
EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS ALEX I'M BOTH WAYS
SO IF SOMEBODY WANTS AND I AM
SO ONE OF SOUTH THANK YOU. NOW
YOUR- ONE FORTY TWO. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WELL CATS CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES AGAIN SO THAT AND-
PRISONER I'M STRIKE SATURDAY.
CALL SOCIAL WORKERS IN SAID
OKAY CAN. TEMPLE BETH AB.
JEWISH COMMUNITY CENTER. AND
THEN THE TELEGENIC CAL. STRONG
SUPPORT. NEXT WE'LL KNOW THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DIANA CRUZ
MEMBER OF AN CAR THREE LOVED
AND I AM AND SUPPORT OF SB SIX
FOUR. SIX WILL BE NUMBER OH
THREE IS AHEAD. HELLO WORKED
SHOULD CHECK JEFF AND SO. THANK
WE ARE IN A THREE THIRTY.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HIS RISE
OUTSIDE OF SILICON PEOPLE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. X. WE GO TO
NUMBER ONE EIGHTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. DANIEL GOOD
TERRACE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN SUPPORT. WE
NOW GO TO NUMBER THREE OH FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
A FELLOW BURIAL- AND I'M AN
IMPACTED WIFE IN STRONG SUPPORT
SB. TEN SIXTY FOUR. NOW GO TO
NUMBER THREE THREE TWO THREE
THIRTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IF
THE JUMP NEVER READY I AM AN
IMPACTED WHY AND I AM OUT WITH
INITIATE JEFF. AND I STRONGLY
THAT. THANK WELL ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
NO FURTHER IN SUPPORT- PLEASE
CONTINUE MISTER CHAIR. THANK
YOU. ORDER ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. I HAD A- AMADOR
COUNTY DA TODD RAY B. BRIBIE.
A. IN LINE MOST MODERATOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I DO HAVE TODD
RIGHT BE ON THE LINE I'M NOT
SURE IF HE ISN'T SELF MUTED.
MISTER RIGHT BE COULD YOU
PLEASE AND MUTE. THERE YOU GO.
OKAY GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
BUT MY IS TOM READING ON THE
JUST ATTORNEY'S AMBER CAL AND
I'M HERE TO HELP THE K.
DISTRICT ASSOCIATION
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE S. B. SIXTY
FOUR PART MY LIFE I WAS SHE
PROBABLY DEFENDER AMBER CAL AND
A DEPUTY FOR DEFENDER COUNTY
SINCE NINETEEN ONE I'LL BE THE
DEPENDING NATURE. THEM I'M A
PAST OF THEA CULTURE OF THE
CITY LIKE TO YOU COMMITTEE A
NUMBER OF THE PERSON CRIMES AND
UPON MEMBER OF PERSON COME I
ALSO HAVE A NEAR CREEK WITH MY
DEAREST. SB PENTZ FOUR BIT
DEPRIVE YOU SEE OUR USING THE
LAB WEAPONS THAT MAKE MARKET TO
HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE DISPONER
HEARINGS WITH. CONFLICT FUSIONS
PROHIBITED HERE FROM COMES VOTE
CORP THE FORMER IN DETERMINING
THE MAKES REAL WOULD BE
VIOLENCE AND JEOPARDIZES.
YOU'RE NOT SORRY TO SAFEGUARD
THE RIGHTS AND PROCTOR'S AS
1060 DEGREES INCREASE THE
NUMBER MAKES ONE TO JUST
PROCEEDING TO GO AHEAD SO THEY
CAN UP ALL THE REGARDING
INFORMANTS SUCH AS ABLE TO OUT
WHO THEY ARE A DETAILED LIST OF
THE- PROVIDE. DOESN'T WAS ABLE
TO UPON PERSON UP MISSING
CRIMES FOCUSED NINE YEAR THAT'S
AS GOOD AS A STEP ONE AND
BECAUSE BOTTOM LINE THE BOMB
WHICH WOULD HAVE TAKE JUST BODY
FROM THERE SHOULD ARE AND
PROSECUTORS WOULD DELIVER TO BY
THE END OF AND THOSE ACTING ON
CAN MAKES BEHALF. AND FOUR THE
JUDGE LAW TERM UNDER ABOUT INTO
DAY ACT PLACING SHE USED ARE
AND B. P. H. YOU CRIMES
OCCURRING AT THE OAK CREEK
STATE PERSON WITH YOU GIVES AGO
WE HAD A CASE WHERE MEMBERS OF
THE GANG DECIDE TO CORRECT
ATTACK A CORRECTIONAL OFFICER
THEY MANUFACTURED STABBING
INSTRUMENTS WHICH WERE TO BE
USED BY THE ASSAILANTS AND
APPOINTMENT STEP FORWARD AND
PROVIDED INFORMATION ABOUT THE
PLAN TO TAP. AS A RESULT OF
THIS INFORMATION THE WEAPONS
WERE FOUND EMPLOYMENT
INFORMATION. LIKELY SAVE A LIFE.
THANK YOU. WHAT AM CLOSER TO BE.
AND NON BY HELLO. BUT SIX
COLLEGES WILL BE DEPRIVE
DEVELOPING INFORMATION CRITICAL
DETERMINANT AND MAKES RESPOND
FUTURE VIOLENCE. THIS IN TURN
WOULD DEPRIVE PTH FROM COMPLETE
AND ACTIVISTS ASSESSMENTS WHEN
MAKING CALLS TO THE BILL YOU
DECISIONS CONDITIONS WOULD ALSO
BE PREVENTED FROM USING LOCAL
CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION.
HERE'S A DISCIPLINARY
PROCEEDINGS WHAT THE INMATE WAS
FOUND NOT GUILTY NOT BECAUSE
THEY WANT TO COME BACK NOT
GUILTY. BECAUSE THEY WERE
SUCCESSFUL IN INTIMIDATING
INFORMANTS REPUBLICAN EVIDENCE
AGAINST HIM FROM COOPERATING
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT. THIS BILL
WOULD ALSO PROHIBIT THE USE OF
VALUABLE INFORMATION FOUND IN
MINOR RULES VIOLATIONS. I
BELIEVE THAT THE OFFICE OF THE
START BUTTON TENSIONS HOWEVER
IS PRESENTLY BUTTON THIS BILL
CORRECTION ON SEPTEMBER SAFETY
VEST AND MAKES SYSTEMS AND
CORRECTIONAL STAFF. YOU DA
WOULD BE DELIGHTED TO DISCUSS
POSSIBLE MA'AM THANK. YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. NOW DO
ANY WOULDN'T. IN OPS AND
CHAMBER. HEARING ROOM ANY
WITNESSES. IN OPPOSITION R. D.
VIDEO CONFERENCING. MISTER
MISTER MEDIATOR COULD YOU NOW
OPEN UP THE LINES DOWN IN LINES
FOR ANY ONE IN OPPOSITION. AND
THOSE ON THE PHONE LINES IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION HE'S PRESS
ONE ZERO. THE AN ONE ZERO HERE
IN OPPOSITION. WILL FIRST GO TO
NUMBERS THREE THREE EIGHT THREE
THREE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
HI MY NAME IS APRIL AND I'M
ACTUALLY IN FAVOR OF THIS BILL
I JUST DIDN'T GET. THE PART OFF
THE CUT OFF POINT SO I'M ABLE
GREAT THEM FROM THE ELEMENTS
EVEN BETTER AND I SOME OF THE
PORT THE BILL. THANK YOU ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE NOT IN OPPOSITION
YOU MAY CONTINUE MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU BRING BACK TO
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS FOR.
SENATOR SKINNER. SIX IT IT IT
KAMLAGER YES MISS KAMLAGER
MISTER CHAIR SENATOR I JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD AND I WILL BE
SUPPORTING IT I THESE
CONFIDENTIAL INFORMANTS OR
SNITCHES ARE ACTUALLY
INCARCERATED AND USED FOR A
REASON I THINK IN PART TO KIND
OF MANAGE AND CONTROL AND VERY.
WHERE AUTHORITY IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS NOT WELCOME OR
NOT TRUSTED WITH THESE
INFORMANTS. YOU KNOW PEOPLE
GENERALLY KNOW WHO THEY ARE-
AND WIELD GREAT POWER. AND
ACTUALLY- HAVE A LOT OF
PROTECTION BECAUSE. OF THE ROLE
THAT THEY PLAY IN AND SO I
ACTUALLY THINK THAT THE
PRACTICE IS INCREDIBLY
TROUBLING THAT YOU COULD HAVE
UNCORROBORATED. ALLEGATIONS
USED TO EITHER. A LENGTH AND
SOMEONE'S CARCERAL TIME OR DENY
THEM PRIVILEGES AND CERTAIN
RIGHT SO I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD IN THE
I WANT TO RESPOND I GUESS TO
SOME OF THE- COMMENTS BY THE
OPPOSITION WHEN THOSE KINDS OF-
DISASTROUS AND UNFORTUNATE
EVENTS HAPPEN. WHERE A
CORRECTIONAL OFFICER OR SOMEONE
OF AUTHORITY IS ATTACKED OR
HURT OR SALTED IT'S NOT JUST IT
I MEAN EVERYONE KNOWS WHAT
HAPPENS AND SO I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT THOSE KINDS OF
INCIDENTS ARE RESOLVED. AND YOU
KNOW- CONSEQUENCES ARE SORT OF
RESULTED BUT IT'S NOT JUST
BECAUSE OF INFORMANTS YOU KNOW
IT'S BECAUSE OF THE CULTURE
THAT'S IN THAT ENVIRONMENT-
THAT DOES STEP UP TO KIND OF
YOU KNOW. SHED LIGHT ON THOSE
KINDS OF INCIDENTS SO I WANT TO
JUST SORT. ENTER THAT I WANT TO
THANK YOU THIS AND I WILL BE
VOTING HI. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
OR QUESTIONS. YOU MAY CLOSE
CENTER THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THERE WERE A NUMBER OF ISSUES
THAT THE DA'S RACE THAT I THINK
WERE. SLIGHTLY SLIGHTLY OVER
SULLINGER OVER DESCRIBING I
MEAN NUMBER ONE. THE BILL DOES
NOT REQUIRE THAT THE IN CUSTODY
INFORMANT'S IDENTITY HE
REVEALED IN NO WAY DOES NOT DO
THAT. WHAT IT REQUIRES IS THAT
TO USE AN IN CUSTODY INFORMANTS.
ACCUSATION IT MUST BE
CORROBORATED AND INTERESTINGLY
IF WE USE THE IF THE SITUATION
OF FOR EXAMPLE WHERE A-
INCARCERATED VIGIL MAY ATTACK A
CORRECTIONS OFFICIAL OR OR
COMMIT ANOTHER CRIME. WHILE
THEY'RE INCARCERATED THE ONLY
WAY ANY EVIDENCE THAT CAN BE
USED AGAINST THEM IN A COURT
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO DO PROCESS
IN COURT WHERE YOU'RE ONLY
ALLOWED TO HAVE. CORROBOREE
TESTIMONY. INTRODUCED IN
CRIMINAL COURT. THIS ACTUALLY
ASSIST THAT WE PROHIBIT THE USE
OF UNCORROBORATED TESTIMONY
DURING CRIMINAL TRIALS AND WE
BARK CONVICTIONS BASED ON
UNCORROBORATED INFO FROM IN
CUSTODY INFORMANTS THAT'S A
LOT. SO IN EFFECT BY ADDING
SIMILAR DUE PROCESS PROVISIONS
FOR IN CUSTODY INFORMANTS
WITHIN OUR PRISONS. IT CAN
ASSIST THE PROSECUTION IF THERE
IS AN ACTUAL CRIME COMMITTED
NOW ON THE ON THE POINT OF.
WHETHER THIS DOES NOT ELIMINATE.
THE ABILITY FOR IN ANOTHER FOR
AN IN CUSTODY INDIVIDUAL. TO
WHO TO WAIT J. COMPLAINT OR
RAISE AN ISSUE OF INACTION BY
ANOTHER IN CUSTODY INDIVIDUAL
IT DOES NOT ELIMINATE THAT.
WHAT IT DOES IS REQUIRED BEFORE
IT IS PUT IN THE FILE THAT'D BE
CORROBORATED. SO THAT'S
PRIMARILY WHAT IT DOES AND IT'S
DUE PROCESS PRINCIPLES AND I
THINK THAT- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COME LONGER DRIVE REYES THE
MAJOR POINTS OF WHY THAT'S
IMPORTANT IN SUCH A SETTING.
BECAUSE THERE COULD BE
MOTIVATIONS OF INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE IN CUSTODY TO MAKE
ALLEGATIONS AND SO TOO WE NEED
HIM CORROBORATED FOR THEM TO BE
USED AND PUT FORWARD IN A
PAROLE HEARING AND THAT'S THE
PURPOSE OF THE BILL- AND WITH
THAT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE I
POINT OUT THAT THE BILL DID
PASSED WITH BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
BOTH IN THE PUBLIC SAFETY
SENATE COMMITTEE AND ON THE
FLOOR OF THE SENATE. THANKYOU
AND- BUT I JUST FIND IT
INTERESTING ON BOTH YOUR BILLS.
IT'S THE KIND OF THE CENTRAL
THEME IS COOPERATING EVIDENCE
WHETHER IT'S FOR. OR AGAINST-
PEOPLE ARE INCARCERATED. AND
THEN FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT IT'S
JUST IT'S KIND OF THE SAME
THEME SONG- OBVIOUSLY IT'S HOW
DO YOU GET THERE SO THAT
EVERYBODY. CAN HAVE JUST
ASSISTANCE OR SUPPORTING THIS
AND I THINK THE SAME HERE IF
YOU SIT DOWN AND WE JUST MAKE
THE GOAL OF HAVING JUSTICE AND
MAKING SURE SHE IS EQUAL ON
BOTH SIDES WHICH IS. WHERE I
THINK YOU'RE TRYING TO GET TO-
PARTICULARLY TO GET THERE.
THANK YOU. SB TEN SIXTY FOR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER HI GENSER. LACKEY LACKEY
NOT VOTING BARRICADE HAN
THERAPY HAVE A DEEP. DEEP I
KAMLAGER HI KAMLAGER HI QUIRK
WELL IT'S QUICK I SENT THE ECHO
STONE STONE ALLY THAT MEASURE
PASSES. MAJOR PASSES
CONGRATULATIONS. THANK YOU
YOU'RE WELCOME. MISTER WILK.
YOUR LAST SENATOR OF THE DAY.
EXCEPT FOR MR MR OTHER I MEAN
TO BE HERE IN PERSON. AT TO
REFINISH WHICH YOU WOULD HAVE
MISSED THE RISER SO OKAY WE'RE
GOING TO GET TO HER. BUILT HIS
LAST NAME STARTS WITH THE
REVIEWS TO BE IN LAST. RIGHT
WILL BE GOOD EVENING- MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO
BEGIN BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR TENSION AND ALL
THEIR WORK ON THIS PARTICULAR
MEASURE. I ALSO ACCEPTED
MEMBERS PROPOSED BY THE CHAIR
WHICH REMOVED THE FINE
INCREASES IN WASTE HAULER
LIABILITY. IT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING- THAT ACCEPTING
THESE AMENDMENTS REMOVES
OPPOSITION FROM THE ACLU PUBLIC
DEFENDERS AND ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE. SB FOUR OWN.
HELPS LAW ENFORCEMENT AND LOCAL
AGENCY STOP PROPERTY OWNERS
FROM TURNING OUR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES INTO UNLICENSED AND
UNREGULATED DUMPSITES. CURRENT
LAW ONLY ADDRESSES SITUATIONS
WHICH THE PROPERTY OWNERS DO
NOT GIVE PERMISSION TO
UNLAWFULLY DUMP WASTE MATTERS
ON THE PROPERTY THIS CREATES A
LOOPHOLE WHICH RESULTS IN MANY
PROPERTY OWNERS GIVING WASTE
HAULERS PERMISSION TO DUMP
INDUSTRIAL WASTE ON THEIR LAND
WITHOUT FIRST OBTAINING THE
REQUIRED PERMITS FROM STATE
COUNTY. AND LOCAL AGENCIES.
PROPERTY OWNERS PROFIT FROM
COLLECTING CASH WELL WASTE
HAULERS PROFIT BY CHARGING
BUSINESSES THE FULL COST FOR
THE TRANSPORTATION OF WASTE
INTENDED FOR A LICENSED
DUMPSITE. AND INSTEAD DO IT
DELIVERS THE WAYS TO PROPERTY
OWNERS LAND FOR FAR LOWER
AMOUNT OF MONEY THERE BY
POCKETING THE DIFFERENCE. SB
FOUR OH NINE CLOSES THIS
LOOPHOLE BY DRESSING THE
SITUATIONS WHICH A PROPERTY
OWNER GIVES CONSENT. IN A
RECENT CASE A PROSECUTOR BUT L.
A. COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY WHO
HELPED MY OFFICE STRAP THIS
BILL A PROPERTY OWNER ACCEPTED
TRUCKLOADS OF COMMERCIAL WASTE
ONTO HIS PROPERTY THERE WAS
LOCATED TOP OF A HILL. WELL
OVER A THOUSAND CUBIC YARD OF
COMMERCIAL WASTE WERE DUMPED
ONTO HIS PROPERTY OP DRIVEWAY
OVER THEIR OWNERS HILLSIDE.
SENSORS NO PERMIT TO RECEIVE
THE WASTE MOUNTAIN PILES OF
COMMERCIAL WASTE WERE NEVER
SECURED. THE NEIGHBOR AND HER
FAMILY WERE IN DANGER BY THIS
ON SECURED HILLSIDE A WASTE.
COULD TUMBLE DOWN BY THE
FAILURE OF THE FENDER TO OBTAIN
PROPER PERMITS. I ALSO RECENTLY
MET WITH I HEART LAKE LOS
ANGELES A COMMUNITY THAT CLEANS
UP A DUMPING. OCCURRING IN
THEIR COMMUNITY ALL ALL OF YOUR
MEMBER OFFICES RECEIVED A VIDEO
THAT WE DID ON THIS HILL. OKAY
THE SUBJECT WITHOUT I WOULD
LIKE TO WELCOME ERICA SCHWARTZ
FROM THE I HEART MAKE L. A. N.
L. COUNTY DEPUTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY KAREN TAYLOR TO
PROVIDE BRIEF TESTIMONY AND
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU. ARE YOU COULD
LET THE MEN. WELL THEY'RE BOTH
ON THE LINE AND THEIR LINES ARE
OPEN. PERFECT. THANK YOU AND
WHAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO GO FIRST
SURE. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN OR SHOULD I SAY GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS- MY NAME IS KAREN
TANDLER AND I AM A LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DEPUTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY
ASSIGNED TO CODE ENFORCEMENT IN
THE ENVIRONMENTAL CRIMES
DIVISION. THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
pOFFICE IS PLEASED TO SPONSOR SB
FOUR ZERO NINE. SENATE BILL
FOUR ZERO NINE AMENDS
PROVISIONS OF CALIFORNIA PENAL
CODE SECTION THREE SEVENTY FOUR
POINT THREE. THE CALIFORNIA
DUMPING STATUTE. BY
STRENGTHENING ENFORCEMENT
EFFORTS. TO MAKE UNLAWFUL SOLID
WASTE DUMPERS ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THEIR ACTIONS. FIRST SB FOUR
ZERO NINE CLOSES THE PROPERTY
OWNER'S CONSENT LOOPHOLE BY
ENSURING THAT THE PROPERTY
OWNER OR HIS OR HER AGENT
OBTAIN THE REQUIRED PERMITS
LICENSES OTHER APPROVALS FROM
THE STATE OR LOCAL AUTHORITY
BUT FOR RECEIVING SOLID WASTE
ONTO THE PROPERTY. THIS HELPS
KEEP OUR ENVIRONMENT CLEAN.
SECOND SB FOUR ZERO NINE
AUTHORIZES EXISTING
GOVERNMENTAL DEPARTMENTS AND
AGENCIES THAT ARE ARE ALREADY
RESPONSIBLE FOR OVERSIGHT AS
ILLEGAL LAND USE. TO MAKE A
FINDING THAT AN ILLEGAL DUMP
SITE LOCATION CONSTITUTES A
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY HAZARD
PUBLIC NUISANCE OR FIRE HAZARD.
THE EXISTING STATUTES TO
NARROWLY LIMIT THIS. TO ONLY
LOCAL HEALTH OR FIRE DEPARTMENT
OR THE DEPARTMENT OF FORESTRY
AND FIRE WHEN IN REALITY OTHER
GOVERNMENTAL DEPARTMENTS AND
AGENCIES ACTIVELY MONITOR
ILLEGAL LAND USE AND SHOULD
HAVE THIS AT THE ALREADY UNDER
PENAL CODE SECTION THREE
SEVENTY FOUR POINT THREE AS
WELL. THE PASSAGE OF THIS
LEGISLATION WILL IMPROVE THE
ENVIRONMENT AND SAFETY IN
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. PLEASE HELP STOP
POLLUTION OF OUR LAND WATER AND
AIR BY PASSING THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION AYE URGENT AYE VOTE
ON SENATE BILL FOUR ZERO NINE
AND I'M PLEASED TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. BY THE
THIRTY ONE MAR ERICA FROM I
HEART MAKE LA ERICA FROM I
HEART. HEY KELLY LA. GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ERIKA
SCHWARTZ AND I AM A COMMUNITY
ORGANIZER FOR SB YOU SEE THAT
PASSED FOR STRENGTH BASED
COMMUNITY CHANGE AND WE
ADVOCATE ALONGSIDE RESIDENTS
ACROSS LA COUNTY- ISSUES THAT
ARE IMPORTANT TO THE COMMUNITY
THROUGH THE FORM OF
NEIGHBORHOOD ACTION COUNCIL I'M
ALSO A MOTHER AND RESIDENT OF
THE ANTELOPE VALLEY AND
VOLUNTEER WITH THE NATIONAL
LABOR WHAT ACTION COUNCIL I
HARDLY KELLY A GROUP THAT LIKE
MANY OTHER AYE HARD GROUP TO
LIKE COUNTY FOCUS KEEPING OUR
COMMUNITIES AND CLEAN. SB THREE
FEET AND THE NEIGHBORHOOD
ACTION COUNCILS ARE PLEASED TO
SPONSOR. SENATE BILL FOUR ZERO
NINE OUR NEIGHBORHOOD I
COUNCILS AND WORLD AND A LOT
ABOUT AND OTHER NEIGHBOR
THROUGHOUT THE L. A. COUNTY
LIKE WILL AND WATCH OVER OR
BEEN MANY MORE HE ADVOCATE
CLEANER STATE AND GO WORKER
SPACES AND WALKING PATHS
CONVERGE THANK. WHICH TALKING
TO DO THAT OR LOAN IT IS A FOR
BEING PART TO GO AND CLEAN UP
THE WEIGHT FOR ME TO FEEL COME
BACK TO FOLLOW WEEK THE TYPE OF
WEIGHT THAT WE CLEAN UP RANGES
FROM TOXIC TIRES COMMERCIAL
WAIT HOUSEHOLD WASTE AND ALL
HORRIBLE THINGS IN BETWEEN OUR
GROUP COLLECTIVELY HAVE PICKED
UP OVER A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND TONS OF SOLID WASTE IN
JUST OVER TWO YEARS. UNFAIR FOR
US TO KEEP HAVING TO CLEAN UP
AFTER BAD ACTORS DO NOT HAVE
THE RESOURCES THAT OTHER MORE
AFFLUENT. COMMUNITIES HAVE.
WELL DONE AT BAY. THE TERM
PEOPLE FROM. INTO OUR TOWN TO
DIE THEIR WAY. BECAUSE THEY
KNOW THEY WERE GET AWAY WITH IT.
THIS CALL HAS. DUE TO CO IN
NINETEEN. AND OUR INABILITY TO
GAP FOR LAW SCALE UP LIKE WE
USED TO. WE STRONGLY URGE YOU I.
PRESIDENT SO THAT THE KEEP WHO
ARE. FOR DUMP SOLID IN OUR
NEIGHBOR. ARE PART JUSTICE BUT
ALSO FOR PEOPLE WHO ALLOW THEIR
ON. POT TO CREATE A LEGAL
COMPLIANCE ARE ALSO RISK. FOR
OUR HEALTH. MY TWO DAUGHTERS
AND THE CHILDREN OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA DESERVE A CLEAN
AND HEALTHY PLACE GROW UP.
THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE MATTER
UP YOUR COMMITTEE TODAY AND
I'LL. ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MAY HAVE. THANK ARE THERE ANY
OTHER WITNESS. OF IN. THE
HEARING. ANY WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT THERE ON VIDEO
TELECONFERENCING. MISTER
MODERATOR YOU MAY NOW OPEN UP
TO DIAL IN TELEPHONE LINES. IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU JOHN LEAVE ME
ALONE ON THE PHONE LINES IF
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN
THE CARE AND SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AND WE'LL START
WITH NUMBER TWO FIFTY SEVEN TO
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF COLD WAR LIMóN ON
BEHALF OF. SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO NUMBER TWO SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS ROBERT SHORT WITH I HARDLY
COLLECT ANGELA AND SPCC AND I
AM STRONGLY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NEXT WILL BE
NUMBER TWO EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI GOOD EVENING MY
NAME HAVE AT THE ET I DID SPEAK
EARLIER- ON A DIFFERENT BILL-
BY ACCIDENT BUT I AM IN COURT
AB SB FOUR OH NINE AND I AM
WITH SPCC. THANK YOU. NEXT TO
BE NUMBER THREE OH SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THREE A SIX LINE IS
OPEN. WELL YES WE CAN HEAR YOU
ARE PERFECT HI THIS MONEY WILL
HAVE AND I AM IN COURT- LOOK AT
THE V. P. THANK YOU. THE NEXT
TO GO TO NUMBER TWO SEVENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS TINA LOUISE I'M FROM
THE SPCC COMMUNITY AND I'M IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
NEXT WE NUMBER TWO NINETY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HOW MANY VETS
WON'T. HE BEDROOMS AND A
COMPLIMENT I DON'T THINK STRONG
SUPPORT A MINUTE AB HOTEL NINE
THANK YOU. VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
KANAGA NUMBER THREE SIXTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS LISA RIVERA AND I'M CALLING
FROM S. B. C. C. AND I'M A
STRONG SUPPORTER OF AT THE FORO%
NINE. THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
TO A NUMBER TWENTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MY NAME
IS TO THE INTERCOM I'M CALLING
FROM SB FIFTY AND I'M CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR OH NINE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. EXCELLENT
NUMBER TWO NINETY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING THIS IS
MICHELLE THOMAS SHOP
REPRESENTING ALAMEDA COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR YOUR THE NUMBER
THREE EIGHTEEN AND PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME MY NAME IS
JACKIE LIVING STYLE AND I AM
CALLING- FROM LIKE LA-
APPARENTLY GALLERY IN SUPPORT
OF SB FOUR NINE THANK YOU. NEXT
WILL BE NUMBER TWO SEVENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS MICHAEL I FOUND AND I
AM WITH THAT HE AND I BELIEVE
IN AND THE AB AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORTED THAT BEFORE AND I.
THANK YOU. THE NEXT TO BE
NUMBER THREE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO HELLO. WE CAN
OR IF. NAME AN ORGANIZATION HI
MY NAME IS. OKAY. I'M SORRY I
CAN'T HEAR YOU YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION ALEX. FIVE HELLO
MY NAME IS ALEX I'M WITH THAT
YOU SEE AN ONLINE STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR NINE. THANK
YOU ALEX. NEXT WILL BE NUMBER
THREE THREE THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS RUDY
MELENDEZ I'M A COMMUNITY
ORGANIZER IN THE COMPUTER WOMAN
TEN ALSO COORDINATOR OF I HEART
WILMINGTON AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB FOUR NINE. THANK YOU.
SIX OF THE NUMBER TO NINETY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS THAT OF CORTES AND BCC
IN THE CITY A WOMAN COMMON
STRONG SUPPORTER SB FOUR NINE.
THANK YOU. EXIT NUMBER THREE
FIFTY THREE THREE FIVE THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING
MY NAME IS BILLY HARRIS I
REPRESENT SPCC AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. FOUR NINE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. SERIAL
NUMBER THREE FIFTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS THAT
IS THAT THE MODEL AND- I
PRESENT THAT PPP THEN I AM
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB FOUR OH
NINE. THANK YOU. NEXT WOULD BE
NUMBER THREE FIFTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SH HI THIS IS
GABRIELLE LEYVA I AM WITH THIS
B. C. C. AND I SUPPORT SB FOUR
NINE. THANK YOU. X. WOULD BE TO
NINETY ONE TO NINETY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS ON THE
NETWORK MEDICAL AYE WE PRETEND
AS IF YOU SEE AND I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB FOUR NINE.
EXHIBIT NUMBER TWO EIGHTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
CANDICE REHNQUIST I AM A
COMMUNITY MEMBER AND LIKE LOS
ANGELES AND ALSO A MEMBER OF
AYE HARTLEY KELLY I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB FOUR NINE THANK YOU.
NEXT YEAR THE NUMBER THREE
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS LOADED BUT I DON'T I
AM FROM SB FIFTY AND I SUPPORT
THE BILL S. FOUR OH NINE. THE
NEXT ORDER NUMBER THREE FIVE
NINE THREE FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD EVENING MY NAME
IS AMIN A MARTINEZ AND I'M LOOK
AT FIFTY THREE AND I'M CALLING
FOR SB FORTY FOUR IS DOWN YOU.
THE NEXT SERVER NUMBER TWO FOUR
ZERO THREE ZERO HAD THAT RIGHT
LIKE. HI MY NAME IS JUAN
GONZALEZ HI AND WITH S. B. C.
AND I SUPPORT SB FOREIGN ACT.
EXCUSE NUMBER TWO OH EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES ANY OTHER
GUESTS WITH S. B. C. C. AND I
SUPPORT AS BEFORE NINE. WILL
NOW GO TO NUMBER ONE NINETY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS CLARK
I'M IN AND I'M GOING YOU'RE
GOING THROUGH WITH SB FIFTY AND
I'M LOOKING ARE CONNECTED FOR
AYE HARPER WHAT STRONG BEING
SUPPORT SB OR ALL NIGHT. THE
NEXT TO THE NUMBER THREE
FIFTEEN THREE ONE FIVE PLEASE
GO. HELLO THREE FIFTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO YES WE CAN
HEAR YOU. HI MY NAME IS ANNE
LEVY THAT NUMBER I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF SB FIFTY ELEMENTAL
CHORD OF SB FOUR NINE. NEXT GO
TO NUMBER THREE THIRTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES WE CAN HAVE A
LOOK AT. MY NAME IS ANDREW
SANCHEZ I'M WITH THAT BTC I'M
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. BUT
NEXT WILL GO TO NUMBER THREE
THREE FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS GABBY BEHAR- A
COMMUNITY ORGANIZER WITH SB
FIFTY AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT AS
BEFORE ON NINE. THE NEXT TO BE
NUMBER TWO OH FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS MEGAN OF
THE ARMY COMMUNITY ORGANIZER
OUT IN THE OPEN ON THE VALLEY
WITH FTTC IN FAVOR OF S. B. O.
FOR PARLIAMENT. UNEXPLODED TO
NUMBER THREE SIXTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS SABRINA
FELLOW FROM SB THREE THREE AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL S.
B. BORROW NINE. BOTH NINE THREE
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE'LL
GO TO LINE OF THIRTY TO NINE
THIRTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MADISON BY ON BEHALF OF THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NEXT WILL LINE THREE FIFTY
TO THREE FIVE TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WELL THEY WERE SUPPOSED
TO HAVE YES WE CAN HEAR YOU
SUBMITTED WHAT. YES MY NAME IS
KEVIN AGAIN WITH S. B. V.
COMMITTEE ORGANIZER WITH I
HEART LIKE A LAND OF THE FARM
BILL AND- I'M FROM ONE. ON. NOW
GO TO NUMBER THREE TWELVE THREE
TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
MY NAME IS GABRIEL I AGREE WITH
S. B. C. AND TO BORDER SB FORTY
NINE. NEXT ILL LINE TO SEVENTY
THREE TO SEVENTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. OUR LOCAL TALIBAN
LEADER I'M WITH YOU YEAH I'M
LIVE IN BALI AND I AM PART OF A
BILL OR NOT. WE NOW GO TO LINE
THREE SIXTY SIX THREE SIX SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MY NAME IS ELI FOR NAY AND I
REPRESENT SB CHICHI AND I'D
STRONGLY SUPPORT S. B. FOUR
NINE THANK YOU. THANKS FOR
ADELINE THREE SIXTY FOUR THREE
SIX FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THREE SIX FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WE'LL GO TO LINE THREE SIXTY
FIVE THREE SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS KARINA
DEVINE AND I REPRESENT AT THE
CC AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOUR OH NINE. NEXT TO ALIGN
THREE SIXTY EIGHT THREE SIXTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS A LIGHT TOUCH IS WHAT
YOU SEE WHEN I SUPPORT SB FOUR
OH NINE. AND ONCE AGAIN THE
PHONE LINES IF YOU'D LIKE TO
VOICE YOUR SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO TIME AND. NEXT WE GO
TO NUMBER THREE FIFTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU. HI MY NAME IS ANNE LEVY
THAT ON BEHALF OF S. B. C. C.
I. SUPPORT SB FOUR NINE. HOLD
THE LINE THREE FIFTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
COLLEEN MALONEY ON BEHALF OF S.
B. C. G. I SUPPORT SB FOUR OH
NINE. GOOD A LINE THREE SIXTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO.
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU- I MANY
FISH CAN ALSO RUN- AND I WOULD
ACTUALLY SHE SHE AND I VOTE FOR
S. B. FOR ALL NIGHT. AND AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NO FURTHER IN
THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE
MISTER CHAIR. FOR YEAH HURRY UP
HURRY. ANYWAY THIS IS NOT. ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. OUR
INSIGHTS NO DON'T SEE NONE- OF
VIDEO CONFERENCING. AND MR
MODERATOR OR ANY OPPOSITION
THAT PHONE DID. WHEN GERMAN IF
YOU HAVE ANY OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AGAIN ONE ZERO
KAREN OPPOSITION. AFTER I HAD A
ADAM HARPER KELSEY I AM A- IT.
THAT WAS SUPPOSED TO CALL IN BY
PHONE. WE DO HAVE A MISTER
HARPER. ON THE LINE. OKAY LET'S
GO. SHARE MEMBERS ADAM HARPER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRIAL
MATERIALS ASSOCIATION OUR
MEMBERS PRODUCE ROCK PRODUCTS
ROCK CONCRETE SAND GRAVEL AND
ASPHALT TO HELP TO BUILD STATED
PUTS STRUCTURES SUCH AS OUR
ROADS HIGHWAYS BRIDGES IN STATE
BUILDINGS AND WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE JUST BEFORE NINE LAST
AMENDED. WE KNOW IT IS NOT THE
SENATE ATTENTION TO CRIMINALIZE
LAWFUL BUSINESSES AND LOOK
FORWARD O CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THE CENTER TO INSERT INTO
ENSURE SB PORO NINE DOES NOT
UNINTENTIONALLY DO STUFF THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY TODAY. THANK YOU. AGAIN
NOT OPEN ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. AGAIN IF YOU HAVE
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NONE
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE CONTINUE
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU ARE YOU
ANY. THE QUESTION IS BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE NO QUESTION JUST
A QUICK COMMENT A VERY PROUD OF
THIS BILL WE ARE FROM A
DISTRICT THAT HAS A LOT OF OPEN
SPACE AND THIS IS A BIG BIG BIG
PROBLEM SO THANK YOU SENATOR.
PROTOCOL OFFICE. YES. THE
PROBLEM YOUR WHICH OFFERS I'M
FROM A DISTRICT THAT DOESN'T
HAVE A LOT OF OPEN SPACE BUT WE
STILL NEED THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. I JUST WANTED TO
KNOW IF YOU SAID THAT YOU
ACCEPTED AMENDMENTS AND I
DIDN'T KNOW WHAT THOSE WERE. SO
THEY WERE THEY WERE NUMBER
THINGS- THEY WERE ONE TO-
REMOVE THE FINANCIAL PENALTY.
AND THEN THE SECOND ONE HAD TO
DO WITH THE- WITH THOUGH WASTE
TALLER DO YOU REMEMBER MISTER
CHAIR. NO I DON'T. ALL
LIABILITIES FOR THE WAY
STEINORTH NOW. OKAY YOU MAY
CLOSE SO I WANT TO THANK MY CO
AUTHOR FOR HIS GREAT JOB IN
GETTING ALL THE COMMUNITY
ORGANIZERS OUT TO TESTIFY
COMMITTEE TODAY SO THANK YOU SO
WOMEN LACKEY AS YOU COULD EAT
AS YOU CAN HEAR FROM THE
TESTIMONY IT WAS PEOPLE THAT
ARE SUBURBAN RURAL AND URBAN
THIS IS AS MENTIONED BY MR CORK
IS A STATEWIDE PROGRAM- PROBLEM
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. OKAY. SHARE
RECOMMENDED I. A CULTURAL. DOES
NOT IN FACT THAT THE BILL
SIMMONS IN SECOND AND ON SB
FOUR OH NINE BY SENATOR WILK
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS A
MANAGER THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER GENSER
IRAQI PROBABLY ARE LACKING HI
BARRICADE CAN. DEEP DEEP HI
KAMLAGER HI KAMLAGER I QUIRK
MORE WORK I SAN DIEGO. STONE.
THE MEASURE PASSED THE
GRADUATION PHONE WORLD FIVE
EIGHTY- I SEE NO. NO WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT AND NO WITNESSES
AGAINST THE DISTRICT GO.
MICHIGA REALLY QUICKLY SO
ANYWAY GOOD EVENING CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I FIRST. I HOPE SO
THAT'S GREAT ON EXCEPT THE
CHAIRS AMENDMENTS SO WILL BE
ACCEPTING THAT WHICH REMOVES
OPPOSITION FROM ACLU COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS IN
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL. AND AGAIN
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT JUST WILL
CLARIFY CURRENT LAW AND SO
JUDGES KNOW THAT THEY CAN
PRESCRIBE- AND EVALUATION FOR
SOMEBODY THAT IS COMMITTED-
ANIMAL ABUSE I IF YOU LOOK AT
THE STATISTICS 90% OF MASS
MURDER 71% OF THOSE CONVICTED
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND 50% OF
ALL RAPISTS. START WITH ABUSING
ANIMALS. SO WITH THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU- ANY WITNESSES.
IN SUPPORT CNN ARE YOU
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN THE
ROOM A REDUCES PORT ON TELE
CONFERENCING. AND ALREADY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT DEBTOR
DIALING IN. AND NO ONE TO BE ON
THE PHONE LINES YOU'RE IN THE
POOR PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. IN
ONE ZERO FOR IN SUPPORT. GOOD
THING YOU'RE NOT A CO AUTHOR
DISABILITY HAVE FIFTY WITNESSES.
HI AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NONE IN
OUR QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE
MISTER CHAIR BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE ANY. QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. JUST SHARE
WHAT THE AMENDMENTS ARE THAT
WERE TAKEN. IT. YEAH IT WAS I
MEAN IT WAS THIS IS BILLS FROM
LAST YEAR OR SO- BUT IT WASN'T
IN THAT I'M SORRY- OKAY YEAH I
DON'T KNOW I'M NOT TRYING TO BE
SO- SO THE SO THE RITUAL BILL-
MANDATED- COUNTY- AND IT'S A
PSYCHOLOGICAL EVALUATION IF YOU
HAD CERTAIN CRIMES ON ANIMAL
ABUSE SO NOW ALL THE BILL DOES
WHICH IS STILL HELPFUL IS IT
CLARIFIES LOCKERS JUDGES DO
HAVE THE DISCRETION TO DO IT
MANY OF THEM DO NOT KNOW THAT
THEY DO. SO THIS WILL CLARIFY
SO THEY KNOW THAT THEY CAN DO
THAT BECAUSE WHAT WE WANT TO DO
IS WE WANT TO CATCH PEOPLE
EARLY AND INTURN THEIR LIFE
AROUND AS OPPOSED ALLOWING.
THEM TO GO DOWN THAT ROAD. AND
BECAUSE GREATER HARM. OKAY AND
SO THAT WAS THE OTHER REASON
WHY ASK THE LAST QUESTION
BECAUSE WE I SAW THE ANALYSIS
BUT IT DIDN'T HAVE ALL THAT
YEAH MEDIA MOVEMENT-O'DONNELL.
ONLY FOR A BRIEF QUESTION BUT
IT WAS FROM LAST YEAR SECOND.
WELL ONE OF THE COMMENTS IN THE
OPPOSITION MENTIONED CANCELING
SO THERE WAS A DISPUTE- THERE'S
SORT OF A YEAH I WAS SPEAKING
WITH A DIFFERENT ONLY TWENTY.
HOUSE THINGS. EVALUATION NOW IT
JUST CLARIFIES LAW THAT JUDGES
CAN ASSIGN. AN EVALUATION THANK
AND ALSO STILL ASSIGN
COUNSELING. I DON'T THINK SO-
SOME OF WHICH IS THE VALUATION
YEAH IT WAS IT WAS IT WAS MUCH
BROADER WHEN I LEFT THE SENATE
THERE WHEN IT'S LEAVING HERE
BUT- IF IT MOVES THE BALL DOWN
THE FIELD ALSO I'M FINE WITH
THAT. OKAY ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
YES R. K. WHAT IS SO I GUESS A
CLARIFICATION BUILDING ON WHAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COMMERCE I MEAN
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THE
CURRENT LAW THERE'S MANDATORY
COUNSELING FOR THESE
INDIVIDUALS AND IT THIS REMOVES
THAT COUNSELING. NOW YEAH I
DON'T HAVE THAT RIGHT NOW. OKAY
ADDITIONALLY VERY HAPPY. OKAY
SO THERE'S NO CURRENT COUNTING
CORRECT SO THE OPPOSITION
LETTER FROM THE HUMANE SOCIETY
THAT. THEY JUST WANTED TO THE
COUNSELING I IT WAS MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT YOU'RE
REMOVING CANCELING MAYBE I
MISUNDERSTOOD. YEAH ABOUT THAT
BUT NO AT THE REQUEST OF THE
CHAIR SO IT WAS ORIGINALLY THE
RACIAL BILL WAS COUNSELING AND
VALUATION NOW WE'RE JUST DOWN
TECH CLARIFYING WHAT JUDGES CAN
ALREADY DO WHICH IS TO SIGN AN
EVALUATION SO I GUESS I WOULD
REFER BACK TO THAT LEGISLATIVE
COUNSEL'S DIGEST WHICH IS
EXISTING LAW REQUIRES THE COURT
TO ORDER THE DEFENDANT TO
COMPLETE COUNSELING. SO CURRENT
LAW DOES REQUIRE COUNSELING
ACCORDING TO THE LEGISLATIVE
COUNCIL'S DESCRIPTION. YEAH SO
IF THAT'S BEING REMOVED AND IT
IS ACTUALLY A NO I'M NOT NO I'M
NOT REMOVING ALL IT IS
CLARIFYING THAT ON THE
PSYCHOLOGICAL EVALUATION JUDGES
AT THE FORTY TO DO IT SO THE
DATA AND SAYS THIS BILL WOULD
DELETE THE REQUIREMENT THAT A
DEFENDANT GRADUATION COMPILE
ALL DOUBLE CHECK THAT. BECAUSE
I'M UNCOMFORTABLE WITH THAT I
KNOW THAT YEAH THAT'S FINE I
WILL I WILL DOUBLE CHECK AND
MAKE SURE THAT IT'S NOT.
CORRECT THAT WOULD GIVE ME
PAUSE TO. OKAY ANY MORE
QUESTIONS. CHURCH RECOMMEND I
VOTE YOU MAY CLOSE-
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
PHONE THE CHECK JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE I VOTE MEANT TO CALL
THE ROLL. ON SB FIVE EIGHTY BY
SENATOR WLCOME MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER GENSER IRAQI ARE LUCKY
AND BARRICADE HIM. BACK HE HAD
NOT VOTING DEEP. DEEP I
KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER NOT VOTING
CORK WORKING AYE SANTIAGO STONE
THAT MISSION IT MEASURES ON
CALL ALL RIGHT THEN THANK YOU
MEMBERS. AND THEN OUR LAST BILL
IS ARE YOU GOING TO RESCIND A
WOMAN OKAY OKAY SO WE NEED TO
GET MISTRESS. YEAH OF COURSE.
NO SANTIAGO. COULD YOU CALLED
MR SANTIAGO WE GET PLUS HE
NEEDS TO FINISH VOTING. WE THIS
TWO ITEMS WERE WAITING. ON SB
FOUR EIGHTY ARCHULETA KAMLAGER.
KAMLAGER HI. ON SB NANOFIBER
STILL WAITING FOR MR SANTIAGO.
AND S. B. TWO OR THREE
REMAINING FOR MR SANTIAGO.
FIFTY S. B. SEVEN THIRTY ONE
WAS WITHDRAWN FROM COMMITTEE SB
NINETY TWO WAS ON CONSENT SB
ELEVEN TWENTY THREE WAS ON
CONSENT. S. B. ELEVEN ELEVEN BY
SENATOR DORADO DEEP. OUR DEEP I.
SB TWELVE NINETY WERE WAITING
FOR MR SANTIAGO S. B. THREE I.
EIGHTY EIGHT WAS ON CONSENT. SB
NINE OH THREE WAS ON CONSENT.
ON SB THREE FIFTEEN THIS
MEASURE WAS ON CALL. OUR QUE
HAN. BEAR CANNOT VOTING DEEP.
WOULD WOULD THIS SB THREE
FIFTEEN. BOB HERTZBERG LARA NO.
NOW KAMLAGER KAMLAGER I WORK.
CORP HI THAT MEASURE PASSES BY
TWO TO. SB THREE SIXTEEN I WAS
WITHDRAWN FROM COMMITTEE. SB
SEVENTY TWENTY THREE WAS ON
CONSENT. SB ELEVEN TWENTY SIX
WAS ON CONSENT. SB SIX TWENTY
NINE MCGUIRE. DEEP. NUMBER
FIFTEEN MMHM A DAY I. DEEP I.
DO YOU WANT ME TO CONTINUE
ANYONE AS- LET'S GO THIS TO HIM
RIGHT NOW. I THANK YOU MISTER
HIGH RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE- ON SB TWELVE NINETY
THAT WOULD- THAT WOULD- NOT
REQUIRE THE COLLECTION OF
ADMINISTRATIVE FEES TO
JUVENILES CHARGED- TOOLS WHO
ARE TWENTY ONE AND UNDER HI
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR RESPECT
LAST NIGHT BUT THEN THAT WOULD
BE MY CLOSING AS WELL OKAY
THANK YOU- DO YOU HAVE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES. I DON'T
BELIEVE THEY'RE HERE BUT IF
THEY ARE- I WOULD I WOULD ALSO
REQUEST THAT THEY BE BRIEF.
OKAY LET'S SEE WHO I HAVE. I
HAVE A ANTI ROADLESS FROM USE
FOR JUSTICE AND APPROPRIATE
CODE UC BERKELEY LAW POLICY
ADVOCACY CLINIC BOTH IS
SUPPOSED TO BE ON THE FRONT.
YES IT IS CARLY WITH THE POLICY
ADVOCACY CLINIC ABLE TO HEAR ME
YES. HI THAT YOU WERE GOING
HERE BECAUSE MONEY COME ANTHONY
ROAD LET THE BUTTE JUSTICE
COALITION ABOUT HIS EXPERIENCE
WITH OTHER EUROPEANS BUT HE HAD
TO JUMP UP TO GO TO CLASS SO I
CAN GIVE A VERY. BRIEF
STATEMENT- PLEASE WHICH IS.
WICKED YEAH THAT IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA YOU WILL NOT BE.
CHARGED YOU TWENTY ONE AND
UNDER WERE OUTLAWED WITH THE
PASSAGE OF AT THE ONE NINETY
EIGHT- IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVENTEEN. A MAJORITY OF COUNTY
FORTY TO FIFTY EIGHT HAVE
VOLUNTARILY ENDED COLLECTION ON
NEARLY THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN NEED
OUTSTANDING FEES BUT THERE ARE
SIXTEEN COUNTIES THAT CONTINUE
TO PURSUE. ABOUT FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS AND YOU BID ON
FEELS BROWN FAMILIES
DISPROPORTIONATELY HARMING LOW
INCOME FAMILIES AND FAMILIES OF
COLOR AND PICNIC. NOW THAT THE
ECONOMIC FALLOUT FROM THE KOBE
NINETEEN CRISIS WE URGE AT THE
STATE TO PROVIDE FINANCIAL AND
EMOTIONAL RELIEF. THE FAMILY IS
THE- FROM YOU TO HELP YOU
REGARDLESS OF WHAT COUNTY THEY
LIVE IN AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE. THANK
YOU ORDER ARE THERE ANY. ONE IN
THE- CARE ROOM THAT HAVE ANY
HERE FOR TO. ANYONE ON THE
VIDEO CONFERENCING FOR SUPPORT.
AND MISTER MODERATOR DIALING
PHONES ARE THERE ANYONE COMING
IN SUPPORT OF TO DEVISE A BILL.
MISTER MODERATOR YOU STILL
THERE.WELL AS I WAS ON MUTE-
PLAYING GERMAN IF YOU'RE IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I WILL START WITH
NUMBER THREE SIXTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY AND COUNTY
OF SAN FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANKYOU. NEXT LEVEL
THE NUMBER TO FORTY EIGHT
PLEASE GIVE A- JERRY MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA
SUPPORT. THE NEXT WHERE THE
NUMBER THREE SEVENTY FOUR AT.
WHAT PACKET GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
THE NEXUS NUMBER FIFTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAPITA BARTOLO
WITH THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY WORTH FOUNDER AND
SUPPORT. NEXT YEAR THE NUMBER
THREE FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT
ALSO QUALITY OF JUSTICE
COALITION CO SPONSOR STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND THREE
SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. L.
A. WITH THE YOUTH JUSTICE
COALITION- COOK FUND FOR AN
OPEN TRUNK REPORT THANK YOU BUT-
NEXEO THREE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MARCO GEORGE IN
SUPPORT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION
THANK YOU SO MUCH. NEXT YEAR
THE THREE THIRTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. CALIFORNIANS WITH
THIRTEEN JEFF WITH STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. X. THREE
THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THREE THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MOVED TO NUMBER ONE
EIGHTY FOUR NUMBER ONE EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. DANIEL
GOOD CHAIRS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN SUPPORT.
THE SERIAL NUMBER THREE SEVENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. JIM
LINDBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRENCH COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
OF CALIFORNIA AND ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN'S
DEFENSE FUND CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU. NUMBER THIRTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ELIZABETH AND ALL
FROM THE LAW AND STRONG SUPPORT.
I'LL GO TO NUMBER FORTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH HI
ANGELA TURNER STOCK TRAINING
WITH PUBLIC COUNCIL INSTRUCT.
THE EXORCIST NUMBER THREE
SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO LUTEA MATTER- FROM CENTER
FOR RESPONSIBLE LENDING AND
WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. WE'LL GO TO LINE THIRTY
FIVE YOU'RE NOW OPEN. A LINE
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE MAKE SURE
NOT ON MUTE. MOVED A NUMBER
THREE SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OF THE MILLER POPPY AND
WITH YOU JUSTICE COALITION AND
STRONG SUPPORT AND COCKLES
BONTA. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO
FURTHER IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE MR THANK YOU ARE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. I HAVE
NONE HERE ARE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IN A ROW. ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ON THE
TELEVISIVO CONFERENCING. AND
NOW MR MODERATOR ANY WITNESSES
ON THE FIND FAULT PHONE CALL IN
LINE IN OPPOSITION. AND IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO WILL GO TO
NUMBER THIRTY FIVE LINE THIRTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
APOLOGIZE THIS IS MIKE A DOCTOR
OFF ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. AND AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO FURTHER IN OUR QUEUE-
PLEASE CONTNUE MR THANK YOU
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS. CNN MR SANTIAGO YOU
ARE YOU ARE YOU DID YOU CLOSE.
A CHAIRS RECOMMENDED AYE VOTE
WE MAY NOT TAKE. THE VOTE ON S.
B. TWO NINETY DORADO THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER HI JONES SAWYER HI
LACKEY. R. LACKEY HI BARRICADE
HAND PARA QUE HANNAH HI DEEP.
NO KAMLAGER WORK I WORK AT A
SAN DIEGO HI SAN DIEGO I STONE
STONE HI THAT MEASURE PASSES TO
PASSAGE. YOU CAN NOW GO WITH
THE. YES. WE WILL NOW GO
THROUGH THE MEASURES AGAIN TO
DO ADD ONS. AND LIFT ALL CALLS.
AND IF SB FOUR EIGHTY ARCHULETA
SENATOR ARCHULETA SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO HI THAT MEASURE PASSES
SEVEN TO ONE. SB NINE OH FIVE
ARCH SENATOR ARCHULETA SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I THAT MEASURE PASSES
EIGHT ZERO. S. B. TWO OH THREE
BY SENATOR BRADFORD TO SANTIAGO.
SB TWO OR THREE. YEAH YES ACT
BY SANTIAGO I THAT MEASURE
PASSED THE SIX TO ONE. SB SEVEN
THIRTY ONE WAS WITHDRAWN FROM
COMMITTEE SB NINE TWENTY TWO ON
CONSENT SB ELEVEN TWENTY THREE
ON CONSENT SB ELEVEN ELEVEN WAS
DISPENSED WITH AND WENT OUT
EIGHT TWO ZERO. SB TWELVE
NINETY DORADO KAMLAGER.
KAMLAGER I. SB THREE EIGHTY
EIGHT WITHOUT CONSENT SB NINE
OH THREE WAS ON CONSENT S. B.
THREE FIFTEEN BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG. HAS PASSED OUT OF
THIS COMMITTEE FIVE TWO. SB
THREE SIXTY NINE WAS WITHDRAWN
FROM COMMITTEE SB SEVEN TWENTY
TWENTY SIX WAS ON CONSENT SB
SIX TWENTY NINE BY SENATOR
MCGUIRE GETS OUT. SEVEN ZERO.
SB NINE FOURTEEN BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO DEEP. DO YOU KNOW
THAT MEASURE PASSES SIXTY TWO.
IDMS AND SKIS ME SB TWELVE
THIRTY SIX RUBIO WITHOUT
CONSENT. SB SEVEN SEVEN SIX BY
SENATOR SKINNER DEEP. DEPINO
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HI THAT
MEASURE GETS OUT SIXTY TWO. SB
TEN SIXTY FOUR BY SENATOR
SKINNER SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO AYE
THAT MEASURE GETS OUT OF
COMMITTEE SEVEN TWO ZERO. SB
ELEVEN NINETY SIX BY A SENATOR
BURKE STONE. STONE AYE THAT
MEASURE PASSES EIGHT ZERO SB
TWELVE TWENTY BY SENATOR UMBERG
STONE. STONE HI THAT MEASURE
GETS OUT SIX TO ZERO SB FOUR OH
NINE BY SENATOR WILK. BARRICADE
HAND. BARAKAT HI SANTIAGO SAN
DIEGO HI STONE STONE AYE THAT
MEASURE GETS OUT EIGHT TWO ZERO.
SB FIVE EIGHTY BY SENATOR WILK.
THIS MEASURE WAS ON CALL IT
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HI STONE
STONE HI THAT MEASURE GETS OUT
SIX ZERO. ON AB **** EXCUSE ME
AT THIRTY TO THIRTY FOURTEEN
THAT MEASURE WAS ALSO ON CALL
BARRICADE HAN BARRICADE HAD NO
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO. HI THAT
MEASURE GETS OUTSIDE TO THREE.
THAT CONCLUDES. AND THAT
CONCLUDES THE BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE MEETING.